♪
>> WELCOME TO THE MLB GAME OF
THE WEEK GAME SHOW, PRESENTED BY
TIME.
THEY'RE IN MILWAUKEE, WISCONSIN,
REDS AND BREWERS, THE TOP TWO
TEAMS IN THE N.L. CENTRAL.
IT'S COMING UP NEXT ON YOUTUBE,
AMERICAN FAMILY FIELD.
AND BIG YELICH.
PEDRO MARTINEZ IS WITH ME, THE
HALL OF FAMER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF YELICH
GETTING INTO A GROOVE RIGHT NOW?
PEDRO: RIGHT ON TIME, RIGHT WHEN
THEY NEED HIM.
THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS ARE GOING
TO DO SOMETHING DOWN THE ROAD TO
BE AS STEADY AS THEY ARE, THEY
ARE GOING TO NEED THAT GUY TO BE
HEALTHY, THE REST OF THE GUYS TO
GET HEALTHY AND PITCH THE WAY
THEY HAVE.
GREG: YOU SEE WINKER IN THE
CAGE, CASTELLANOS BEHIND THE
CAGE, THE BIG TWO FOR CINCY.
WIDE OPEN, AND YOU'RE STARTING
TO SEE THE CREAM AT THE TOP,
PEDRO MARTINEZ, MATT YALLOF,
PLAYING GAME TO OF SEVEN IN A
ROW AGAINST ONE ANOTHER.
THE SEVEN-GAME LEAD BY
MILWAUKEE, THIS COULD BALLOON.
IT COULD BALLOON IN ABOUT A WEEK
AND A HALF.
PEDRO: THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
SERIES FOR BOTH TEAMS.
THIS IS A MAKE OR BREAK KIND OF
SERIES.
I THINK IF MILWAUKEE ENDS UP
WINNING THIS SERIES, THEY CAN
CREATE A LITTLE GAP BETWEEN THEM
AND THE CINCINNATI REDS THAT
HAVE A REAL, REAL GOOD OFFENSE.
IF THE CINCINNATI REDS ARE ABLE
TO WIN SOME GAMES HERE, MAKE A
MOVE DURING THE BREAK, AND GO
GRAB SOMEONE THAT CAN PITCH
RIGHT ALONG WITH CASTILLO AND
SONNY GRAY AND THE REST OF THE
GUYS THEY HAVE IN THE BULLPEN,
AND THERE BULLPEN GETS A LITTLE
HELP, I THINK THEY CAN BE THE
ONES CHASING THE MILWAUKEE
BREWERS.
SO IT'S REALLY INTERESTING,
THIS SERIES, WATCHING THESE TWO
TEAMS GOING AT IT.
BUT I'M EXCITED ABOUT THE
MILWAUKEE BREWERS ROTATION.
MATT: AND THE BULLPEN.
WE'LL GET INTO IT.
RIGHT NOW, WE'LL SHOW YOU
HIGHLIGHTS FROM THE FIRST GAME
OF THIS SERIES, LAST NIGHT, AND
THEN WE'LL TALK.
>> BACK ON IT WINKER, CAN'T MAKE
THE PLAY!
WOW, WINKER WAS THERE AND HE
MISSED IT.
THE BREWERS TIED TO THE GAME.
>> 2-2 ON ON GARCIA.
LONG RUN NAQUIN, HE'S LOOKING
UP, IT IS GONE!
AVI GARCIA, TWO RUN HOME RUN AND
THE BREWERS ARE IN FRONT IN THE
EIGHTH!
MATT: YEAH, AVI GARCIA, BIG
GAME.
I WANT TO MENTION IT, REDS HAD
THE BASES LOADED IN INNING ONE
AND INNING TWO AND CAME AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
THAT GAME CHANGED EARLY, NOT
REALLY LATE.
PEDRO: THOSE ARE THE TIMES YOU
SAVE THE GAME OR GIVE THE GAME
SOMETIMES.
I REMEMBER PLAYING FOR PHILIPPE,
HE SAID SOMETIMES -- FELIPE.
HE SAID SOMETIMES THE GAME IS
NOT MADE IN THE EIGHTH INNING.
IT'S WHEN THE SITUATION CALLS
FOR IT.
AND I THINK THAT'S GOING TO DECK
EIGHT HOW THEY DO IT.
AND THE ONE THING IS NOT BEING
ABLE TO GET ANYTHING WITH THE
BASES LOADED, NOBODY OUT SAYS A
LOT ABOUT THE WAY MILWAUKEE CAN
PITCH.
AND THAT'S PROBABLY BEEN THE
STRENGTH FOR THE MILWAUKEE
BREWERS IS THE PITCHING, HOW
THEY GET DIFFERENT PIECES EVERY
NIGHT, CHIPPING IN.
IT'S HUIRA.
IT'S AVISAIL GARCIA.
IT'S ADAMES.
THEY HAVE DIFFERENT HEROES EVERY
SINGLE NIGHT.
AND IN CINCINNATI, THE TWO GUYS
THAT NORMALLY CLICK, WINKER AND
CASTELLANOS.
THEY GO OFER AND WE'RE NOT
GETTING ANYTHING FROM ANYBODY
ELSE, WE'RE IN TROUBLE BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT PITCHING AS WELL AS
MILWAUKEE HAS.
MATT: MILWAUKEE INDEFINITELY A
BIT OF A DOWNTURN NOW, BTU IT
HAPPENS.
HE'S BEEN SO GOOD FOR SO LONG.
WE TURN OUR ATTENTION TO ANOTHER
ASPECT OF THIS GAME.
DEVIN WILLIAMS PITCHED IN THE
GAME LAST NIGHT, ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR, GUPTA WIN  -- GOT THE WIN
LAST NIGHT.
STEVEN WILLIAMS HAVE SOMETHING
IN COMMON.
TELL ME ABOUT IT.
PEDRO: VERY SIMILAR.
THIS KID HAS ONE OF THE BEST
CHANGEUPS EVER.
FROM ME, YOU CAN PROBABLY EXPECT
TO SEE FASTBALLS ABOVE 95 THAT
GO ALL THE WAY TO 98.
THIS KID, IT'S NOT THAT HE
DOESN'T THROW 95, 96 MILES PER
HOUR.
IT'S HIS CHANGEUP, THE DIFFERENT
WAYS HE GRIPS THE BALL, THE
DIFFERENT WAYS HE VARIES HIS
SPEED ON HIS CHANGEUP.
SOME OF THOSE ARE 86 MILES PER
HOUR.
SEE THAT ONE?
FINGERS SPREAD APART.
THAT ONE LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING
TO BE ON THE PLATE.
THAT THING DROPS BECAUSE HE
OPENS UP THOSE FINGERS.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT.
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH 84, 86 MILES
PER HOUR.
ANOTHER CHANGEUP, THAT'S
DIFFERENT.
THAT ONE DROPPED.
THAT ONE TAILED AWAY AND
DROPPED.
THAT ONE, WHICH I WILL USE
AGAINST RIGHT-HANDED BATTERS, I
WOULD START OFF THE PLATE AWAY,
AND THEN THAT MOVEMENT WILL MAKE
A COMEBACK.
THAT'S BECAUSE I WILL OPEN MY
FINGERS THIS WAY, LIKE THIS.
I'LL OPEN MY FINGERS AND MAKE
SURE I DROP VELOCITY ON IT, THAT
I WILL GENERATE A LOT MORE
MOVEMENT AND DROP IN FRONT OF
THE PLATE.
THAT'S WHEN I WAS AHEAD AND I
WANTED NO MISTAKES UP OVER THE
PLATE OR AROUND THE PLATE.
I WOULD SPREAD MY FINGERS A
LITTLE BIT MORE AND LET THE RING
FINGER COME INTO PLAY AND
DROPPED THE BALL RIGHT IN FRONT
OF THE PLATE.
AND WE ARE VERY SIMILAR.
THIS KID HAS FOUND A WAY TO
MANIPULATE THE CHANGE IN
DIFFERENT WAYS.
ONE IS VELOCITY, YOU HAVE IT
AROUND THE PLATE WHEN YOU NEED
IT.
YOU NEED A CHANGEUP TO DISRUPT
THE TIMING.
AT THE SAME TIME WHERE THE
UMPIRE CAN CALL A STRIKE, THAT'S
WHERE YOU GO TO A REGULAR
CHANGEUP.
WHEN YOU'RE AHEAD, YOU USE THE
OTHER ONE THAT HAS A LOT MORE
MOVEMENT AND IT'S GOING TO DROP
IN FRONT OF THE PLATE.
MATT: AND HE'S ONE OF THE GUYS
WHO BRIDGES FROM THE STARTER TO
HEATER AT THE BACK END.
THAT'S SUCH A BIG PART OF WHAT
MILWAUKEE DOES ON THE MOUND.
WE'VE GOT TO MOVE ON TO THE POLL
QUESTION FOR THIS GAME HERE.
WHO IS GOING TO WIN THIS GAME
TONIGHT, GAME TWO OF THIS SET
BEFORE THE BREAK?
WE'LL HAVE RESULTS LATER ON.
IT'S VERY SIMPLE.
IT'S EASY.
YOU PICK ONE OR THE OTHER.
IT'S NOT FIVE OPTIONS.
YOU PICK ONE OF TWO THINGS.
WHEN WE COME BACK ON THE PREGAME
SHOW, AN INTERVIEW WI>> THIS G'.
HE HAS HIT BULLETS ALL SEASON
LONG.
WINKER UNLOADS.
>> RETRIEVE THE SOUVENIR.
>> THAT'S A BEAUTIFUL SWING.
>> WINKER SOCKS IT, AND IT'S
GONE!
HOME RUN!
SMOKED TO CENTER FIELD, THE REDS
WIN!
>> WINKER HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
CLUTCH FOR THIS TEAM.
>> THAT MAN IS A BALLPLAYER AND
ONE OF THE GAME'S ELITE
HITTER'S.
>> AND THAT IS PICTURE-PERFECT.
AND MILEY IS COOKING WITH GAS.
WADE MILEY CRUISING IN
CLEVELAND.
WIZARDRY FROM WADE MILEY!
A NO-HITTER, AND BASEBALL
HISTORY!
>> I GIVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
SHUTOUT TO MY SON, MADE ME WEAR
THIS HULK TATTOO ON MY FOREARM.
THANK YOU.
>> SENT HIS SON ON A MISSION TO
FIND MORE HULK TATTOOS.
>> YOU THINK THAT'S COOL?
>> YEAH.
>> MY BEST BUDDY.
YOU'RE MY BEST BUDDY, PAL.
♪
MATT: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW
PRESENTED BY TIME -- CHIME.
WE'RE SO HAPPY TO HAVE ALL-STAR
BRANDON WOODRUFF JOIN US ON THE
SHOW, TWO TIME ALL-STAR.
WHEN YOU HAVE AN ALL-STAR THERE
AND A HALL OF FAMER HERE, I SHUT
UP AND I LET PEDRO GO.
TAKE IT AWAY.
PEDRO: WELL BRANDON, WHAT A
GREAT LETTER TO HAVE YOU HERE.
I KNOW THAT THESE DAYS, YOU'RE
PROBABLY IN A HURRY TO DO YOUR
STUFF TO GET READY FOR THE GAMES
AND GET THE SEASON GOING, AND AT
THE SAME TIME, HAVING A LITTLE
STOP TO GO TO THE ALL-STAR GAME.
I'M WONDERING, TALK TO ME.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING?
BRANDON: I FELT PRETTY GOOD.
THE BIG CONVERSATIONS THIS YEAR,
OBVIOUSLY WITH 60 GAMES LAST
YEAR, HOW WE ARE GOING TO
NAVIGATE A FULL SEASON.
TO BE QUITE HONEST, MY FIRST
FULL SEASON WAS IN 2019 AND I
GET HURT AFTER THE ALL-STAR
BREAK.
I'M STILL TRYING TO BE HEALTHY
AND WORK THAT FULL SEASON THAT I
HAVEN'T DONE BEFORE.
AT THIS MOMENT, I FEEL REALLY
GOOD AND I DON'T FEEL LIKE I'M
BREAKING DOWN AT ANY POINT.
THAT'S A GOOD SIGN FOR ME AND
HOPEFULLY I CAN KEEP THAT GOING
FOR THE REST OF THE SEASON.
PEDRO: WELL, YOUR TEAM, I
CANNOT BE MORE IMPRESSED WITH
YOUR TEAM.
THE WAY YOU GUYS STRUGGLED,
BEING YOUNG, ABLE TO OVERCOME
BAD MOMENTS.
BASICALLY WITH PITCHING, WHICH
IS YOUR DUTIES AND THE REST OF
THE PACK THAT'S COMING BEHIND
YOU, RIGHT ALONG WITH A GOOD
RELIEVER IN THE BULLPEN.
HOW ARE YOU ABLE TO OVERCOME THE
BAD MOMENTS AND BE IN THE
POSITION YOU ARE RIGHT NOW?
YOU ARE THE TEAM TO BEAT IN THE
CENTRAL.
AND I'M IMPRESSED WITH THE WAY
YOU GUYS DID IT.
BRANDON: YEAH, AND YOU KNOW AS
WELL AS ANYBODY, IT'S SUCH A
LONG, LONG YEAR.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE THE UPS AND
DOWNS.
I REMEMBER SAYING EARLY ON IN
THE SEASON WHEN WE WERE GOING
THROUGH A BAD STRETCH, WE JUST
NEED THAT ONE GAME TO CLICK AND
TO GET GOING AND THE THING THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING REALLY WELL IN
THE PAST FEW WEEKS IS WE'VE DONE
ALL THE LITTLE THINGS RIGHT IN
TERMS OF PITCHING AND EXECUTING
ON THE OFFENSIVE SIDE AND
RUNNING THE BASE PATHS AND JUST
DOING THE LITTLE THINGS THAT
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THE GAME.
THAT'S WHAT LED TO THAT 11 GAME
WIN STREAK AND GOT US GOING ON A
HOT STREAK.
THAT'S THE THINGS CONSISTENTLY
GOOD TEAMS HAVE TO DO OVER THE
COURSE OF A LONG SEASON AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN KEEP THAT
GOING.
MATT: I'M WONDERING, DID YOU
BREAK OUT THE MISSISSIPPI TO
STATE SWEAT -- MISSISSIPPI STATE
SWEATSHIRT AND RUM AROUND
MILWAUKEE A B -- AND ROME AROUND
MILWAUKEE A BIT?
BRANDON: THEY WERE IN
PITTSBURGH.
I ALMOST SHED A TEAR WHEN I SAW
THE FINAL OUT.
THERE IT IS RIGHT THERE.
I TELL YOU WHAT, THE BEST FANS
IN THE COUNTRY, AND I DID A LIVE
INTERVIEW WHEN THEY WERE IN THE
TEAM HOTEL AND I COULDN'T HEAR
WHAT THE RADIO GUYS WERE SAYING
BECAUSE IT WAS SO LOUD.
AND I WANT TO SAY THEY SAID
JONATHAN PAPELBON WAS LEADING
THE CHARGE AND GETTING FANS
GOING IN THE HOTEL.
THAT WAS THE FIRST TEAM SPORT TO
WIN A NATIONAL CHAMPIONSHIP AT
MISSISSIPPI STATE AND ALL THE
FORMER GUYS IN THE BIG LEAGUES
NOW, EVEN THAT ARE NOT PLAYING,
ARE VERY PROUD.
I KNOW MISSISSIPPI IS GOING
CRAZY RIGHT NOW.
PEDRO: BRANDON, I WATCH YOU, AND
YOU LOOK SO POISE, SO MUCH ARE
ON THE MOUND.
WHAT DO YOU TEACH THE YOUNG
PITCHERS COMING BEHIND YOU, LIKE
PERALTA, DEVIN WILLIAMS, ALL
THOSE YOUNG KIDS THAT ARE
LOOKING UP TO YOU?
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE, DAILY, FOR
THEM TO KIND OF GRASP FROM WHAT
YOU KNOW AND WHAT YOU DO AND HOW
YOU GO ABOUT YOUR BUSINESS?
BRANDON: I TELL YOU, AND IT'S
STILL A LEARNING PROCESS FOR ME,
BUT EACH AND EVERY TIME YOU GO
OUT AND YOU GET INNINGS UNDER
YOUR BELT, YOU LEARN A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
BUT I THINK GETTING TO PITCH IN
THE PLAYOFFS IN 2018 AND THOSE
BIG MOMENTS HAS HELPED ME IN THE
FUTURE, AND STILL HELPS ME NOW,
TAKING IT ONE PITCH AT A TIME,
PUTTING EVERY BIT OF YOUR FOCUS
ON THE VERY NEXT PITCH AND NOT
WORRYING ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED THE
LAST PITCH.
OR ONCE YOU RELEASE THE BALL OUT
OF YOUR HAND, YOU HAVE NO
CONTROL OVER ANYTHING UNLESS
IT'S HIT BACK TO YOU.
I THINK CONTROLLING WHAT YOU CAN
CONTROL, TAKE A DEEP BREATH,
TAKE IT A PITCH AT A TIME AND
NEXT THING YOU KNOW, HOPEFULLY
YOU ARE DEEP INTO THE BALLGAME
AND GIVING YOUR TEAM A CHANCE TO
WIN.
MATT: AND WITH YOU, YOU'RE ON
YOUR WAY TO DENVER.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO YOU?
AND YOU ARE GOING TO GO SUNDAY,
THE FINAL GAME BEFORE THE BREAK,
SO ARE YOU AVAILABLE ON TUESDAY?
BRANDON: I DON'T THINK I'LL BE
AVAILABLE.
I DON'T THINK IT'LL BE SMART TO
DO THAT AFTER THROWING ON
SUNDAY.
BUT I TELL YOU, IT MEANS A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT.
IT'S JUST MAKING THE FIRST
ALL-STAR GAME, YOU'RE KIND OF
STARSTRUCK AND YOU GET IN A ROOM
WITH GUYS WHO HAVE FIVE, SIX,
SEVEN, EIGHT ALL-STAR GAMES AND
YOU'RE KIND OF SITTING IN THE
CORNER AND WATCHING AND
LISTENING.
BUT THIS TIME AROUND, I'M GOING
TO ENJOY IT BECAUSE YOU DON'T
KNOW HOW MANY OF THESE YOU CAN
GET.
YOU KNOW, IT'S JUST KIND OF THAT
VALIDATION OF ALL THE HARD WORK
YOU PUT IN AND KNOWING WHAT YOU
ARE DOING IS WORKING.
AND I THINK THAT'S PRETTY COOL
AND THERE'S STILL A LOT OF WORK
TO BE DONE TO GET BETTER.
BUT WHEN YOU GET TO CELEBRATE
THOSE MOMENTS, YOU TAKE IT ALL
IN AND ENJOY THE MOMENTS BECAUSE
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW MANY YOU'LL
GET.
JUST GO HAVE FUN.
PEDRO: BRANDON, ONE SMALL
QUESTION.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW, BECAUSE IT
LOOKS TO ME THAT EVER SINCE YOU
GOT ADAMES AND THE REST OF THE
TEAM STARTS TO GET HEALTHY, THE
TEAM SEEMS TO BE A DIFFERENT
LEVEL.
DESCRIBE THE ATMOSPHERE AND HOW
OPTIMISTIC YOU GUYS ARE ABOUT
HOW THE SEASON IS GOING AND
WHERE YOU CAN END UP.
BRANDON: OBVIOUSLY WE'RE PLAYING
REALLY GOOD BASEBALL RIGHT NOW.
AND WHEN WILLY CAME IN, THE
ENERGY HE BRINGS -- AND IT'S
GENUINE.
EVERY DAY, HE BRINGS IT.
HE GETS THE GUYS PUMPED UP.
I THINK THAT HAS GIVEN US A
LITTLE BIT OF A JOLT.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN KEEP PLAYING
SOME GOOD BASEBALL, AND WE STILL
GOT TO BUY FIVE MONTHS, THREE
MONTHS LEFT.
SO -- 2.5 MONTHS, THREE MONTHS
LEFT.
SO HOPEFULLY WE CAN KEEP IT
GOING.
BRANDON: THANK YOU, GOOD LUCK.
AND YOU'VE GOT TO STAY HEALTHY.
A LOT OF FUN, MAN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PEDRO: LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
YOU IN DENVER.
WHAT A GREAT MANAGER YOU GOT.
BRANDON: HE'S AWESOME.
THANK YOU GUYS.
MATT: TIME NOW FOR THE CREATOR
SPOTLIGHT.
AND THE SPOTLIGHT TODAY IS ON
THE FIREBALL REVIEW.
MOST CONTENT IS BASEBALL
CENTRIC, A HUGE ANGELS FAN, AND
THE GAME HE ATTENDED IN 2002 --
OF THE GAMES, PLURAL, GAMES
THREE AND FOUR OF THE ALDS.
THE FAVORITE MOMENT FOR JIMMY,
THE FIREBALL REVIEW.
HEY, GOOD TIME TO BE AN ANGELS
FAN FOR SURE.
WE'LL GET TO OHTANI.
YOU ONLY NEED ONE NAME.
IT'S SHOHEI.
MY DODGERS SAYS -- DAUGHTER SAYS
SHO-HEY!
YOU ARE AT OPENING DAY THIS
YEAR.
HOW WAS THAT?
JIMMY: OPENING DAY WAS
INTERESTING.
IT WAS A LITTLE WEIRD BECAUSE
YOU EXPECT IT WAS GOING TO BE
COMPLETELY FULL.
IT WAS ONLY HALF FULL.
IT WAS GREAT TO BE BACK AT THE
PARK AGAIN.
ANGELS CAME FROM BEHIND AND BEAT
THE WHITE SOX.
I THINK THE WHITE SOX ARE
PROBABLY GOING TO BE A WORLD
SERIES CONTENDER THIS YEAR, SO I
WAS FEELING GOOD ABOUT THE
ANGELS.
AND THEY'VE BEEN ABOUT HIGH
TIDE, LOW TIDE THIS YEAR.
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE EXPERIENCING
HIGH TIDE, SO THAT'S A GOOD
THING.
MATT: WITH SHOHEI OHTANI, HE'S
TAKEN BASEBALL NOT ONLY BY
STORM, BUT SPORTS WORLDWIDE.
EVERYBODY IS LOOKING AT HIM AND
SAYING WE HAVE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
AND THE TRUTH IS, WE HAVE NOT.
IN DENVER, THE ALL-STAR GAME, AS
A FAN, WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SEE THEM DO WITH HIM ON THE
FIELD, OFF THE FIELD?
HOW DO YOU WANT TO SEE HIM USED?
JIMMY: WELL, I THINK THEY'RE
ALREADY DOING IT.
HE'S GOING TO PITCH.
HE'S GOING TO HIT.
THAT'S EXCITING.
MIKE TROUT IS PROBABLY THE BEST
PLAYER, ONE OF THE GREATEST
PLAYERS OF ALL TIME, AND HE'S
NOT EVEN THE MOST EXCITING
PLAYER ON HIS OWN TEAM.
THAT PRETTY MUCH TELLS YOU
EVERYTHING ABOUT SHOHEI, REALLY.
MATT: AND AS A FAN WITH SHOHEI,
WHAT'S IT LIKE TO HAVE THE
BASEBALL WORLD FOCUSED ON YOUR
CLUB EVERY SINGLE DAY?
YOU CAN'T GO ANYWHERE AROUND
BASEBALL, ANYWAY, AND NOT HEAR
HIS NAME IN A CONVERSATION
ANYWHERE.
JIMMY: NO, I MEAN, NOT ANYWHERE.
IT'S REALLY INCREDIBLE.
I THINK THE ANGELS REALLY LUCKED
OUT BECAUSE THEY WANTED HIM TO
PITCH AND HIT.
EVERYONE ELSE WANTED HIM TO
FOCUS ON THE PITCHING, IF I
REMEMBER CORRECTLY.
ANGEL STEPPED IN AND SAID YEAH,
YOU CAN DO ANYTHING YOU WANT TO
DO.
I JUST WISH WE COULD GET SOME
PITCHING.
THAT'S THE THING WE'RE REALLY
MISSING OUTSIDE OF SHOHEI.
MATT: TRADE DEADLINE COMING UP
AT THE END OF THE MONTH.
YOU COULD HAVE BEEN THE NEXT
SHOHEI WHEN YOU TRIED OUT FOR
THE ANGELS, OR PART OF A TRYOUT,
ANYWAY.
TELL US ABOUT THAT, BACK IN
2016I BELIEVE?
JIMMY: WELL, IT WASN'T REALLY A
TRYOUT.
ANGELS DO A CANNED FOOD DRIVE.
THAT'S WHAT YOUTUBE REFERS TO AS
CLICK BAIT.
I PUT THAT IN THE TITLE.
I DON'T THINK THE ANGELS LET US
SWEEP THE PARKING LOT, LET ALONE
TRY OUT FOR THE TEAM.
BUT IT WAS STILL EXCITING.
IT'S A GOOD CAUSE.
IT'S A CANNED FOOD DRIVE AROUND
THANKSGIVING.
THEY DIDN'T DO IT LAST YEAR.
IT'S A PRETTY NEAT EXPERIENCE.
YOU CAN CHECK FLY BALLS.
YOU CAN HIT IN THE CAGE.
FOR ONE DAY, YOU'RE A BIG
LEAGUER.
MATT: SO I USED THE WORD TRYOUT
PROBABLY INCORRECTLY.
MY BAD.
I'M GOING TO TAKE THE HIT FOR
THAT ONE.
BUT FOR A VERY GOOD CAUSE.
LET'S TALK BASEBALL MOVIES.
EVERY FAN HAS AN OPINION, THE
BEST BASEBALL MOVIE AND WHY.
WHAT'S YOURS?
JIMMY: I'M GOING TO CHEAT A
LITTLE BIT, MATT.
I HAVE TWO CHOICES, "THE
NATURAL," BECAUSE IT CAPTURES
THE MYSTICAL FEELING AROUND
BASEBALL.
ROY HOBBS IS AN OLD-TIME PLAYER.
HE'S LIKE BABE RUTH.
YOU HEAR HOW BABE RUTH CAN DO
ALL THESE DIFFERENT KIND OF
THINGS.
I DON'T KNOW IF HE WAS MUCH
BETTER THAN THE PLAYERS TODAY.
BUT ROY HOBBS, YOU GET THE
FEELING THAT'S WHAT THE PLAYERS
THAN WOULD BE LIKE.
THE SECOND IS "MAJOR LEAGUE,"
BECAUSE IT HAS DRAMA, COMEDY,
ACTION.
BOB UECKER IS A NATIONAL
TREASURE.
HE SHOULD HAVE WON AN OSCAR FOR
THAT MOVIE.
THE ENDING WHERE JAKE TAYLOR
CALLS HIS SHOT AND THE THIRD
BASEMAN FOR THE YANKEES IS
PLAYING WAY BACK, HE BUNTS.
EVERYTHING IS IN SLOW MOTION.
WILLIE MAYS COMES HOME TO SCORE.
THAT MOVIE IS LEGENDARY.
MATT: I'M GOING WITH "BAD NEWS
BEARS" FOR ME, BECAUSE IT'S
RIGHT IN MY WHEELHOUSE, A
DEVICE.A
AND IN ESSENCE, IT WASN'T ABOUT
BASEBALL.
THEY USED IT AS A VEHICLE TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING ON AT
THE TIME IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA,
I LOVE IT.
IT'S MY FAVORITE.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THIS.
FAVORITE MOMENT FOR YOU AT A
GAME WHERE YOU ATTENDED.
EVERYBODY HAS THAT ONE GAME, OR
SERIES WHERE THEY SAY I'LL NEVER
FORGET.
FOR YOU, WHAT WAS IT?
JIMMY: IT WAS 2002, THE ALDS.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY THOUGHT
THE ANGELS WERE GOING TO WIN THE
WORLD SERIES THAT YEAR.
THEY PLAYED THE YANKEES AT THE
HEIGHT OF THEIR POWERS WITH
JETER.
TORRE WAS THE MANAGER, ANDY
PETTITTE, MARIANO WAS THERE.
THEY CAME IN, WON GAME THREE
FROM BEHIND.
GAME FOUR, THEY JUMPED ON DAVID
WELLS.
I HAD NEVER HEARD ANGEL STADIUM
THAT LOUD.
WE HAD A BAD REPUTATION FOR
BEING A SOFT CROWD.
MY EARS RANG FOR THREE DAYS
AFTER THAT.
IT WAS THE MOST AMAZING THING
EVER.
MATT: I DO REMEMBER THAT AND I
DO REMEMBER HOW LOUD IT WAS.
THEY OBVIOUSLY WENT ON TO WIN
THE WHOLE THING INTO THOUSAND
TWO IN SEVEN GAMES AGAINST SAN
FRAN.
SO WE'RE GOING TO CHECK OUT
FIREBALL REVIEW.
JIMMY, WE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
JIMMY: THANKS A LOT, MATT.
APPRECIATE IT.
MATT: YOU GOT IT.
COMING UP IN OUR FINAL SEGMENT,
A STEP ON THE WALKIE THAT SHOULD
MAKE THE HOME CROWD -- WELL,
WE'LL HAVE TO COME BACK TO HEAR
YOU SHOULD FEEL.
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU WHAT YOU
SHOULD FEEL.
I CAN DO THAT BECAUSE I'M GOING
TO DO THAT WHEN WE COME BACK.
>> THAT'S ROPES TO LEFT FIELD.
O'NEILL'S SPUN AROUND.
BYE-BYE, BASEBALL!
NICK CASTELLANOS LAUNCHES A
TWO-RUN TATER AND THE REDS GET A
COUPLE MORE BACK.
IT'S 7-2.
>> YOU SEE A LITTLE TROT RIGHT
THERE, LIKE A LITTLE DEION
SANDERS, A LITTLE PRIME TIME AND
A BAT FLIP.
♪
MATT: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK PREGAME SHOW,
PRESENTED BY CHIME.
TIME FOR PICK TO CLICK,
PRESENTED BY BETMGM.
HALL OF FAMER PEDRO MARTINEZ,
WHICH TEAM IS GOING TO WIN THE
N.L. CENTRAL?
PEDRO: I HAVE TO SAY THE
MILWAUKEE BREWERS.
WHY?
BECAUSE THE NEXT TEAM BEHIND
THEM, I DON'T SEE THEM MOVING
THAT HARD TO GET THE PITCHING
THEY NEED.
AND MILWAUKEE HAS ALL THE
PITCHING AND THE KEY PIECES FROM
THEIR OFFENSE COMING TO BE
HEALTHY.
MATT: AND YOU SEE THE ODDS.
THEY'RE -800, SO I AGREE WITH
YOU.
I'LL TELL YOU SOMETHING.
SINCE DIVISIONS BEGAN, TEAMS
WITH A SEVEN-GAME LEAD OR
GREATER AFTER 89 GAMES, WHICH IS
WHAT MILWAUKEE HAS PLAYED, HAVE
ONLY MISSED THE FORCE --
POSTSEASON FOUR TIMES.
SO IF YOU LIKE MILWAUKEE, YOU'RE
IN GOOD SHAPE.
ALL ABOUT PITCHING.
DO THAT AGAIN REAL QUICK.
PITCHING.
I LIKE THAT.
WILL A BREWERS PICTURE WHEN THE
-- WIN THE N.L. CY YOUNG AWARD?
PEDRO: IT'S GOING TO BE HARD TO
SEE ONE OF THEM IS GOING TO WIN
IT GIVEN THE YOUR JACOB DEGROM
IS HAVING.
BUT THEY'RE PROBABLY GOING TO
HAVE THE RUNNER-UP.
MATT: I AGREE, THEY MIGHT HAVE
THE RUNNER-UP AND NUMBER THREE,
POSSIBLY WHEELER SOMEWHERE IN
THERE.
SO THE ANSWER IS NO FROM PEDRO.
NUMBER THREE, WILL THERE BE OVER
NINE RUNS SCORED TONIGHT IN THE
REDS-BREWERS GAME RIGHT HERE?
PEDRO: I WOULD PROBABLY SAY YES.
I WOULD SAY YES TO THAT ONE.
COUPLE OF GUYS GOING OUT THERE
WITH TEAMS THAT CAN BOP.
CINCINNATI CAN BOP.
AND MILWAUKEE IS SCORING A LOT
OF RUNS.
I EXPECT THOSE RUNS TO BE OUT
THERE.
MATT: OVER NINE FROM PEDRO.
AND FINALLY, WHO IS GOING TO WIN
THE GAME THIS EVENING?
PEDRO: I'M TILL -- PICKING
MILWAUKEE.
MATT: AGAIN?
PEDRO: I'M GOING MILWAUKEE.
MATT: THEY HAVE BEEN OUT OF
CONTROL.
WHEN YOU GET ON A ROLL LIKE
THAT, THEY THINK THEY'RE GOING
TO WIN.
PEDRO: THEY GET CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM EVERYBODY.
THEY'RE GETTING HEALTHY.
EVERYTHING IS JUST CLICKING FOR
THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS.
I HAVE A PRETTY GOOD FEELING
THEY'RE GOING TO WIN THIS GAME.
MATT: OK, SO THE POLL RESULTS,
LET'S MOVE ONTO THAT.
YOU LIKE MILWAUKEE TO WIN.
AND IT LOOKS LIKE THE FOLKS
AGREE WITH YOU, 50% -- 57%
AGREE.
AND IT REALLY WOULD NOT BE FAIR
IF WE DIDN'T DIVE IN A LITTLE
BIT TO WILLY ADAMES BECAUSE
WILLY ADAMES, WE SAW HIM FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS IN TAMPA BAY,
PLAYING IN THAT DON'T.
I  -- THAT DOME.
I READ SOMETHING INTRIGUING.
HE SAID ONE OF THE DIFFERENCES
IN MILWAUKEE -- HE'S BEEN ON
FIRE -- HIS CONFIDENCE.
ANTI-TALKED ABOUT THE LIGHTING
IN THE DOME -- AND HE TALKED
ABOUT THE LIGHTING IN THE DOME,
HE HAD A MAJOR ISSUE PICKING UP
SPIN.
HE GETS TO MILWAUKEE, WHOE
DIFFERENTL -- WHOLE DIFFERENT
DEAL.
PEDRO: THE CONFIDENCE, HE
DOESN'T HAVE ANYBODY CHASING
HIM.
WANDER FRANCO WAS ALWAYS ON THE
LOOP BEHIND HIM, AND THAT'S WHY
THEY TRADED HIM BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT SO HIGH ABOUT WANDER
FRANCO AND BRUJAN AND OTHER
PROSPECTS THAT I DON'T THINK
ADAMES EVER FELT COMFORTABLE
ABOUT SAYING I'M THE SHORTSTOP
OF THE FUTURE.
NOW, WHEN HE LANDED IN
MILWAUKEE, I THINK MILWAUKEE
TOLD HIM YOU ARE THE SHORTSTOP
OF OUR FUTURE.
HERE, YOU HAVE IT.
AND NOW HE CAN PLAY WITHOUT
HAVING TO THINK, WHO'S COMING
AFTER ME?
AND NOT ONLY THAT, I HAVE TO BE
RIGHT ALONG WITH ADAMES.
THE DOME IN TAMPA HAS TO GO.
THAT'S PROBABLY THE WORST FIELD
IN ALL OF BASEBALL.
MATT: LIGHTING IS A PROBLEM.
PEDRO: THE LIGHTING IS A
PROBLEM.
THE ROOF IS A PROBLEM.
IT LEAKS.
IT'S HARD.
IT'S UNCOMFORTABLE FOR
EVERYBODY.
THAT DOME HAS TO GO.
AND GOING TO MILWAUKEE WITH A
PRETTY GOOD STADIUM, ALMOST
BRAND-NEW STADIUM, AND THE
LIGHTING AND EVERYTHING IS SET
FOR HIM TO HIT, I MEAN, PERFECT
PLACE FOR HIM.
MATT: AND HE'S REALLY EXPLODING.
YOU SEE THE SCENE.
THEY'RE GETTING IT READY FOR YOU
IN MILWAUKEE.
FINAL THOUGHT FROM YOU IN 15
SECONDS.
GO.
PEDRO: WELL, I EXPECT THE
MILWAUKEE BREWERS TO HOLD ONTO
THE CENTRAL AND NOT GIVE IT UP.
PITCHING, HEALTHY, PERFECT.
MATT: ALRIGHT, SO THIS IS GAME
TWO OF SEVEN IN A ROW BEFORE AND
AFTER THE BREAK BETWEEN THESE
TWO TEAMS.
AND THE REDS BETTER MAKE SOME
HAY AND DO IT QUICKLY.
THE GAME IS COMING UP, STEPHEN
NELSON, DANSAC, DANNY
GRAVES, AND JON MOROSI.
I MATT YALLOF, ENJOY.
>> HERE'S THE PITCH.
>> HE DRIVES IT DEEP!
>> WHAT A PLAY!
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
OH, MY!
STEPHEN: HAPPY FRIDAY FROM THE
GOOD LAND FOR A GOOD GAME.
I MEAN A REALLY GOOD GAME, A
PIVOTABLE SERIES.
THAT'S WHITE WE'RE TAKING YOU
OUT TO THE SITE OF THIS MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE,
PRESENTED BY CHIME.
THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS, THE
RED-HOT CREW WITH A FULL
SEVEN-GAME LEAD HOSTING THAT
TEAM THAT'S CHASING THEM, THE
CINCINNATI REDS, FOR GAME TWO
WITHIN THE SEVEN-GAME SET.
RIGHT NOW, FOCUS ON THE DAN
LIST, DANNY GRAVES, DAN PLESAC.
WE'LL INTRODUCE YOU TO JON
MOROSI IN A LITTLE BIT.
WE WANT TO FIRST SAY HEIGHT TO
THE YOUTUBE FAMILY THAT IS
WATCHING US HERE.
A LOT OF PEOPLE MAY BE VETERANS
OF THIS BECAUSE LAST YEAR, IT
WAS 2 MILLION FANS SUBSCRIBING.
NOW IT'S MORE THAN 3 MILLION.
EVERYBODY SUBSCRIBE TO THE
CHANNEL.
YOU CAN CLICK THE BELL ICON AND
THAT MEANS YOU WILL GET
NOTIFICATIONS PRIOR TO UPCOMING
GAMES ALL SEASON LONG.
YOU GOT ALL THAT?
DAN: GOT AT ALL.
THIS IS A BIG SERIES.
THE LATE, GREAT YOGI BERRA ONCE
SAID IT'S GETTING LATE EARLY,
RIGHT?
AND IT COULD BE GETTING LATE
EARLY FOR THE REDS, THE
CARDINALS, AND THE CUBS.
MILWAUKEE COMES IN WITH A
SEVEN-GAME LEAD OVER THE REDS.
STEPHEN: IT'S BEEN A REALLY
GREAT RUN FOR THE MILWAUKEE
BREWERS, AND IT ALL GOES BACK TO
ONE DATE AND ONE ACQUISITION.
DAN: MAY 22, WILLY ADAMES.
AND IT'S HARD THAT A GUY THAT I
WOULDN'T EVEN SAY EARLY-SEASON
-- LET'S CALL HIM THE CORNER
POLL.
HE'S BROUGHT NOT ONLY A WINNING
ATTITUDE, BUT A CHANGE IN
ENTHUSIASM.
THERE'S A SHOT OF KESTON HIURA,
A COUPLE GOOD DAYS LATELY.
THIS IS A BREWERS TEAM THAT DOES
SOMETHING BETTER THAN NO ONE
ELSE IN THE CENTRAL.
THEY PITCH AND THEY CATCH THE
BALL, AND THEY ACQUIRED WILLY
ADAMES.
LOOK AT THE DIFFERENCE WITH
TAMPA AND MILWAUKEE, .197
AVERAGE OPPOSED TO .290 WITH
MILWAUKEE.
PLAYS A PREMIUM POSITION AT
SHORTSTOP.
CRAIG COUNSEL TOLD US THEIR
DEFENSE, THEY FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE FOUR SHORTSTOPS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE DIAMOND, AND WILLY
ADAMES HAS MADE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE AND ONE OF THE
REASONS THEY ARE THE FAVORITE.
STEPHEN: AND IF YOU DON'T WANT
TO TAKE DAN PLESAC'S WORD FOR
IT, LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS.
THEY DON'T LIKE.
THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS HAVE THE
BEST RECORD IN ALL OF BASEBALL
SINCE MAY 22.
THAT SAYS IT ALL FOR YOU.
AND WILLY ADAMES, WE ALWAYS KNEW
THAT HE COULD PICK IT.
NOW HE'S OUT OF THE TROP, HE CAN
SEE THE BALL A LITTLE BETTER.
GRAVY, I THINK IF HE WAS A
BREWER ALL YEAR LONG, HE WOULD
BE AN ALL-STAR.
WE HAVE THE REDS, TWO THIRDS OF
THE STARTING LINEUP IN THE
OUTFIELD, LED BY NICK
CASTELLANOS.
DANNY: WHAT NICK CASTELLANOS HAS
BEEN ABLE TO DO IS REMARKABLE.
YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS, THE
N.L. RANKS, TOP 10 AND JUST
ABOUT EVERYTHING, AVERAGE,
EXTRA-BASE HITS LEADING THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE.
HE'S DONE IT PRETTY EASILY.
COMPARED TO LAST YEAR, HE
STRUGGLED A LITTLE BIT WITH HIS
OFFENSE.
BUT WE ALL KNOW WHAT KIND OF
HITTER CASTELLANOS IS.
YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE
BREAKDOWNS HE'S HAD.
WATCH THESE PITCHES.
THEY'RE MISTAKE PITCHES BUT HE'S
CAPITALIZING ON THESE MISTAKES,
WHETHER A FASTBALL IN, FASTBALL
AWAY.
IF THEY MISS, HE DOES DAMAGE.
SO GUYS, WHEN THEY MISS OVER
THE MIDDLE OF THE PLATE, HE'S
PULLING IT FOR A HOME RUN.
, WHEN THEY MESS UP HE'S PULLING
IT.
HE'S CAPITALIZING ON EVERY
SINGLE MISTAKE THESE GUYS ARE
THROWING.
LIKE I SAID, DOESN'T MATTER WHAT
PITCH IT IS.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE A
MISTAKE, GET READY TO PAY FOR
IT.
STEPHEN: TIME FOR STATCAST,
POWERED BY GOOGLE CLOUD.
WE GO BACK TO 2020, IT WAS A
ROUGH YEAR FOR EVERYONE IN THE
CINCINNATI REDS LINEUP.
THE EXTRA-BASE HIT PRODUCTION
THEN TO NOW, A LOT MORE SUCCESS,
A LOT MORE PULL POWER.
HE'S GOT THE BEST HOME AVERAGE
IN MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
WE KNOW THAT.
THEY'RE ON THE ROAD RIGHT NOW.
HIS ROAD CLIP IS PRETTY GOOD, AS
WELL.
CASTELLANOS AND JESSE WINKER A
REPRESENT IN THE CINCINNATI REDS
AT THE ALL-STAR GAME.
WHO IS REPRESENTING US IN
MILWAUKEE?
J.P. MOROSI.
STEPHEN: -- JON: GORGEOUS NIGHT
AS NOW THE CINCINNATI REDS
TRYING TO PROVE THEIR MEDDLE
WITH JUST THREE WEEKS TO GO
BEFORE THE TRADE DEADLINE.
, INDEED THEIR QUEST FOR A
SECOND STRAIGHT POSTSEASON BERTH
REACHING A CRITICAL STAGE IN
THIS BALLPARK HERE, JUST 50
MILES NORTH OF THE U.S. NAVAL
STATION GREAT LAKES.
THE QUEST FOR A SECOND STRAIGHT
RED OCTOBER GROWING MORE
CHALLENGING BY THE DAY AS YOU
CONSIDER THE TEAMS THE REDS MUST
NOW CONTEND WITH HERE IN THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE CENTRAL AND THE
N.L. WILD-CARD RACE, BEAUTIFUL
ANIMATION BUILT FOR US BY A
CINCY CAMP, SHOWING JUST WHAT IS
AHEAD FOR THE CINCINNATI REDS.
THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO, AT
TIMES, STOCK UP PRETTY WELL
AGAINST THEIR COMPETITION IN THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE.
BUT IN THIS DIVISION, THE N.L.
CENTRAL, THE BREWERS PLAY GREAT
BASEBALL, SEVEN GAMES CLEAR OF
THE REDS.
ONLY TWO TEAMS IN THE N.L., THE
DODGERS AND THE GIANTS, HAVE
BETTER RECORDS THAN THE
MILWAUKEE BREWERS.
THE REDS HAVE ONE THING ON THEIR
SITE.
THEY'RE THE ONLY TEAM IN
BASEBALL WITH TWO DIFFERENT
OUTFITTERS IN THE STARTING LABS
FOR TUESDAY'S MIDSUMMER CLASSIC
BAKERSFIELD, NICHOLAS
CASTELLANOS AND JESSE WINKER,
BOTH IN THE NATIONAL LEAGUE
NIGHT.
THEY BOTH BAT IN THE TOP OF THE
FIRST INNING.
STEPHEN NELSON, DANNY GRAVES,
DAN PLESAC ON THE CALL NEXT.
>> JUST BEYOND THE OUTSTRETCHED
GLOVE OF TORRE US, MILEY SCORES
AND REMOVES THE HELMET.
MCCUTCHEN THROW FROM LEFT TO THE
PLATE, WINKER SLIDES IN SAFE,
TWO RUN SINGLE FOR CASTELLANOS.
IN THE AIR, STUMBLED START FOR
HERRERA, STREAKS BACK, GONE!
A GRAND SLAM!
BELIEVE IN NICK CASTELLANOS.
WELL HIT TO LEFT.
THAT'S DOWN, A BASE HIT.
STORMS THROUGH SECOND.
ALL GATHERED BY MCCUTCHEN, WAVE
IS ON FOR INDIA, HEADLONG SLIDE,
SAFE!
BACKSLIDE CASTELLANOS TO THIRD.
HE HAS DRIVEN IN SEVEN RUNS.
CASTELLANOS DRILLS IT TO RIGHT
FIELD.
AND OUT OF HERE!
HOME RUN NICK CASTELLANOS!
THE M.V.P. CAMPAIGN CONTINUES.
UP THE MIDDLE.
INTO CENTER FIELD.
INDIA TURNS AND HOLDS.
FIRE IN FROM BRYANT AND A TWO
OUT HIT FROM CASTELLANOS.
STEPHEN: LET'S KEEP IT ROLLING
ON THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE
ON YOUTUBE, PRESENTED BY TIME.
I'M'S -- CHIME.
I'M STEPHEN NELSON SPOILING THE
PARTY AS WE SHOW YOU THE N.L.
CENTRAL STANDINGS.
IT IS A COMFORTABLE CUSHION FROM
MILWAUKEE AS IT STANDS RIGHT NOW
AND IT COULD BE EVEN BETTER BY
THE TIME IT'S ALL SAID AND DONE
WHAT THIS FOUR-GAME SERIES AND
THE THREE-GAME SET OUT OF THE
BREAK BETWEEN MILWAUKEE AND
CINCINNATI.
THE MANAGER FOR THE MILWAUKEE
BREWERS, ONE OF THE BEST IN ALL
OF BASEBALL.
DAN PLESAC, YOU KNOW HIM, FORMER
TEAMMATE.
DAN: HIS FATHER WAS COMMUNITY
RELATIONS DIRECTOR WHEN I CAME
UP WITH THE BREWERS IN 1986.
AND THAT GUY YOU'RE LOOKING AT,
AS A HIGHSCHOOLER, PLAYED CATCH
WITH THEM SEVERAL TIMES.
HAD NO IDEA ONE DAY HE WOULD BE
IN THE BIG LEAGUES.
GREAT CAREER IN NOTRE DAME,
SCORE THAT RUN FOR THE FLORIDA
MARLINS TO WIN THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
HE MAY GO DOWN AS THE GREATEST
MANAGER IN THE HISTORY OF THE
MILWAUKEE BREWERS.
STEPHEN: AND HE APPRECIATES THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF MANAGING A
HOMETOWN TEAM, AS DOES THIS MAN,
EVEN BELL.
DANNY: YEHA, AND LISTENING TO
CRAIG COUNSEL EARLIER, HE
MENTIONED DAVID BELL AND THE
BELL FAMILY AS ROYALTY IN MAJOR
LEAGUE BASEBALL, AND THAT'S WHAT
IT IS.
BASEBALL IS IN HIS BLOOD.
THEY ABSOLUTELY LOVE HIM IN THE
CLUBHOUSE.
IF YOU CAN'T PLAY FOR DAVID
BELL, YOU DON'T NEED TO BE IN
THIS GAME.
STEPHEN: LET'S SHOW YOU HIS
LINEUP THAT HE'S TROTTING OUT
THERE AGAINST ERIC LAUER OF THE
MILWAUKEE BREWERS AS LEADING
OFF, JONATHAN INDIA.
THE ROOKIE MIGHT BE THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR IN
FRONT OF WINKER AND CASTELLANOS.
DANNY: WHEN JONATHAN INDIA MADE
THIS TEAM OUT OF SPRING
TRAINING, WHERE DID THIS GUY
COME FROM?
THEY DIDN'T REALLY EXPECT HIM TO
MAKE THE TEAM, BUT HE MATCHED.
HE STARTED OFF OUT OF THE GATE
GREAT, SLOWED DOWN A LITTLE BIT,
BUT PICKED IT UP.
AND HE'S GOT THE BIG LEAGUE
CARE, SOMETHING WE'RE JEALOUS
OF.
STEPHEN: NOT A LITTLE MORE FLOW
THAN ERIC LAUER, WHO'S GOT A
HOCK GOING.
DAN: HE DOES.
AND YOU LOOK AT THAT E.R.A., A
COUPLE OF ROUGH OUTINGS, BUT
INCREASED VELO.
USUALLY WHEN A GUY COMES UP UP,
HE'LL BE SNEAKY QUICK.
USUALLY HIS CURVEBALL AND SLIDER
ARE BETTER, TOO.
HIS CHANGEUP NEEDS MORE
REFINING.
HE JUST NEEDS ONE OF THOSE
OFFSPEED PITCHES TO HELP GET
THROUGH THIS LINEUP.
STEPHEN: CALLED UP MAY 26, DOING
UP AND DOWN FOR THE MINOR
LEAGUES, JOINED THE BREWERS
SIX-MAN ROTATION.
CORBIN BURNES SCHEDULED TO JOIN
US LATER IN THE BROADCAST.
IF YOU HAVE A QUESTION, HIT US
UP IN THE COMMENTARY SECTION.
FIRST PITCH IS IN THERE FOR
STRIKE ONE.
WE'RE PLAYING BASEBALL IN
MILWAUKEE.
AND GRAVY WAS NOT LYING ABOUT
THE FLOW.
OUR MLB NETWORK ROBERT FLORES
CALLS HIM -- A NICHE REFERENCE
IF YOU DON'T FOLLOW 1990'S
REFERENCE.
TAKE MY WORD FOR IT, IT'S A
QUALITY REFERENCE.
QUICKLY BEHIND, 0-2.
FIGHTS OFF THAT PITCH DOWN THE
LINE INTO RIGHT FIELD.
WE'LL DO IT AGAIN.
SINCE MOVING TO THE LEADOFF SPOT
IN THE FIFTH OF JUNE, INDIA'S
GOTTEN ON BASE CLIP OF .429.
HE'S REALLY STARTING TO PUT
THINGS TOGETHER.
DAN: THIS IS AN INTERESTING
TEAM, THE REDS.
THEY ARE REALLY THE ONLY TEAM IN
THE CENTRAL THAT CAN MAKE A RUN
AT MILWAUKEE BECAUSE THEY CAN
HIT.
THE BREWERS,, UP UNTIL RECENTLY
WILLY ADAMES SHOT LIFE INTO THAT
OFFENSE.
THE CUBS HAVE SHOT -- STRUGGLED
OFFENSIVELY.
THIS CINCINNATI REDS TEAM CAN
SCORE RUNS.
THE ISSUE WITH THE REDS, THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO FIGURE OUT THAT
EIGHTH AND NINTH INNING.
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
STEPHEN: IF IT'S A BATTLE OF THE
BULLPENS, THE ADVANTAGE GOES TO
THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS.
DAN: SCOUTING REPORT EARLY ON
ESTABLISHING THE FASTBALL.
AND SO FAR, THAT'S WHAT LAUER
HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO, FIVE
PITCHES, FIVE STRAIGHT
FASTBALLS.
HE HAS A CURVEBALL AND A SLIDER
TO GO ALONG WITH THAT HEATER.
STEPHEN: 1-2 FOUGHT BACK AGAIN.
YOU SEE HIM GRIMACING, BUT
JONATHAN INDIA HAS BEEN PLAYING
THROUGH SOME MINOR -- NOTHING
MAJOR, MAKES AND BUMPS AND
BRUISES THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
IF IT WAS ANYTHING LONG-TERM
THAT WAS GOING TO JEOPARDIZE
HIM, WE WOULDN'T RUN HIM OUT
THERE.
BUT HE JUST WANTS TO PLAY THAT
BAT.
GROUNDER THROUGH THE RIGHT SIDE.
FELL BEHIND 0-2 QUICKLY, THEN ON
THE SEVENTH PITCH OF HIS AB, A
LEADOFF BASE HIT.
DAN: WHAT TO EXPECT FROM ERIC
LAUER, HE'S NOT AN OVERPOWERING
GUY.
NEEDS TO CONTROL THE HEART OF
THE ORDER, JESSE WINKER, NICK
CASTELLANOS, JOEY VOTTO.
ESTABLISH THE FASTBALL EARLY.
NEEDS EITHER THE SLIDER OR THE
CURVEBALL TO BE ON, PREFERABLY
THE SLIDER.
THAT SHOULD COMPLEMENT THE
FASTBALL.
STEPHEN: THAT SCOUTING REPORT
PRESENTED BY CHIME.
GRAVY, HERE IS JESSE WINKER, ONE
OF THE MOST LIKABLE HUMANS IN
MAJOR LEAGUE BASEBALL.
DANNY: HE REALLY IS.
HE'S DEFINITELY NOT AFRAID TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH ANYONE
HE WALKS UP TO, WHETHER HE KNOWS
YOU ARE NOT.
HE LOVES BEING AROUND PEOPLE.
IT'S AMAZING HOW HE'S BEEN
ATTACKING IT.
STEPHEN: WATCHES ONE THERE FOR
STRIKE ONE.
HE IS NOT KIND TO THE MILWAUKEE
BREWERS, THOUGH.
HIS SPLITS AGAINST THE CREW,
.391 BATTING AVERAGE, NINE HOME
RUNS, 14 DRIVEN IN, AND .844
SLUG.
THE 0-1 TO HIM FOULED BACK.
HE'S FIGHTING THINGS A LITTLE
BIT RIGHT NOW.
WHAT DO YOU NOTICE AS YOU WATCH
WINKER GO THROUGH HIS RELATIVE
STRUGGLES OF LATE?
FORGIVE US, SOME AUDIO ISSUES.
DANNY: I THINK WHEN HITTER START
TO STRUGGLE A LITTLE BIT, WE
SOMETIMES GOT TO GIVE CREDIT TO
PITCHERS MAKING ADJUSTMENTS TO
THESE HITTERS.
AND THEY GUESS A LOT, TOO.
THEY GUESS SOMETIMES.
JUST LIKE WINKER DID THERE.
STEPHEN: THAT WAS A GOOD PITCH
TO GIVE CREDIT, LIKE GRAVY IS
SAYING.
DAN: ONE OF THE THINGS LAUER
NEEDS TO DO IS ESTABLISH ONE OF
TWO OFF-SPEED PITCHES.
NORMALLY THAT PITCH, UP UNTIL
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS, WASN'T
CALLED A STRIKE.
YOU CAN SEE IT GRAZING THAT TOP
OF THE STRIKE ZONE, NOT AN EASY
THING TO DO TO GET JESSE WINKER
CAUGHT LOOKING.
STEPHEN: AND NOW IT'S NICHOLAS
CASTELLANOS.
GRAVY BROKE DOWN IN OUR PREGAME
INTRO, FIRST AMONG NATIONAL
LEAGUE OUTFIELDERS IN AVERAGE,
EXTRA-BASE HITS, AND RUNS BATTED
IN.
RUNNER ON, SWINGS AT THE FIRST
PITCH, INTO SHALLOW RIGHT CENTER
FIELD.
AND THERE IS TWO AWAY HERE IN
THE TOP OF THE FIRST INNING.
HERE'S HOW MILWAUKEE LINES UP
DEFENSIVELY.
YELICH, TAYLOR, GARCIA, LEFT TO
RIGHT IN THE OUTFIELD.
PETERSON, ADAMES, BARRIA'S FIRST
TO THIRD, AND LAUER AND PENA THE
BATTERY MATES.
AND NOW IT'S JOEY VOTTO.
I CAN'T SAY JOEY VOTTO'S NAME
NORMALLY.
I ALWAYS HAVE TO TURN IT UP A
LITTLE BIT FOR THE VETERAN, AND
ONE OF THE GREAT REDS EVER.
THERE'S SOME PAINT FROM LOWER TO
START AT ALL.
DAN: YOU LOOK AT THAT RESUME, 1,
962 HITS, CLOSING IN ON 2000
HITS, AND HE'S BEEN A STAPLE AT
FIRST BASE, MORE GAMES AT FIRST
BASE THAN ANY CINCINNATI REDS IN
HISTORY, AND THAT'S A STORY
FRANCHISE.
STEPHEN: THAT'S THE FIRST TEAM
IN THE HISTORY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL, THE RED STOCKINGS WAY
BACK WHEN.
THAT'S SAYING SOMETHING FOR JOEY
VOTTO.
DANNY: WHEN YOU SAY THAT AND YOU
SAY AGAIN, YOU JUST THINK I
CANNOT BELIEVE YOU JUST SAID
THAT.
BUT IT'S AMAZING WHAT HE'S BEEN
ABLE TO DO FOR HIS CAREER AND
THE PEOPLE HE'S STUCK UP WITH --
STACKED UP WITH.
THE NUMBERS ARE RIDICULOUS.
STEPHEN: HAS BEEN A MONUMENTAL
SEASON FOR HIM IN TERMS OF A
MILESTONE, 300 HOME RUN AT THE
END OF APRIL, ENJOYED HIS 1000TH
STEAK AT THE END OF JUNE.
AND HE'S GOING TO BE AN
INTERESTING CASE STUDY.
WE'LL LEAVE IT TO RYAN KENNING
AND OB -- BRIAN KENNY AND OB NOW
TO BRING -- BREAK IT DOWN.
HE'S DONE IT IN SOME WAY
DIFFERENT WAYS, HE'S EVOLVED AS
HE'S GOTTEN OLDER, ABOUT TO TURN
38 YEARS OLD IN SEPTEMBER.
2-1.
DAN: THAT'S WHAT HE DOES WHEN
HE'S SEEING THE BALL WELL.
THAT'S A GOOD PITCH BY LOWER.
A LOT OF HITTERS GET ANXIOUS IN
THE COUNT AND THEY WILL HIT MORE
LIKE A PITCHERS PITCH.
THAT'S WHAT JOEY VOTTO HAS DONE
SINCE HE'S PUT ON A REDS
UNIFORM, GREAT RECOGNITION OF
THE STRIKE ZONE.
DAN: AND THEY ALWAYS -- DANNY:
AND THEY ALWAYS SAID HE TAKES
TOO MANY PITCHES, BUT HE HAS
1000 CAREER R.B.I.'S.
HE WAITS FOR A PITCH THAT HE CAN
DRIVE AND IT FRUSTRATES ME WHEN
GUYS SAY HE TAKES TOO MANY
PITCHES.
STEPHEN: LOOKING AT THE
COMMENTARY SECTION, THE REDS
SAYING VOTTO HAVING FUN PLAYING
WITH THIS TEAM.
THAT'S A GREAT OBSERVATION.
A VETERAN PLAYER LIKE THAT,
ALWAYS HAD A GREAT PERSONALITY.
HE'S BEEN A LIGHTNING ROD FOR
THE CINCINNATI REDS, BUT NOW
HE'S GOT COMPANY AND SOME JUICE
AROUND HIM, CASTELLANOS, WINKER,
AND COMPANY, DRAWS A WALK WITH
TWO AWAY.
WE TALKED ABOUT A MILESTONE MAN
FOR JOEY VOTTO, A COUPLE BIG
ONES THIS SEASON.
DANNY: HOW ABOUT THAT?
THIS IS A GUY, HE'S BEEN ON THE
FIELD EVERY YEAR, PUTTING UP
GREAT NUMBERS, AND I KNOW HE WON
AN M.V.P., BUT HE'S QUIETLY
DOING IT.
A LOT OF GUYS HAVE HIT 300TH
CAREER HOMER AND 1000TH CAREER
R.B.I., BUT YOU DON'T REALLY
CARE ABOUT JOEY VOTTO UNLESS YOU
ARE FROM THE MIDWEST OR FOLLOW
THE NATIONAL LEAGUE CENTRAL.
HE'S A NAME THAT HAS A REALLY
GOOD CHANCE TO GET INTO THE HALL
OF FAME WITH THESE NUMBERS.
STEPHEN: NOW EUGENIO SUAREZ.
DAN: THIS IS THE PLAYER OF 2021,
WHERE WE TALK ABOUT THE THREE
TRUE OUTCOMES, THE WALK,
STRIKEOUT, HOME RUN.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE AVERAGE UP
.177, BUT 17 BOMBS AND 49
R.B.I.'S TO GO ALONG WITH IT.
A LOT OF SWING AND MISS IN THAT
SWING.
STARTED THE YEAR AS A SHORTSTOP,
MADE THE TRANSITION FROM THIRD
BASE TO SHORTSTOP.
HE'S BETTER THAN A .177 HITTER.
AND OF MR. LAUER ISN'T CAREFUL,
HE CAN TURN THIS ONE AROUND.
STEPHEN: IT HIT PINA IN HIS
WRIST OR HAND.
DAN: APPEARED TO BE ACROSS A.
HE'S EXPECTING THE BALL TO BE
CUTTING IN AND AWAY.
HE CAUGHT IT RIGHT ON THE
BAREHAND.
DANNY: THAT'S A HARD PASS FOR
ME.
DAN: ALMOST CAUGHT IT WITH HIS
PALM.
SOMETIMES THAT HAPPENS WITHOUT
WALK WITH A RUNNER AT SECOND
BASE.
OBVIOUSLY ACROSS UP.
MANNY PINA HAS HAD STRUGGLES
OFFENSIVELY, COUPLE OF BIG HITS
IN THAT METS SERIES, ONLY
HITTING .126 ON THE SEASON.
YOU HATE TO SEE THAT,
PARTICULARLY ON THE THROWING
HAND.
STEPHEN: GETTING CHECKED OUT BY
THE MILWAUKEE STAFF RIGHT NOW.
DAN: ANOTHER GOOD LOOK AT IT.
APPEARS TO BE A SLIDER.
IF ANYTHING, EUGENIO MAY HAVE
TICKED THIS A LITTLE BIT,
CAUSED A CHANGE IN DIRECTION.
STEPHEN: THE FACT THAT IT'S A
THROWING HAND -- IF IT WAS --
DAN: IT APPEARED TO GET HIM
SQUARE IN THE PALM OF THE HAND,
TOO.
STEPHEN: EVEN IF HE STAYS IN, HE
IS GOING TO BE FEELING IT
TOMORROW.
HE HAS THE LOOK OF SOMEBODY WHO
WANTS TO STAY IN THE GAME, ROUND
OF APPLAUSE.
DANNY: YOU ALMOST FEEL LIKE IT'S
BETTER YOU HIT HIM SQUARE IN THE
PALM INSTEAD OF ON THE FINGERTIP
OR ON THE WRIST.
STEPHEN: MAYBE HE'S TALKING
HIMSELF INTO IT.
DAN: THAT'S ONE TOO IF YOU'RE
ERIC LAUER.
ONE THING YOU ALWAYS WANT TO DO
AS A PITCHER, TAKE CARE OF THE
GUY PUTTING THE FINGERS DOWN.
I KNOW IT'S THE QUICKEST WAY TO
THE BIG LEAGUES, BUT YOU HAVE TO
BE A SPECIAL BREED TO PUT THAT
EQUIPMENT ON BEHIND HOME PLATE.
STEPHEN: NOW THEY'RE GOING TO
SINK UP THERE'S.
THERE'S A CONVERSATION, OMAR
NARVAEZ.
THIS IS WHAT YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT, THE CROSS UP.
DAN: EXPECTING THE BALL TO BE
DOWN AND IN.
HE TURNED THAT GLOVE OVER ALMOST
TO BE ABLE TO CATCH THE SLIDER
OR THE CURVEBALL.
STEPHEN: SHAKING IT OUT.
JON: HE SLOWED DOWN THE SIGNS A
LOT RIGHT THERE.
STEPHEN: TRYING TO GET FEELING
BACK.
LOWER THROUGH IT WHERE -- LAUER
THREW IT WHERE PINA WANTED IT
THERE.
TRYING TO CATCH A BIG-LEAGUE
PITCH BAREHANDED, DO NOT
RECOMMEND.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
NOW THE 1-2.
INDIA ON SECOND AFTER A LEADOFF
WALK.
AND LAUER PUNCHED OUT WINKER AND
GOT CASTELLANOS TO FLY OUT TO
CENTER FIELD BEFORE WALKING
VOTTO.
DAN: THIS HAS BEEN KIND OF THE
ISSUE WITH LOWER.
LANDING THE SECONDARY PITCH.
HE'S BEEN ABLE TO LOCATE THAT
FASTBALL, STRUCK OUT JESSE
WINKER ON A SLIDER UP IN THE
ZONE, BUT GETTING TILTED BREAK
ON THE BREAKING BALL.
STEPHEN: COMES IN ON SUAREZ.
WAS HOPING FOR A CALL HE DID NOT
GET.
DANNY: GOING BACK TO PINA, AFTER
GETTING HIT ON THE HAND LIKE
THAT, I KNOW HE'S OUT THERE
THROWING STILL, BUT THAT MIGHT
MAKE A DIFFERENCE WHEN HE'S
TRYING TO SWING THE BAT.
DAN: NO QUESTION.
I'M WATCHING.
IF I WERE HIM, I'D TAKE MY
BACKHAND AND TALK IT BEHIND MY
BACK.
STEPHEN: HIDING IT BEHIND THE
GLOVE NOW.
PLAYING CATCH.
AND THERE'S A STRIKEOUT TO END
THE TOP OF THE FIRST INNING FROM
ERIC LAUER.
THE BAT AND
DISCUSSED AS THE REDS STRAND A
PAIR.
IT'S WADE MILEY'S TURN TO TOE
THE SLAB.
WE'LL INTRODUCE HIM NEXT.
>> AND THE PITCH.
SWING AND A DRIVE INTO LEFT
CENTER AND DEEP, WAY BACK, GET
UP, GET OUTTA HERE, GONE FOR
WILLY ADAMES!
>> THERE IS ADAMES.
>> ADAMES IN THE AIR, RIGHT
CENTER, BALL'S HIT WELL,
MARISNICK ON THE RUN.
AND IT'S OUT!
IT'S A GRAND SLAM, THE FIRST OF
THE YEAR FOR THE BREWERS!
WILLY ADAMES AGAIN!
TOUGH PLAY, ADAMES FIRES AND IN
TIME.
>> CLOSE ONE.
>> MY GOODNESS.
THIS GUY'S SOMETHING ELSE.
>> DEVIL IS CRUSHED, DEEP --
THAT BALL IS CRUSHED, DEEP INTO
LEFT CENTER FIELD, ADAMES DOES
IT AGAIN.
A LONG HOME RUN.
WILLY ADAMES PUTS THE BROKERS ON
THE BOARD 1-0 -- BREWERS ON THE
BOARD WITH A 1-0.
ADAMES SHOOTS ONE INTO RIGHT
FIELD.
HE GOT JAMMED A LITTLE BIT BUT
MUSCLES INTO RIGHT.
IT'S A SINGLE AND A THREE-HIT
GAME.
THERE'S HIS FIRST BASE HIT, ALL
THE WAY INTO THE CORNER.
HE'LL STAND UP AT SECOND BASE,
SETTLING FOR A DOUBLE.
STEPHEN: HOW ABOUT THE CREW'S
LINEUP?
LUIS URIAS IN FRONT OF WILLY
ADAMES, ONE OF THE HOTTEST
PEOPLE ON THE PLANET, LAST 20
GAMES AT A .333 CLIP WITH 14
BASE HITS.
TYRONE TAYLOR, JACE PETERSON,
WHO HAS FILLED IN NICELY FOR THE
INJURED KOLTEN WONG AT SECOND
BASE.
KESTON HIURA, MANNY PINA, AND
FINALLY THE PITCHER, ERIC LAUER.
GRAVY, IT'S WADE MILEY'S TURN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF HIS SEASON?
AS HE STARTS OFF URIAS WITH A
BREAKING BALL DOWN AND IN.
DAN: MAY 7 A VERY SPECIAL DATE
IN HISTORY FOR WADE MILEY, THREW
A NO-HITTER AGAINST THE
CLEVELAND INDIANS.
NOT YOUR USUAL SUSPECT, NOT A
HARD THROWER.
CHANGES SPEEDS, BEEN AROUND FOR
A LONG TIME.
WHAT HE DOES IS HE BRINGS
STABILITY TO A ROTATION.
HE'S A GUY THAT DAVID BELL CAN
COUNT ON, 6-4.
BUT A VERY GOOD 3.06 E.R.A.
PITCHING IN THE BALLPARK AND
CINCINNATI.
QUALITY STARTER, YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE GOING TO GET EVERY FIVE
DAYS.
STEPHEN: ONE OF THE SEVEN
NO-HITTERS WE'VE SEEN THROWN,
2021.
DAN: HE REMINDS ME OF MARK
BUEHRLE, FORMER WHITE SOX
PITCHER, WORKS FAST.
HE GETS RIGHT BACK ON THE MOUND.
THE NIGHT HE THREW THE
NO-HITTER, TALKED TO SEVERAL
POSITION PLAYERS.
THEY LOVE THE FACT THAT HE GETS
BACK ON THE MOUND, GETS IT, AND
THROWS IT, KEEPS THE DEFENSE ON
THEIR TOES, KEEPS THE GAME AT A
GOOD PACE.
HE'S A FUN GUY TO PLAY BEHIND.
STEPHEN: THERE A PLENTY TO START
THE GAME, GRAVY.
DANNY: THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE TEMPO HE HAS ON THE MOUND,
THE WAY HE GETS THE BALL AND
GETS BACK UP THERE.
HE KIND OF LULLS YOU TO SLEEP
AND THEN GETS YOU WITH THE
CHANGEUP.
GREAT JOB OF PITCHING.
THAT'S WHAT WADE MILEY'S DONE
ALL YEAR, GET BACK ON THE MOUND
AND DELIVER THE PITCH.
STEPHEN: AND NOW IT'S WILLY
ADAMES.
BOTTOM OF THE FIRST INNING.
TONIGHT'S ODDS, CURSI BETMGM,
FOR WILLY.
TOTAL BASES, OVER-UNDER SET AT
1.5, PLUS MONEY.
QUICKLY BEHIND, 0-2.
I'VE TALKED TO WILLY A COUPLE
TIMES AS TIME CALLED.
SAW IT LATE, THE BALL FLUTTERED
TO THE GROUND IN FRONT OF THE
MOUND.
I WOULD DESCRIBE WILLY ADAMES AS
A STRONG GU -- STRAW GUY.
DAN: WHEN THEY ACQUIRED HIM MAY
22, THE BREWERS WERE 22-23, ONE
GAME UNDER.
WE SIT HERE THREE GAMES BEFORE
THE ALL-STAR BREAK, BREWERS ARE
SEVEN GAMES IN FRONT.
CRAIG COUNSEL TOLD US BEFORE THE
GAME HE WOULD HAVE TO BE ON A
LEADERBOARD FOR N.L. M.V.P..
HE HAS BEEN THAT IMPORTANT FOR
THE BREW CREW.
STEPHEN: ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
TWO STRIKES, TWO BAGS FOR
WILLY ADAMES.
HE'S A TOUGH GUY TO GET OUT
RIGHT NOW.
HOW DO YOU ATTACK HIM?
DANNY: IT'S MAG -- AMAZING
WATCHING ADAMES.
THAT'S NOT A BAD PITCH BY MILEY.
THAT'S A CUTTER, DOWN, IN A
LITTLE BIT ON THE HANDS, BUT
STILL ABLE TO GET THE BARREL TO
THE BALL.
HOPE THAT HE HITS IT AT
SOMEBODY.
THAT'S WHAT I ALWAYS SAY WHEN
THEY'RE HITTING EVERYTHING.
STEPHEN: CHANGE OF SCENERY
WASN'T JUST GOOD, IT WAS
NECESSARY.
HE HAS BEEN VERY OPEN ABOUT NOT
SEEING WITH THE LIGHTING AT THE
TROP.
IF YOU'RE A HITTER, YOU'RE DEAD
BEFORE YOU STEP IN IF THAT'S THE
CASE.
DAN: JUST AS SOME ARE MORE
COMFORTABLE THROWING ON
DIFFERENT MOUNDS, DIFFERENT KIND
OF SPLITS.
IF YOU'RE HAVING A DIFFICULT
TIME SEEING THE BALL -- WE
HAVEN'T HEARD THAT A LOT IN THE
PAST -- BUT HE HAD A DIFFICULT
TIME PICKING THE BALL UP.
NEW LIFE, DIFFERENT UNIFORM,
GETTING AWAY FROM THE RUMORS,
WANDER FRANCO, SUPERSTAR, NUMBER
ONE PROSPECT.
IT WAS A GOOD TRADE FOR BOTH
TEAMS BECAUSE FEYEREISEN HAS
PITCHED VERY WELL FOR THE RAYS.
THIS IS A TRADE THAT WORKED WELL
FOR BOTH TEAMS, BUT THIS IS A
GOOD MILWAUKEE BREWERS TEAM, BUT
IT'S A REALLY GOOD TEAM SINCE
THEY ACQUIRED THIS GUY, WILLY
ADAMES.
AND YOU CAN'T SAY ENOUGH.
WHEN YOU ACQUIRE A GUY THAT
PLAYS SHORTSTOP, IN THE MIDDLE
PART OF THE DIAMOND, HE'S A
TERRIFIC PLAYER.
THE KEY TO THE BREWERS GETTING
OVER THE HUMP, YOU'RE LOOKING AT
HIM IN THE BATTER'S BOX RIGHT
NOW, CHRISTIAN YELICH.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT M.V.P. GUY.
HE STRUGGLED LAST YEAR IN 2020
AND OFF TO A SLOW START SO FAR
THIS YEAR.
STEPHEN: WATCHES THE 3-1,
APPARENTLY CAUGHT PART OF THE
PLATE.
WADE MILEY AND EVERYBODY IN REDS
COUNTRY WILL CERTAINLY NOT
COMPLAIN.
DANNY: AND TO YOUR POINT ABOUT
YELICH NOT HAVING AS GREAT A
YEAR AS HE USUALLY DOES, THERE'S
STILL THAT THOUGHT IN THE BACK
OF YOUR HEAD AS A PITCHER THAT
THIS GUY WAS AN M.V.P. AND HE
STILL KNOWS HOW TO HIT SO YOU
STILL HAVE TO PITCH HIM
CAREFULLY.
STEPHEN: AND STILL FINDS A WAY
TO GET ON BASE, BUT HE'S DOING A
LOT OF THAT, DRAWING A WALK.
NOW A DOZEN MARKS HIS LAST 13
GAMES -- WALKS HIS LAST 13 GAMES
.
SO ONE OUT TRAFFIC FOR WADE
MILEY AFTER THE DOUBLE BY ADAMES
AND THE WALK FROM YELICH.
ADAMES HAS 10 EXTRA-BASE HITS
HIS LAST 15 GAMES.
DAN: THIS GUY COMING UP, AS MUCH
AS WILLY ADAMES HAS BEEN,
AVISAIL GARCIA HAS BEEN
TREMENDOUS FOR THE BREWERS,
PLAYING MAINLY IN RIGHT FIELD,
COMES UP WITH BIG HITS.
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT HIM
PHYSICALLY, HIS TIME WITH THE
TIGERS, I CALLED HIM A MIGUEL
CABRERA TYPE OF GUY.
HE'S YET TO REALLY FULFILL THE
PROMISE.
THERE WAS A TIME THE SOCKS
THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO BE A 30
HOME RUN, 100 R.B.I. GUY.
HE HASN'T QUITE BEEN THAT, BUT
NOTHING TO SNEEZE AT, 16 BOMBS
SO FAR.
AND HE'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THE BREWERS HAVE STAYED AFLOAT
UNTIL THIS OFFENSE HAS STARTED
TO PICK UP.
STEPHEN: AND HE WILL EAT YOUR
FASTBALL.
BREAKING BALL CHOPPED OVER TO
SHORT.
ONE TO INDIA.
ON TO FIRST BASE, THEY TURN TWO,
HELP WADE MILEY GET OUT OF THE
FIRST UNSCATHED.
A NICE POINT BY JOEY VOTTO AS
THEY GO 6-4-3.
DANNY: THIS IS WHY WADE MILEY'S
SO GOOD.
HE CAN GET TWO PITCHES WITH ONE
OUT.
HE NEVER REALLY PANICS.
HE MAKES PITCHES AND KYLE FARMER
STARTS AT OFF GREAT.
STEPHEN: WE'RE STILL STARING AT
ITH.
-- GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE.
SECOND INNING COMING UP NEXT.
♪
>> HERE'S GARCIA, BASES ARE
LOADED, AND THERE'S ONLY ONE MAN
OUT.
HERE IT IS.
>> GARCIA, SWINGING BUNT, FLIP
TO THE PLATE.
A RUN WILL SCORE.
IT WAS THE ONLY SHOT HE HAD.
>> TUCKER BARNHART GETS HIS
SHOT.
GETS PAST NARVAEZ!
CASTELLANOS GOES HOME, HE
SCORES.
REDS ON THE BOARD, 2-1, SECOND
AND THIRD.
BACK TO IT, AGAIN BOUNCES AWAY.
NORVASC CAN FIND IT.
THE REDS TIE THE GAME -- NARVAEZ
CAN'T FIND IT.
REDS TIE THE GAME.
REDS TAKE THE LEAD.
2-0.
BASE HIT!
NICK WOOD SCORES AND THE REDS
ARE ON TOP, 3-2.
-- NAQUIN SCORES AND THE REDS
>> WINKER CAN'T MAKE THE PLAY.
HE MISSED IT, GAME-TYING HIT FOR
HUIRA.
>> IN THE AIR, CENTER FIELD, GOT
IT ON THE BARREL, LONG RUN
NAQUIN.
HE IS LOOKING UP, IT IS GONE!
TWO RUN HOME RUN AND THE BREWERS
ARE IN FRONT IN THE EIGHTH.
STEPHEN: WE'RE SET FOR THE TOP
OF THE SECOND INNING, AND WILL
BE GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE FROM
YOUTUBE.
FIRST PITCH TO ARISTIDES AQUINO,
SHALLOW RIGHT FIELD, CAN OF CORN
FOR HIM.
LET'S GO BACK TO THAT DOUBLE
PLAY AS THE FIREBALL REVIEW
COMMENTED, A PITCHER'S BEST
FRIEND.
DAN: BUT WATCH JONATHAN INDIA
HERE, DOES A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
GETTING TO THE BAG, PRESENTING
HIS THROW CHEST HIGH WITH
CHRISTIAN YELICH BEARING DOWN ON
HIM, DOESN'T WAVER AT ALL AND
THROWS A STRIKE TO JOEY VOTTO.
HE MADE THIS LOOK REALLY EASY,
DOES A GREAT JOB SHOWING A
TARGET, GREAT PIVOT, STRONG
THROW, REALLY SIMPLE
SIX-FOR-THREE DOUBLE PLAY THAT
HE MADE LOOK AWFUL EASY.
STEPHEN: NOW W'ERE GOING TO
WATCH THE PLAYER WHO STARTED
THAT DOUBLE PLAY, KYLE FARMER,
REALLY GOOD ATHLETE.
GOT SOME GOOD CAREER NUMBERS
AGAINST LAUER, 4-12 LIFETIME.
GOT A NICE COUNT HERE, 2-0.
DANNY: AND NOT TO HARP ON INDIA,
BUT REMEMBER HE WAS A THIRD
BASEMAN OUT OF COLLEGE, SO HE'S
GOT THAT ARM AS A SECOND BASEMAN
NOW.
DOESN'T TAKE MUCH FOR HIM TO GET
ON THE BALL.
STEPHEN: FARMER SENDS THE 2-0
INTO RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
AVI ON THE TRACK, PUTS IT UP TO
MAKE THE CATCH.
TWO AWAY.
STEPHEN: ONE OF THE THINGS LAUER
WANTED TO DO EARLY WAS
ESTABLISHED THE FASTBALL.
DONE A GOOD JOB OF THAT.
HAS IMPRESSED TO GO TO THE
BREAKING STUFF.
STRUCK OUT WINKER IN THE FIRST
ON A CALLED STRIKE UP IN THE
ZONE ON A SLIDER.
HE'S BEEN ABOUT 75-80%
FASTBALLS.
STEPHEN: TO YOUR POINT ON INDIA,
COMING UP AS A THIRD BASEMAN NOW
AT SECOND, OBVIOUSLY GOT THE
CANON THAT WILL DO JUST FINE AT
SECOND.
WE'VE SEEN THAT BEFORE, NOT
BEING AFRAID TO MOVE GUYS
AROUND.
THAT ONE GETS UNDERNEATH THE
GLOVE OF URIAS, SO A TWO OUT HIT
FOR TUCKER BARNHART.
NICK SENZEL, AS WELL, DRAFTED AS
IN INFIELDER, MOVED TO THE
OUTFIELD.
THEY'RE NOT AFRAID TO LET
ATHLETES BE ATHLETES.
DAN: THIS IS A FUNNY PLAY.
I THINK URIAS THOUGHT THIS WAS
HIT EARLIER -- HARDER THAN IT
WAS.
MORE THAN LIKELY, SCORED A BASE
HIT, BUT A PLAY MOST OF THE TIME
URIAS MAKES THAT PLAY.
DANNY: THOSE ARE THE ONES, LIKE
LINE DRIVES BACK TO THE PITCHER,
EVERYBODY LAUGHS AT THE PITCHER,
BUT THEY DON'T LAUGH AT THE
POSITION PLAYERS MISSING IT.
DAN: WE'RE THE ONES GOING
THROUGH A FULL DELIVERY AND
YOU'RE SEEING A BIG SWING,
YOU'RE NOT SURE IF IT'S A ROCKET
OR NOT.
DANNY: EXACTLY.
STEPHEN: ALL RIGHT, WADE MILEY.
CAN YOU HELP YOUR OWN CAUSE
HERE?
CHOPS ONE OVER TWO URIAS, AND
REDEMPTION AT THE HOT CORNER.
SO A QUICK 1-2-3 INNING FOR ERIC
LAUER.
AFTER 1.5, STILL WAITING FOR THE
FIRST RUN OF THE BALLGAME.
HIGH CHOPPER.
NO WORRIES FOR URIAS.
WHEN WE COME BACK, CREW COME
BACK TO THE TYRONE
TAYLOR, JACE PETERSON, AND
KESTON HIURA.
♪
>> GROUNDED TO VOTTO, LEAPING
SNAG.
FARMER ON TO FIRST, DOUBLE PLAY!
WHAT A LEAPING GRAB ON A 3-6
-3 DYNAMITE DOUBLE PLAY!
AKIYAMA INTO RIGHT CENTER.
DOWN, BASE HIT.
FIRES TO THE PLATE.
THE SLIDE, THE TAG, OUT.
IT'S IN!
TOE'S ONT EH PLAYTE. -- ON THE
PLATE.
SAFE!
STEPHENSON TO RIGHT FIELD!
THE REDS WIN!
THEIR CAREER WALKOFF HIT FOR THE
ROOK.
THE PADRES CHOSE TO FACE TYLER
STEPHENSON.
THEY CHOSE POORLY.
IN THE AIR, CENTER FIELD,
STUMBLE START FOR HERRERA,
STREAKS BACK, GONE!
A GRAND SLAM!
VOTTO.
ANNIHILATES IT TO RIGHT FIELD!
1,000 R.B.I.'S!
SO HERE'S YOUR SHORTLIST.
JOHNNY BENCH, TONY PEREZ, PETE
ROSE, FRANK ROBINSON, AND NOW
JOSEPH DANIEL VOTTO.
STEPHEN: WE'RE BACK TO MLB GAME
OF THE WEEK, PRESENTED BY CHIME.
SOME OUTSTANDING ROTATION DUOS.
YOU WANT 1-2 PUNCHES?
GOOD HANDFUL OF THEM.
DAN: YOU COULD ALMOST ADD A
THIRD.
FREDDY PERALTA WILL BE GOING
TOMORROW NIGHT FOR THE BREWERS.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GET IN A FIGHT
WITH THE BREWERS WITH STARTING
PITCHING.
COUPLE THINGS THEY DO REALLY
WELL, THEY START, RELIEF, AND
CATCH THE BALL.
STEPHEN: AND CINCINNATI, WHEN
HEALTHY, YOU CAN MAKE THE CASE
FOR THEM TO BE ON THERE, AS
WELL.
SONNY GRAY NOT HEALTHY, LUIS
CASTILLO TURNING THINGS AROUND.
THAT LEADS US TO THIS POLL
QUESTION.
WHICH TEAM HAS THE MOST IMPOSING
1-2 PUNCH IN THE ROTATION?
MILWAUKEE, THE METS, SAN
FRANCISCO, OR THE SOUTHSIDERS?
DAN: HOW GOOD HAS TAIJUAN WALKER
BEEN FOR THE METS?
STEPHEN: SOME OF THE UNDER THE
RADAR ONES, WALKER FOR THE METS,
LANCE LYNN SENDING DANE DUNNING,
A PROSPECT THEY REALLY LIKE, AND
CARLOS RODON, FELLOW NC STATE
ALUM LIKE YOU, DAN PLESAC.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE CLOSING THE
BOOK ON HIM AFTER SOME INJURIES,
NEVER REACHED THAT THIRD OVERALL
POTENTIAL.
HE'S DOING IT NOW.
DAN: GETTING A GOOD LOOK AT
CRAIG COUNSELL RIGHT THERE.
IN OUR MEETING THIS AFTERNOON, I
THOUGHT IT WAS INTERESTING.
HE SAID WE HAVE A TEAM BUILT
AROUND OUR STARTING PITCHING.
IT'S A HARD THING TO SAY.
THERE HAVE BEEN GREAT BREWERS
TEAMS, GO BACK TO THE 1980 TWO
TEAM THAT WENT TO THE WORLD
SERIES WITH ROBIN YOUNG, PAUL
MOLITOR, ROLLIE FINGERS, TED
SIMMONS.
THIS MIGHT BE THE BEST PITCHING
STAFF THEY'VE EVER PUT TOGETHER.
THAT'S SAYING A LOT.
STEPHEN: THAT'S SAYING A LOT.
TYRONE TAYLOR 1-1 ON THAT ONE.
DAN: ALL THREE OF THEIR BIG
THREE, BRANDON WOODRUFF, FREDDY
PERALTA, AND CORBIN BURNES ALL
SPENT TIME PIGGYBACKING GOING
FROM THE BULLPEN INTO THE
ROTATION, BACK INTO THE BULLPEN.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I THINK
IS A STRENGTH OF THIS MILWAUKEE
ORGANIZATION, YOU HAVE TO BE AN
INTERCHANGEABLE PART AND YOU
HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT.
FROM AN EVERYDAY PLAYER --
THERE'S A GOOD LOOK AT FREDDY
PERALTA -- BUT IT'S HARD TO DENY
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE STARTING
ROTATION.
WOODRUFF, BURNES, PERALTA,
LAUER.
AND YOU CAN THROW HOUSER INTO
THE MIX.
STEPHEN: GOOD PITCH FROM MILEY.
DAN: PRETTY GOOD CHANGEUP AFTER
COUPLE OF FASTBALLS IN.
89, 90, BACKS IT UP WITH THAT
CHANGEUP.
THAT'S ONE OF THE KEYS FOR WADE
MILEY.
HE'S NOT GOING TO RELY, LIKE
WE'VE SEEN LAUER THROW A LOT OF
FASTBALLS EARLY.
MOVE THE BALL ALL AROUND.
FIRST PITCH, SLIDER FOR A CALLED
STRIKE.
WE'VE SEEN JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING
IN HIS ARSENAL SO FAR.
STEPHEN: HERE'S THE DEFENSIVE
ALIGNMENT FOR CINCINNATI BEHIND
WADE MILEY.
SLOW ROLLER TO INDIA AT SECOND.
JUST A BIT OUTSIDE TO VOTTO, BUT
HE CAN HANDLE IT.
BY THE WAY, FOR THE COMMENTARY
SECTION, HERE'S A REFERENCE.
FIRST WANT TO NAME IT GETS A
SHOT UP.
"PETERSON!
PETERSON!"
NOT GIVING YOU MUCH BUT IF
YOU'RE A 1980'S KID, YOU GET IT.
DAN: I CAN TELL YOU ABOUT KESTON
HIURA, MINOR LEAGUES A COUPLE
TIMES, THE BREWERS THAT HE WAS
GOING TO BE THERE SOLUTION TO
FIRST BASE.
CRAIG COUNSEL TOLD US LAST YEAR
WAS THE FIRST TIME HE STRUGGLED
HITTING.
THIS IS A GUY THAT CAN WAKE UP
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT AND
GET A COUPLE OF HITS.
HE'S HAD A DIFFICULT TIME
CATCHING UP WITH THE FASTBALL
PRIMARILY UP IN THE ZONE.
STEPHEN: AND SOMETHING YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT EARLIER WAS PACE
IN WHICH HE WORKS WHEN HE SAW
THE CLOCK DROP DOWN.
LET'S DO IT AGAIN JUST TO GIVE
PEOPLE A SENSE.
DAN: AND HE WORKS FAST.
WHAT IT DOES FOR A HITTER, YOU
GET BACK IN THE BOX, GREAT 1-1
CHANGEUP.
WE SEEN FASTBALL, CURVEBALL,
CHANGEUP, ALL THREE THROWN FOR
STRIKES.
STEPHEN: AVERAGING ABOUT 21
SECONDS FOR WADE MILEY.
YEAH, THE FIREBALL REVIEW GOT
IT, "FERRIS BUELLER."
"MR. PETERSON."
COUPLE OF BIG HITS LAST NIGHT.
RED'S FANS WOULD ARGUE GOT SOME
HELP IN THE FIELD FROM A
MIS-PLAY BY JESSE WINKER.
BUT PERHAPS THAT'S THE KIND OF
THING, KIND OF NIGHT THAT CAN
HELP KESTON HIURA GET BACK ON
TRACK.
DAN: AND REALLY A PITCHER LIKE
WADE MILEY IS MORE WHAT HE NEEDS
RIGHT NOW UNTIL HE GETS GOING.
HE WAS EXPOSED IN THE PRIOR
SERIES WHEN THE BREWERS WERE IN
NEW YORK.
THERE'S A LOT OF VELOCITY IN
THAT METS ROTATION AND BULLPEN.
THAT FASTBALL OVERPOWERED HUIRA
IN THAT THREE-GAME SERIES.
IT SHOULD BE EASIER FOR HIM
UNTIL HE GETS THAT TIMING.
CRAIG COUNSELL TALKED ABOUT IT.
HE HAS A LOT OF, I DON'T WANT TO
SAY MOVING PARTS, BUT THAT LEG
KICK AND TIMING HASN'T BEEN IN
SYNC SO FAR IN 2021.
STEPHEN: HERE'S MANNY PINA.
PICKOFF ATTEMPT AT FIRST BASE.
JON: GUYS, I PAID MY PHONE BILL
SO I'M BACK WITH YOU NOW.
YEAH, I'M ABLE TO GET BACK ON
AND TALK WITH YOU GUYS.
JUST IN TIME FOR MANNY PINA.
STEPHEN: JUST IN TIME FOR THE
GUY WE WONDERED IF HE WOULD STAY
IN THE GAME EARLIER WHEN HE WAS
BEHIND THE PLATE, GOT CROSSED
UP, AND THEN A FOUL TIP SENT A
BALL RIGHT INTO HIS THROWING
HAND.
THAT, NOT GREAT.
DANNY: AND YOU SEE WHAT WADE
MILEY IS DOING IMMEDIATELY,
TRYING TO THROW PITCHES IN,
WHETHER IT'S A CUTTER IN OR BACK
INSIDE TO SEE IF HE CAN HANDLE
THAT PITCH IN THERE WITH THAT
RIGHT-HANDED THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
SORE.
STEPHEN: GETS AHEAD, 0-2 DOES
MILEY.
DANNY: HE WANTS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THAT.
DAN: HOW ABOUT MANNY PINA?
FIVE HOME RUNS AND FOUR SINGLES.
STEPHEN: SEE THAT HAND, HE IS
NOT RIGHT.
YOU SAW IT, THAT REACTION.
THERE IS SOMETHING WRONG WITH
MANNY PINA.
POPPED UP INTO SHALLOW R THERE.
WE'RE THROUGH TWO FULL IN
MILWAUKEE.
♪
>> 2-1 GAME, THEY ARE LOADED FOR
THE CUBS.
JAKE COUSINS DEALS.
AND A SWING AND A MISS!
HE STRUCK HIM OUT.
HAPP LEAVES THEM LOADED.
>> AND THE PITCH.
SWING AND A DRIVE TO LEFT CENTER
FIELD AND DEEP.
WAY BACK, GET UP, GET OUT OF
HERE GONE FOR WILLY ADAMES!
AND THEY HAVE OPENED UP THIS
BABY.
>> HERE IS ADAMES.
ADAMES IN THE AIR RIGHT CENTER.
FALL IS HIT WELL, MARISNICK ON
THE RUN.
AND IT'S UP AND OUT!
IT'S A GRAND SLAM, THE FIRST OF
THE YEAR FOR THE BREWERS!
WHAT MORE CAN THIS GUY DO FOR
THE BREWERS?
AND THAT BALL IS LAUNCHED,
CENTER FIELD, DEEP, AND IT IS
GOING TO BE CAUGHT BY BRADLEY.
STALLINGS ROUNDED SECOND.
THE THROW COMES IN, HIURA THE
TAG, AND HE'S OUT.
>> SWING AND A GROUND BALL,
BASE.
ONE RUN IS IN.
HERE'S THE THROW HOME.
SAFE!
TAYLOR SLIDES UNDER THE TAG OF
CONTRERAS AND THE BREWERS HAVE
THE LEAD, 8-7.
>> HE AIN'T FOOLING ANYBODY.
HE AIN'T FOOLING NOBODY.
TAKE IT EASY.
I GOT YOU.
YOU KNOW, BRO.
TOO SOLID, TOO SOLID.
STEPHEN: INDIA AND WILLY ADAMES
MIC'D UP.
ALONGSIDE ANY GRAYS, DAN PLESAC,
AND JON PAUL MOROSI, I'M STEPHEN
NELSON.
SO, THEY'RE STILL WAITING FOR A
CATCHER TO COME OUT IN
MILWAUKEE, AND IT IS MANNY PINA.
HE'S GOING TO STAY IN THE GAME.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
FIRST INNING.
DAN: THIS IS A CROSS UP RIGHT
HERE.
NOTHING BY RIGHT HAND.
MY HAVE BEEN TIPPED BY EUGENIO
SUAREZ.
DOESN'T GET ANY LEATHER,
STRAIGHT INTO THE PALM OF HIS
HAND.
GIVE HIM CREDIT FOR HANGING IN
THERE.
WATCH HIS REACTION, TRYING TO
SHAKE OUT THE RIGHT HAND, TRYING
TO PLAY THROUGH A LOT OF PAIN.
STEPHEN: DODGER FILMS COMMENTING
HE'S GOT TO COME OUT.
HE'S STAYING IN.
DAN: BOY, JUST WHAT MR. LAUER
WOULD LIKE, BE REALLY EFFICIENT.
ESTABLISH THE FASTBALL COMMAND
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE PLATE.
REDS ARE UP THERE, FREE
SWINGING.
STEPHEN: AND BY THE WAY, IF
YOU'RE ABLE TO COMMENT, SEND US
A QUESTION FOR CORBIN BURNES.
WE'RE SET TO TALK TO HIM IN A
LITTLE BIT.
I'LL BE YOUR MOUTHPIECE.
I WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU, AND
WE'LL FLOAT THOSE ALONG.
HERE'S JESSE WINKER.
DAN: DANNY, YOU'VE HAD A CHANCE
TO WATCH JESSE WINKER A LOT.
HE'S HAD A CHANCE TO DEVELOP
INTO ONE OF THE TOP LEFT-HANDED
HITTING BATTERS IN BASEBALL
RIGHT NOW, WELL-DESERVED GOING
INTO THE ALL-STAR GAME.
STEPHEN: BACK TO LAUER.
DANNY: HE'S BEEN SUCH A TREAT
FOR THE REDS.
HE'S DEVELOP MORE AND MORE AS IT
GOES BUT.
HE'S STARTING TO DRIVE THE BALL,
GOT A LOT MORE POWER, AND HE'S
ATTACKING FASTBALLS MORE, WHICH
IS MADE HIM SO MUCH BETTER.
IN THE PAST, HE WAS TAKING A LOT
OF PITCHES.
NOW HE'S A LITTLE MORE
AGGRESSIVE.
THE GUY IS SUCH A TREAT.
HE'S JUST A PURE HITTER OUT
THERE.
DAN: COUPLE OF QUICK OUTS FOR
LAUER.
YOU WONDER IF CASTELLANOS IS
GOING TO TAKE A COUPLE PITCHES.
STEPHEN: YOU WANT A.
ARE, NICHOLAS CASTELLANOS -- A
PURE HITTER, NICHOLAS
CASTELLANOS IS A GUY YOU WANT TO
BE WATCHING.
DAN: I THINK NICK AT NIGHT IS
GOING TO BE TAKING ONE.
I'M GOING TO THROW ONE DOWN THE
MIDDLE.
STEPHEN: HE WANTS TO ANSWER
THAT, BEQUEST OR, WHO IS GOING
TO SCORE FIRST?
HE'S GOT 17 BOMBS ON THE YEAR.
SWING AND A DRIVE INTO RIGHT
FIELD, JUST IN FRONT OF THE
TRUCK GARCIA COMES IN.
SO A FLY OUT TO RIGHT ENDS THE
THIRD INNING.
YOU THINK YOU ARE GETTING A
COMMERCIAL?
NAH, WE'VE GOT SOMETHING SPECIAL
FOR YOU.
AND ON THE OTHER SIDE OF IT, A
SPECIAL GUEST.
LET'S TAKE EVERYONE TO
COUNSELL'S CRAFT STAFF.
DAN: PLENTY OF GOOD PUBS AND
BREWERIES AROUND MILWAUKEE.
BIG WOO BREW.
STEPHEN: LITE SAID FRED.
DAN: FOR FREDDY GARCIA.
THE AIRBENDER.
JOSH HADER GOING TO HIS THIRD
ALL-STAR GAME, ONE OF THE TOP
RELIEVERS IN THE SPORT.
STEPHEN: YOU LIKE THE DARK
STUFF?
SOME DARK HADER STOUT.
DAN: I THINK I'M GOING TO GO
WITH THAT PUNCH OUT PILSNER.
I WANT ME SOME CORBIN BURNES.
STEPHEN: GRAVY, WHAT YOU THINK?
DANNY: LITE SAID FRED BECAUSE
I'M A LITTLE HEAVY THESE DAYS.
DAN: STAY AWAY FROM THE CARDS,
DANNY.
DANNY: THAT'S RIGHT.
STEPHEN: YOUR BODY IS A TEMPLE.
I GET YOU.
WE COME BACK WITH SOME COMPANY,
SOME ALL-STAR COMPANY.
CORBIN BURNES OF THE MILWAUKEE
BREWERS HAS HOPPED ON A HEADSET.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU SAW THE
COUNSELL'S BREWERY MADE, BUT
YOU HAD THE PUNCH OUT PILSNER
MADE FOR YOU.
CORBIN: THAT'S AWESOME.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON.
DAN: YOU'RE GOING TO YOUR FIRST
ALL-STAR GAME.
WHAT DOES IT FEEL LIKE?
CORBIN: IT'S AWESOME.
IT'S SOMETHING YOU ALWAYS DREAM
OF, PLAY IN THE ALL-STAR GAME
AND THAT BIG STAGE, TO BE JOINED
BY BOTH WOODY AND HADER AND
HOPEFULLY PERALTA IS PRETTY
AWESOME.
STEPHEN: WE'RE LOOKING AT SOME
OF YOUR HIGHLIGHTS FOR THE
SEASON.
THERE HAVE BEEN A TON.
IS THERE ONE DAY OR ONE
HIGHLIGHT THAT STICKS OUT IN THE
FIRST HALF?
CORBIN: I THINK I GOT TO GO BACK
TO THE PADRES GAME EARLY ON IN
THE YEAR.
THE GUYS PLAYED SOME GREAT
DEFENSE BEHIND ME.
IT'S A PLAYOFF ATMOSPHERE
PLAYING A GOOD TEAM.
I THINK WE HAD A GREAT SERIES,
ENDED UP SWEEPING THE PADRES AT
THEIR PLACE.
THAT PROBABLY STICKS OUT THE
MOST.
DAN: YOU MADE SOME CHANGES TO
YOUR GAME, ADDED A CUTTER TO THE
MIX LAST YEAR.
WAS IT A HARD THING TO DO TO DO
TO CHANGE YOUR GAME PLAN AROUND?
CORBIN: YEAH, IT WAS DEFINITELY
DIFFICULT.
BUT WHEN YOU GET PUNCHED IN THE
FACE, YOU'VE GOT TO FIGURE
SOMETHING OUT OR YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO BE IN THE GAME VERY
LONG.
IT WAS TAKING THE SLIDER AND
FIGURING OUT WHAT TO DO WITH IT.
WE STARTED OFF TRYING TO THROW
TWO SLIDERS AND TURNED INTO A
CUTTER.
KIND OF TOOK OFF AND 2020 AND
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP IT AND THROW
THE CURVEBALL AND CHANGEUP MORE.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WORKING WITH
THIS YEAR.
DANNY: WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
JONATHAN INDIA'S HAIR, BUT
CORBIN BURNES ROCKING THAT SWEET
FLOW.
I'VE GOT A NON-BASEBALL QUESTION
FOR YOU.
HAVE YOU GONE DOWN BERNIE'S
SLIGHT YET?
CORBIN: I ACTUALLY HAVE NOT.
I HAVE NOT.
THAT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS
EVERYONE DOES AT FAMILY DAY.
EVERY FAMILY DATE, NOW I ASK MY
WIFE.
NOPE.
I DON'T DO THAT EITHER.
DAN: YOU GREW UP AN ANGELS FAN.
DID YOU HAVE A FAVORITE PLAYER
AS A KID GROWING UP?
CORBIN: I ALWAYS LOVED WATCHING
JERED WEAVER THROW.
HE WENT OUT WITH NOT THE
GREATEST STUFF, BUT JUST
ATTACKED THE ZONE.
HE WAS THROWING HIS FASTBALL AT
84, 85, ATTACKING WITH IT LIKE
HE WAS THROWING 95.
I LOVED WATCHING HIM PITCH,
GOING AFTER GUYS NO MATTER WHAT
HE HAD.
THAT'S SOMETHING I KIND OF TOOK
FROM THAT AND BY THE TIME I WAS
IN HIGH SCHOOL, TROUT WAS IN THE
BIG LEAGUES.
IT WAS FUN WATCHING HIM, AS
WELL.
STEPHEN: TALK ABOUT GAMERS,
JERED WEAVER.
WE'VE GOT ONE FROM THE COMMENTS
SECTION ON YOUTUBE.
WITH THE DRAFT AROUND THE
CORNER, WANT TO KNOW WHAT
GETTING DRAFTED WAS LIKE FOR
YOU, AND HOW WAS THE WHOLE DAY?
AND MY MOM ATTENDED ST. MARY'S
COLLEGE, TOO.
THAT'S PRETTY COOL.
CORBIN: NICE.
DRAFT A IS CRAZY.
I HEARD IS DIFFERENT THIS YEAR,
THAT DAY ONE IS ONLY THE FIRST
ROUND.
IN 2016 WHEN I WAS DRAFTED, THE
FIRST DAY WAS THE FIRST TWO
ROUNDS, AND THEN THREE THROUGH
10 THE SECOND DAY.
EVERYTHING LEADING UP TO THE
DRAFT, AT THE OTHER GOING TO GO
THE FIRST DAY, AND THEN IT GETS
STRESSFUL.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, I WAS
HAPPY OF HIS CHOSEN BY THE
BREWERS.
THEY GAVE ME AN OPPORTUNITY AND
I WAS FORTUNATE TO FLY THROUGH
THE MINOR LEAGUE SYSTEM AND GET
TO THE BIG LEAGUES PRETTY
QUICKLY.
THAT'S ALL CREDIT TO THEM AND
THEIR DEVELOPMENT STAFF, HELPED
TO GET ME HERE.
STEPHEN: AS THERE'S TIME CALLED,
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU 10 SECONDS
TO MAKE A PITCH FOR FREDDY
PERALTA BEING ONE OF THE
REPLACEMENTS ON THE NATIONAL
LEAGUE ROSTER FOR THE ALL-STAR
GAME.
CORBIN: OH  MAN, FREDDIE'S BEEN
AWESOME, REALLY SINCE THE FIRST
START HE'S HAD.
HE SAID ONE ROUGH ONE THAT MADE
HIS NUMBERS AND FLIGHT A LITTLE
BIT, BUT HE'S STILL GOT A LOW
2.00 E.R.A. AND ATTACKS THE ZONE
AND PUNCHES OUT THE WORLD.
IF FREDDY DOESN'T END UP IN THAT
GAME, I THINK SOMETHING IS
WRONG.
STEPHEN: I WILL BE OUT THERE
WITH MILLAR AND SEE YOU IN
DENVER.
CONGRATS ON A FIRST HALF THAT
MADE A LOT OF BREW CREW FANS
HAPPY.
CORBIN: THANK YOU, SEE YOU
THERE.
STEPHE BURNES, ONE OF
THE ACES OF THE MILWAUKEE
BREWERS.
STILL SCORELESS AFTER THREE.
♪
>> DEREK JETER INTRODUCED TO THE
CROWD.
IS IT 3K TODAY?
HE'S TWO AWAY, AND DEREK WILL
COME TO THE PLATE.
MOST OF THE CROWD STANDING AND
THEY ARE ANXIOUS TO SEE HISTORY
TODAY.
>> BASE HIT BETWEEN LEFT FIELD
AND SHORT!
THE COUNTDOWN IS ONE.
>> 2,999 HITS FOR DEREK JETER.
♪
27 MEN HAVE PICKED UP 3000 HITS,
DERREK TRYING TO BECOME NUMBER
28.
THAT ONCE DRIVEN DEEP TO LEFT
FIELD, SEE YA!
3000, HISTORY WITH AN
EXCLAMATION POINT!
OH, WHAT A WAY TO JOIN THE 3000
HIT CLUB!
DEREK JETER HAS DONE IT IN GRAND
STYLE.
♪
STEPHEN: IT'S BERNIE'S CHALET
NOW.
IT USED TO BE BERNIE'S DUGOUT.
I HAVE GONE DOWN THAT SLIDE.
IT WAS AWESOME.
DID I FEEL LIKE I WAS GOING TO
NOT MAKE IT?
FOR A SPLIT SECOND.
THEN I MADE IT DOWN.
DAN: I HAVEN'T MADE THE TREK
DOWN THE SLIDE.
WHAT DO YOU SLIDE INTO?
STEPHEN: THERE IS BASICALLY A
PIT, AND THERE'S PADDING.
OUR CAMERA MAN WAS NOT READY
FOR.
HE MET THAT WALL PRETTY QUICKLY.
DANNY: I'M SO JEALOUS.
STEPHEN: ON THE BUCKET LIST?
IT SHOULD BE.
DANNY: YES, THAT AND MANY TIMES
BEEN TO THE BALLPARK, WANTED TO
GET A PICTURE WITH BOB UECKER
AND SLIDE DOWN.
DIDN'T DO EITHER ONE.
STEPHEN: VOTTO IS RETIRED.
STARTED OFF THE TOP OF THE
FOURTH INNING.
IF YOU
WE'LL FOCUS ON A YOUTUBE CONTENT
CREATOR.
TODAY, OUR CREATOR SPOTLIGHT
SHINES ON THE FIRE BALL REVIEW.
ON THIS CHANNEL YOU CAN EXPECT
TO SEE PREDICTIONS AROUND THE
LEAGUE AS WELL AS THE OCCASIONAL
MOVIE REVIEW.
HE NAILED MY QUESTION EARLIER.
WHAT REFERENCE WAS MAKING?
ERIC BUEHLER.
AND HE SAID HE KNEW THAT ONE AS
WELL.
ONE AWAY HERE IN THE THE OF THE
FOURTH.
WE'RE SEEING SUAREZ.
HE STRUCK OUT IN THE FIRST.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT PREGAME
GIVEN THAT FORMIDABLE FIRST
THREE AND ADRIAN HOUSER, WHAT
ABOUT ERIC?
HE STEPPED UP TO THE PAGE.
DAN: HE'S FALLEN BEHIND 3-0.
BUT HE'S HAD PRETTY GOOD COMMAND
OF HIS FASTBALL EARLY.
GETS A FAVORABLE CALL.
HE PUNCHED SUAREZ ON A 3-2 PITCH
THAT WAS UP ABOVE THE ZONE THAT
HE MAY HAVE CHASED FOR BALL
FOUR.
HERE'S ANOTHER LOOK FOR THAT
STRIKE.
MAYBE A HALF A BALL ABOVE THAT
STRIKE ZONE?
STEPHEN: JUST COME AND GET IT
RIGHT THERE.
DAN: WHEN YOU'RE HITTING .177
LIKE SUAREZ, YOU GET A FASTBALL
AND BOOM, YOU DON'T HIT IT.
STEPHEN: THAT KIND OF SHOWS THAT
RIGHT NOW, HE WON'T BE AGAIN.
HE'S NOT THE GUY THAT WE SAW A
COUPLE OF SEASONS AGO.
DAN: IT'S INTRIGUING BECAUSE AT
ONE POINT HE WAS ONE OF THE TOP
THIRD BASEMEN WHEN YOU PUT THE
WHOLE PACKAGE OF THE SLUGGING,
THE HITTING AND EVERYTHING
TOGETHER.
AND LISTEN, THERE'S A SECOND
HALF A SEASON OF BASEBALL LEFT
TO BE PLAYED.
BUT AS WE'VE SEEN IN TWO AT-BATS
EARLY, HE'S HAD A COUPLE OF
NACHESE HE'S HAD TO HIT, AND HE
SWUNG THROUGH IT AND HE MISSED
ANOTHER ONE RIGHT THERE.
DAN: TO BE --
STEPHEN: STRIKEOUTS HAVE BEEN
PART OF HIS GAME AS HE DRAWS A
WALK.
ALSO HAD SHOULDER SURGERY.
SO THERE ARE SOME OTHER FACTORS
AND ALSO HITTING A BASEBALL AT
THE MAJOR LEAGUE LEVEL IS HARD.
WHICH TEAM HAS THE MOST IMPOSING
1-2 PUNCH IN THEIR STARTING
ROTATION?
WOODRUFF AND BURNS AND THE
PUNCHOUT PILLS?
DAN: IT GOES TO SHOW YOU HOW
GOOD THOSE TWO ARE BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE NOT PLAYING IN A MAJOR
MARKET, CHICAGO, SAN FRANCISCO,
L.A.
IT GOES TO SHOW YOU HOW MUCH
BURNS AND WOODRUFF ARE RESPECTED
IN THE GAME OF BASEBALL.
AND AND YOU PUT FREDDIE PERALTA
AND THAT'S WHY IT'S GOING TO BE
HARD FOR THE REDS AND THE
CARDINALS.
THEY JUST HAVE BETTER PITCHING
THAN INELSE IN THE DIVISION.
STEPHEN: STRIKE TWO.
DANNY: YOU TALK ABOUT THEIR
PITCHING, THAT'S WHY THE REDS
WERE SO GOOD LAST YEAR BECAUSE
OF THEIR PITCHING THAT THEY HAD
THAT A LOT OF THE STARTERS WENT
DEEP INTO GAMES.
THIS MILWAUKEE STARTING ROTATION
IS ACTUALLY RIDICULOUS.
SAY THE TOP TWO, YOU CAN GO TOP
THREE EASILY ONE OF THE BEST IN
BASEBALL.
STEPHEN: THERE'S NO QUESTION
ABOUT THAT.
THERE ARE SO MANY OUTSTANDING
STARTING PITCHERS AROUND THE
LEAGUE.
WHEN WE HAVE THAT QUOTE, UNQUOTE
PITCHER, WHO DO YOU TAKE OFF?
IT'S A TOUGH CONVERSATION.
AQUINO SWATS ONE INTO LEFT
FIELD.
J.P. MOROSI HAS MORE ON THIS
MILWAUKEE ROTATION WHICH HAS SIX
.
J.P.: ONE OF THE KEYS FOR THE
BREWERS HAS BEEN REST.
WE HEARD SO IT OFTEN, TEAMS
GOING TO A SIX-MAN ROTATION
BECAUSE OF THE UNIQUE 2020
SEASON TO KEEP THEIR STARTERS
BETTER RESTED HERE IN 2021.
WELL, THE BREWERS RIGHT NOW
DINING BETTER JOB THAN ANY OTHER
TEAM IN BASEBALL OF KEEPING
THEIR GUYS RESTED, AND ERIC
LAURER TONIGHT STARTS FOR THE
SEVENTH TIME IN THE LAST EIGHT
GAMES ON FIVE DAYS' REST OR
MORE.
STEPHEN: THANK YOU FOR THAT
REPORT IN BETWEEN THOSE GAMES,
DO WE HAVE FOOTAGE OF J.P.
DANCING?
I'M TRYING TO SPEAK IT INTO
EXISTENCE.
KYLE FARMER FLEW OUT IN THE
SECOND INNING.
YOU KNOW, THE REDS' STARRING
STAFF, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THE REDS COMMENTED THEMSELVES
SINCE THE 30TH OF MAY HAVE A
.325 E.R.A. WHICH IS THIRD BEST
IN BASEBALL.
SO THEY WANT IN ON THE
CONVERSATION.
WILLY ADAMES GOING BACK.
MAKES THE GRAB.
DAN: THE ISSUES WITH THE REDS
HAVE BEEN THE EIGHTH AND NINTH
INNING BUT HOPEFULLY
POST-ALL-STAR BREAK THEY'RE
GOING TO GET A LITTLE BOOST.
LORENZEN IS A BIG PART.
THEY THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO BE
CLOSING GAMES FOR THEM ALONG
WITH AMIR GARRETT.
BUT HE PITCHED MUCH BETTER.
HE'S LOOKING FOR HELP.
THEY MIGHT GET IT FROM MICHAEL
LORENZEN.
STEPHEN: THAT'S A BIG TIME ARM
THEY'RE HOPING TO GET AFTER THE
BREAK.
DANNY:IT IS A HUGE ARM.
HE CAN THROW MULTIPLE PITCHES
WITH SERIOUS VELOCITY.
HE'S GOT GOOD TILT.
DEVELOPED A REALLY GOOD CHANGEUP
LAST YEAR WHEN HE WAS THROWN
MULTIPLE INNINGS.
IT'S GOING TO BE A HUGE BOOST
FOR THESE GUYS IF AND WHEN HE
COMES BACK.
DAN: IF HE EVER HIT YOU, YOU
BETTER THINK ABOUT CHARGING
AFTER THAT GUY.
DANNY: DEFINITELY NOT.
STEPHEN: YOU'RE SAYING YOU HAVE
NOT WORKED OUT WITH MICHAEL
LORENZEN?
DANNY: NELLY, I DON'T THINK I'VE
EVER WORKED OUT.
SO THAT'S A NO.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHEN: YOU'RE A SAVER, NOT A
LIFTER.
DANNY: RIGHT.
RIGHT.
YEAH.
I WAS ALLERGIC TO THE WEIGHT
ROOM SMELL.
I JUST DIDN'T LIKE IT.
STEPHEN: I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
CAN RELATE AS THE COUNT NOW 0-2
FOR LAURER.
ONE STRIKE AWAY FROM GETTING OUT
OF THIS FOURTH INNING.
HE DOES HAVE A PAIR OF REDS ON
BASE BEHIND HIM RIGHT NOW.
TUCKER BARNHART TRYING TO GO
2-2.
SENDS IT INTO LEFT FIELD.
TUCKER BARNHART GOING TO START
THE SCORING BRINGING HOME
SUAREZ.
THROW BACK TO THIRD GETS AQUINO!
1-0, CINCINNATI AFTER FOUR.
THREE AND A HALF DOWN.
WAIT FOR ANOTHER LOOK AT THAT.
WENT ALL THE WAY INTO THE CORNER
.
GOOD SPOT BY ADON DISON THE TURN
SPOTTING AQUINO.
DAN: FREE WILLY, RIGHT?
GREAT RELAY AND A GREAT JOB BY
URIAS TO BE THERE
STEPHEN: CINCINNATI DID GET THE
FIRST ONE.
IT'S 1-0.
>> I BLANKED OUT.
I STARTED GOING CRAZY, I GUESS
AND CAME IN AND SAT DOWN.
AND JUST LIKE WHAT HAPPENED?
>> IT WASN'T THE FIRST TIME
BRANDON WOOD RF HAD EXPERIENCED
SOMETHING THAT MADE NO SENSE IN
THE SUMMER OF 2016, WOODRUFF'S
ONLY BROTHER DIED AFTER AN
A.T.V. ACCIDENT.
BRANDON WAS IN THE MINORS WHEN
BLAKE PASSED AWAY.
AND IN HIS FIRST GAME BACK AFTER
THE FUNERAL PITCHED SIX SHUTOUT
INNINGS IN A 1-0 WIN.
THE ONLY RUN, YEP, A HOMER.
>> IT WAS JUST CRAZY BECAUSE THE
WHOLE DAY THE WIND WAS BLOWING
IN LIKE 20 MILES AN OR AND BALLS
WERE GOING NOWHERE.
AND I HIT ONE AND HE HAD A LOT
TO DO WITH THAT.
>> TWO YEARS LATER IN THE
BIGGEST GAME OF HIS LIFE, HE
HOMERED AND WAS THE WINNING
PITCHER AGAIN.
AND THE ONLY THING WOODRUFF CAN
FIGURE IS IT MUST HAVE HAD
SOMETHING TO DO WITH HIS
BROTHER.
>> IT'S LIKE -- IT'S STUFF THAT
YOU REALLY CAN'T EXPLAIN HOW IT
HAPPENED, BUT IT DID.
AND -- AND TO HAPPEN IN A SPOT
LIKE THAT WAS PRETTY COOL.
STEPHEN: BACK WITH SOME
FIRST-HALF N.L. M.V.P.
CANDIDATES.
NICK CASTELLANOS, HE'S ONE.
JACOB DEGROM.
I KNOW THE WRITERS AND VOTERS
HAVEN'T LOVED GIVING IT TO A
PITCHER, BUT HE'S DEFINITELY IN
THE CONSIDERATION AS IS MAX
MUNCY AND FERNANDO TATIS JR.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK -- I THINK THAT COULD BE
A DECENT POLL QUESTION.
CHRISTIAN YELICH WILL STEP IN TO
LEAD OFF THE BOTTOM OF THE
FOURTH AGAINST WADE MILEY.
BREAKING BALL STARTS THEM OFF
WITH STRIKE ONE.
DAN: YOU KNOW, I'M ALL THINGS
PITCHER.
BUT I GUESS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I WOULD -- MY ARGUMENT
AGAINST DEGROM WOULD BE SIMPLY
THIS, STEPHEN, THE AMOUNT OF
INNINGS.
STEPHEN: CHRISTIAN YELICH INTO
LEFT FIELD.
EASY FOR WINKER.
DAN: IT HASN'T BEEN LIKE YOU
COULD MAKE IT HE'S ON A
HISTORICAL PACE.
BUT HIS INNINGS ARE DOWN WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING IN COMPARISON TO
BOB GIBSON THAT MAGICAL YEAR IN
1968.
BUT WITH THAT SAID, I THINK THE
SECOND HALF OF THE SEASON, JACOB
DEGROM HAS SELECTED NOT TO PITCH
IN THE ALL-STAR GAME ON TUESDAY.
SO I THINK -- I THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE HIS INNINGS
INCREASE THE SECOND HALF OF THE
YEAR.
SO WE HAD THIS DISCUSSION LATER
ON, I MIGHT BE BUYING A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
STEPHEN: NICK CASTELLANOS IS
TRYING TO MAKE HIS CASE.
HE MAY NOT BE GETTING THE INK
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I THINK IT
DOES SEEM LIKE A TWO-HORSERACE
BETWEEN DEGROM AND TATIS JR.
BUT CASTELLANOS NEEDS TO BE
MENTIONED MORE.
DANNY: HE ABSOLUTELY DOES.
A LOT OF THAT TOO HAS TO DO WITH
NOT BEING A BEING MARKET TEAM.
YOU'VE GOT DEGROM IN NEW YORK
AND TATIS IN SAN DIEGO.
GRANTED, TATIS IS PUTTING UP
RIDICULOUS NUMBERS RIGHT NOW
AFTER MISSING SOME GAMES.
HE STILL CONTINUED TO MASH OUT
THERE.
BUT NICK CASTELLANOS DOESN'T GET
THE LOVE, I DON'T THINK THAT HE
-- HE DESERVES.
BUT WITH ALL THAT SAID, DON'T
THINK HE REALLY CARES.
HE'S JUST GOING TO GO OUT THERE
AND CONTINUE TO PLAY HARD AND
PUT UP GOOD NUMBERS FOR HIS
TEAM.
I KNOW THAT SOUNDS CLICHE, BUT
THAT'S JUST WHO HE IS.
STEPHEN: I GOT YOU.
BIG FAN OF NICK CASTELLANOS.
I'M GLAD THAT BASEBALL FANS
AROUND THE COUNTRY RECOGNIZEER
WHAT HE AND JESSE WINKER DID
THIS FIRST HALF AND SELECTING
THEM BOTH AS STARTING
OUTFIELDERS.
YOU NEVER KNOW WITH THE WAY THE
VOTING PROCESS IS FOR THE
ALL-STAR GAME.
IF IT DOES TURN INTO A
POPULARITY CONTEST, THAT IS A
PART OF THE EQUATION.
BUT THE WHEREWITHAL AS FANS
RECOGNIZE, HEY, IT'S THESE TWO
GUYS.
THEY BELONG.
THEY BELONG THERE.
AND A SPECIAL MOMENT FOR THEM
THERE, AN EMOTIONAL ONE FOR
JESSE WINKER.
AND YOU COULD HIT UP THE
CINCINNATI REDS SOCIAL CHANNELS
AND WATCH THAT PRESS CONFERENCE
AFTER IT WAS ANNOUNCED THAT THEY
WOULD BE ALL-STAR STARTERS AND
HOW IT HIT HIM.
HE DIDN'T KNOW THAT THIS WAS
GOING TO BE POSSIBLE FOR HIM TO
BE A STARTER IN THE ALL-STAR
GAME, ME JESSE WINKER?
DANNY: AND LISTEN, THERE'S A
COOL FACTOR ABOUT CASTELLANOS
TOO.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE GOTTEN TO
SEE HIM AS MUCH.
NICK CASTELLANOS IS A COOL DUDE
JUST WATCHING HIM PLAY MAKES IT
LOOK SO EASY AND SMOOTH.
STEPHEN: TOTALLY.
THERE'S A GROWNOUT FROM GARCIA.
I WANT TO GO TO J.P. MOROSI FOR
MORE ON THIS GUY, WADE MILEY.
J.P.: WELL, WADE MILEY BEFORE HE
THREW THAT NO-HITTER, HIS
4-YEAR-OLD SON, JEB, GAVE HIM A
TATTOO OF THE INCREDIBLE HULK ON
HIS RIGHT ARM.
YOU CAN SEE IT THERE.
AND AFTERWARD WADE MILEY
CREDITED THE TATTOO WITH PART OF
THE REASON WHY HE THREW THAT
NO-HITTER AND THERE IT IS.
MARVEL, NOW SEIZING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CELEBRATE THAT
ACHIEVEMENT WITH A POSTER THAT'S
GOING TO BE GIVEN OUT AT GREAT
AMERICAN BALLPARK ON THE 17TH OF
JULY.
STEPHEN, IS SOUNDS LIKE JEB'S
FAVORITE AVENGER WAS THE HULK.
WHICH AVENGER YOU?
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHEN: J.P., YOU KNOW ME?
I AIN'T A SUPERHERO.
J.P.: YOU'RE A LOVER NOT A
FIGHTER.
STEPHEN: I'M KEEPING SOMEBODY'S
I'LL GET YOU COFFEE?
I GET YOU SOME MORE BASEBALL
AFTER WE COME BACK.
AFTER FOUR FULL, IT'S 1-0,
CINCINNATI.
>> YOU WANT TWO RINGS?
DANG, MAN.
TWO BIG RINGS?
FROM THE MINUTOR LEAGUES I HAVE
FOUR.
AND THEN LAST YEAR WITH THE
AMERICAN LEAGUE -- I CAN'T WEAR
THAT.
IT'S TOO BIGGERS MAN.
STEPHEN: WILLY ADAMES TALKING TO
THE BREWERS' MANAGER CRAIG
COUNSELL AS WADE MILEY HAD ZERO
INTENTION OF TAKING THE BAT
RIGHT THERE.
WILLY ADAMES REALLY FUN
OUTGOING.
CRAIG COUNSELL HAD A REPUTATION
AS A PLAYER FOR NOT BEING THE
MOST TALKATIVE GUY, HE WAS A
GRINDER.
DAN: HE WAS AN OVERACHIEVER.
IT STARTED AT AN EARLY AGE.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT THE TWO
RIPPINGS.
ONE RING WITH THE FLORIDA
MARLINS.
THE OTHER WITH THE ARIZONA
DIAMONDBACKS.
STEPHEN: MILEY RETIRED FOR OUT
NUMBER ONE.
IF YOU WERE WATCHING YOU WOULD
KNOW FOR SURE WHO'S GOING TO
TAKE HOME THE HOME RUN CROWN
FROM COLORADO, YOU COULD ENTER
THE T-MOBILE HOME RUN DERBY
BRACKET CHALLENGE AND COMPETE TO
WIN $100,000 AT MLB.COM/BRACKET.
RESTRICTION DOSS APPLY.
SO YOU COULD SEE THE OFFICIAL
RULES FOR DETAILS.
SIGN ME UP.
GRAVE YES, ZACK.
HOME RUN DERBY PICK.
GRAVE Y, YOU'RE FIRST.
DANNY: IT'S IN COLORADO.
THE RUMOR IS THAT THE BALLS
AROUND IN THE HUMIDOR THING.
I'M GOING PETE ALONSO AGAIN.
STEPHEN: PETE ALONSO?
REALLY?
ARE THERE POLAR BEARS IN
ROCKIES?
THERE WILL BE ONE IN THE DERBY.
DAN: I'M GOING TO GO WITH SHOHEI
OHTANI.
NOT ONLY DO I THINK HE'S GOING
TO WIN IT.
I'M CALLING THE LOCKEST BOMB,
550 -- LONGEST BOMB, 550-PLUS.
JOEY GALLO TO ME IS THE MAJOR
DANGER.
STEPHEN: THIS IS A LOADED FIELD.
IT'S A LOADED FIELD.
BY THE WAY, SHOHEI'S FIRST ROUND
DRAW, THAT'S A TOUGH ONE.
JUAN SOTO.
DAN: AND HE'S THE EIGHTH SEED.
STEPHEN: THAT'S A TOUGH BRACKET
THERE FOR SHOHEI.
DANNY: BUT GUYS, SHOHEI OHTANI
IS THE EASY PICK.
YOU'VE GOT GO WITH SOMEBODY
DIFFERENT THAT'S TOO EASY,
RIGHT?
STEPHEN: I WENT WITH MATT OLSON.
DAN: I WENT WITH JOEY GALLO.
I'M THINKING THREE TRUE
OUTCOMES.
THERE ARE NO WALKS.
THERE ARE NO STRIKEOUTS.
IF YOU'RE TALKING BIG FELLA,
RIGHT?
DANNY: THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S VERY TRUE.
I'M GOING WITH EXPERIENCE.
ALONSO'S GOT THE EXPERIENCE,
RIGHT?
STEPHEN: HE DOES HAVE
EXPERIENCE, THAT'S TRUE.
BUT I FEEL LIKE WHEN HE WON IT
HE WAS A FIRST-TIMER, RIGHT?
ROOKIES CAN DO IT.
OLSON WOULD BE A ROOKIE.
SALVY PEREZ IS A SLEEPER.
EVERYONE'S BEEN COUNTING HIM
OUT.
HE'S HIT THE LONG BALL, HE'S GOT
31 IN LIKE 123 GAMES.
BETWEEN THIS YEAR AND LAST YEAR.
SO SALVY PEREZ IS AN INTERESTING
ONE.
I HAD THE UP YET, HIM OVER PETE
ALONSO IN THAT FIRST ROUND.
THIS IS A FUN DISCUSSION.
JONATHAN INDIA'S A FUN BASEBALL
PLAYER.
I JUST LOVE HOW HE'S TURNED IT
ON HERE FOR THE SENSE NATTY
REDS.
AND HE GETS ON BASE ONCE AGAIN
NEAR THE ONE OUT SINGLE.
SO HERE IS THE T-MOBILE HOME RUN
DERBY, OFFICIAL BRACKET.
J.P. MOROSI, YOU HEARD ZACH
GRAVY AND I TALK ABOUT OUR TALKS
AND OUR PICKS.
DO YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT ONE?
J.P.: I HEARD A LOT OF WRONG
ANSWERS.
THE RIGHT ANSWER IS GOING TO BE
JUAN SOTO.
JUAN SOTO WILL UPSET OHTANI IN
ROUND ONE.
SOTO HAS HEARD EVERYTHING ABOUT
VLAD JR. AND OHTANI AND TATIS
AND ACUNA AND NOW SOTO SAYS,
IT'S MY TURN.
HE'S WINNING THE DERBY.
STEPHEN: I -- I DON'T LIKE THAT,
J.P.
I LOVE THAT I LOVE THAT.
AND, YOU KNOW, WHAT, TO WIN A
BRACKET CHALLENGE.
YOU HAVE TO GO AGAINST THE
GRAIN.
YOU ALLUDED TO THAT AS WELL.
AND SO THAT IS WHY JUAN SOTO
COULD BE A -- COULD BE A GOOD
PICK FOR PEOPLE OUT THERE.
THAT'S THE POLL QUESTION RIGHT
HERE.
GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON YOUTUBE
PRESENTED BY CHIME.
SO IF YOU'RE TUNING IN -- DANNY:
IT'S GOOD THAT WE ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT ANSWERS.
STEPHEN: THAT'S TRUE.
GAVE EVERYBODY AN ARGUMENT FOR
EVERY SINGLE PARTICIPANT.
TREVOR STORY HAS THE EXPERIENCE
ATTITUDE.
JESSE WINKER WANTS TO GET BACK
ON THE HOME RUN TRACK IN THIS
REGULAR SEASON.
HE HAS COOLED OFF A LITTLE BIT
AFTER A TORRID START.
HE'S WORKED HIMSELF INTO A 3-0
COUNT ON LAURER.
YEAH,ER MEAN, GRAVY, WOULD IT BE
FAIR TO CALL THAT A CERTIFIED
SLUMP FOR JESSE WINKER?
IT'S THE FIRST TIME WE'VE SEEN
IT THIS SEASON?
DANNY: OH, YEAH, FOR SURE.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME HE'S HE'S
HAD ANY KIND OF STRUGGLES.
YOU ALMOST DON'T NOTICE IT
BECAUSE THE TEAM HAS BEEN
PLAYING SO WHELM IF YOU WOULD
HAVEN'T SHOWED ME THESE NUMBERS
I WOULDN'T HAVE IMAGINED HOW BAD
HE WAS IN THE SLUMP RIGHT THERE.
THAT'S THE THING.
YOU'VE GOT GUYS BEHIND HIM THAT
-- GUYS THAT ARE SWINGING THE
BAT WELL.
SO YOU CAN GET AWAY WITH BEING A
LITTLE BIT OF A SLUMP.
THE GOOD THING IS THE ALL-STAR
BREAK IS COMING UP, SO HE'LL BE
ABLE TO RECOUP A LITTLE BIT AND
TRY TO GET BACK ON TRACK.
STEPHEN: MILWAUKEE IS SHIFTING
ON JESSE WINKER.
HE SEES THE SHIFT MORE THAN 70%
OF THE TIME HE STEPS IN.
ONE OUT WALK HERE IN THE FIFTH.
SO NOW A RUNNER SCORING POSITION
FOR THE REDS.
A CHANCE TO ADD TO THEIR 1-0
LEAD.
DAN: ERIC LAURER'S BREAKING
BALL, HE'S GOING TO GET A VISIT
FROM HIS PITCHING COACH.
66 PITCHES TO GET THROUGH  4
1/3.
THE PITCH COUNT IS URN CONTROL.
TRYING TO SETTLING THE
LEFT-HANDER DOWN.
HE'S TURNED HIMSELF INTO A
ONE-PITCH GUY IF HE CAN LAND
THAT CURVEBALL, THAT CUTTER, HE
NEEDS SOMETHING TO GIVE REDS OFF
THE FASTBALL.
STEPHEN: THIS COPYRIGHTED
TELECAST IS PRESENTED BY THE
AUTHORITY OF THE OFFICE OF THE
COMMISSIONER OF BASEBALL AND MAY
NOT BE REPRODUCED, RETRANSMITTED
IN ANY FORM.
AND THE ACCOUNTS OF AND
DESCRIPTIONS OF THIS GAME MAY
NOT BE DISSEMINATED WITHOUT
EXPRESSED WRITTEN CONSENT.
USUALLY MY ONLY GOAL IS MY
COPYRIGHT READ AND I LEFT OUT
THE O BETWEEN REPRODUCE
RETRANSMITTED.
CASTELLANOS, A CHANCE TO DO SOME
DAMAGE HERE.
FOR MORE STAT CAST POWERED BY
GOOGLE CLOUD.
LOVE THIS LOOK.
TAKING YOU INTO THE HEART OF
THIS ZONE.
THAT'S -- IF YOU MISS THERE,
THAT MEANS HE'S HURTING YOU.
DAN: YOU SEE THAT BLUE ZONE,
DOWN AND AWAY.
ALL I HAVE TO DO IS GET THAT
BALL THERE.
GOOD LUCK.
IT'S EASIER SAID THAN DONE
PARTICULARLY WITH THE STRIKE
ZONE IS THE STRIKE ZONE YOU SEE
THAT BOX THAT YOU'RE SEEING ON
YOUR SCREEN AT HOME.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING AWAY LIKE
PITCHERS DID IN THE EARLY 90'S.
A LOT OF PITCHERS THEY WERE
GETTING A COUPLE OF MIVERAGES IN
AND OFF THAT INSIDE AND OUTSIDE
PART OF THE PLATE.
THOSE DAYS ARE GONE.
YOU CAN GO AHEAD AND TRY TO
PITCH THAT GUY DOWN AND AWAY,
BUT IF YOU MISS, HE'LL MAKE YOU
PAY FOR IT.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER.
WHEN WE MAKE A MISTAKE HE'S
GOING TO MAKE YOU TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF IT.
IT'S SO HARD TO HIT THAT BOTTOM
CORNER AWAY.
I MEAN, NO WONDER WHY IT'S TOUGH
FOR HIM TO HIT THAT PITCH.
BUT YOU SEE ALL THE RED AROUND
THERE.
YOU JUST HOPE TO HIT IT AT
SOMEBODY.
LIKE I SAID EARLIER, HOPE THEY
HIT IT AT SOMEBODY.
STEPHEN: THAT WAS ONE OF THE
BETTER BREAKING BALLS.
ALMOST A CUTTER.
CASTELLANOS, I THINK HE HAD THE
APPEARANCE THAT THAT WAS A
FASTBALL THAT WAS TAILING AWAY
AND THE BALL BROKE DOWN AND IN.
AND ALL HE COULD IS HIT IT AND
HIT IT FOUL.
STEPHEN: SEEN A LOT OF CUTTERS
AS FAR FROM HIM.
AHEAD TO CASTELLANOS, 1-2.
INDIA AND WINKER ON SECOND AND
FIRST RESPECTIVELY.
HERE'S THE PITCH.
SENT CENTER FIELD.
TAYLOR GOING TO COME IN.
AND THERE'S OUT NUMBER TWO.
DAN: THERE'S ANOTHER BREAKING
BALL RIGHT THERE.
THAT'S ONE THAT I'M SURE
NICHOLAS CASTELLANOS WOULD LIKE
TO HAVE ANOTHER PASS AT THAT ONE
THAT PITCH WAS INTENDED TO BE
DOWN AND IN.
KIND OF ONE OF THOSE CEMENT
MIXER ONES THAT HELD UP.
YOU CAN SEE NICK TRYING TO LOOK
AT IT ON THE SCOREBOARD.
YOU SEE THAT BIG DOT ON THAT
SLIDER RIGHT THERE.
THIS BALL IS MIDDLE-MIDDLE.
IT ALMOST JAMS HIM.
HE HAS A GOOD LOOK AND THAT'S
NICHOLAS CASTELLANOS WOULD LIKE
TO DO SOME DAMAGE WITH THAT
PITCH.
STEPHEN: NOW, TWO OUTS FOR JOEY
VOTTO.
VOTTO HAS TWO MORE YEARS
REMAINING ON HIS 10-YEAR
CONTRACT THAT HE SIGNED BACK IN
2012.
SPEAKING OF TWO, THAT'S WHERE HE
RANKS ALL TIME IN EVERY MAJOR
CATEGORY SEEMINGLY FOR
CANADIAN-BORN POSITION PLAYERS
RIGHT BEHIND THE HALL OF FAMER,
LARRY WALKER.
VOTTO FOULS ONE OFF.
DANNY: YOU KNOW, GUYS IN THAT
AT-BAT AGAINST WINKER THAT
LAURER PITCHED AROUND HIM, I WAS
ALMOST THINKING WHAT SHE DOING
PITCHING AROUND HIM TO GET TO
CASTELLANOS?
AND IT APPEARS IT'S KIND OF WHAT
IS WORKING OUT FOR THE GOOD --
YOU KNOW, GETTING CASTELLANOS TO
POP-UP.
AND NOW HE'S ABLE TO ATTACK THE
STRIKE ZONE AGAIN AGAINST VOTTO.
>> VOTH HAS 21 YEARS HOME RUNS
AND 63 RIBBIES IN MILWAUKEE.
MOST OF ANY ROAD BALLPARK IN HIS
CAREER.
TWO ABOARD HERE IN THE FIFTH.
1 THE 1-1.
DAN: THEY WAS NATIONAL LEAGUE
M.V.P..
PRETTY GOOD RIGHT THERE.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME GREAT ONES
THAT HAVE PLAYED IN THIS GAME.
NOT BAD TO BE SECOND.
HE'S HAD A TREMENDOUS CAREER
TRAILING ONLY LARRY WALKER IN
ALL THOSE CATEGORIES.
DANNY: THAT GIVES ME CHILLS,
THAT NAME.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHEN: TAKES YOU BACK IN A BAD
WAY, GRAVY?
DANNY: I'M TELLING YOU.
SCARE Y THAT'S WHEN YOU'RE
WATCHING LIIAN ONKING AND YOU
THINK MUFASA.
AND YOU GET THE CHILLS.
AND THAT HAPPENED WITH LARRY AND
ME.
STEPHEN: SPOILER ALERT.
THE --
DAN: 1243RD WALK TYING WILLY
RANDALL FOR 55TH PLACE ON THE
ALL-STAR LIST.
NEXT ON THAT LIST, RUSTY STALL
BIT.
STEPHEN: A BIG PUNCHY FROM
LAURER WHO CELEBRATES WITH A
CLAP FOR HIMSELF AND THE
FANS CLAP FOR THEMSELVES.
HE KEEPS MORE FREDS CROSSING THE
PLATE.
BUT MILWAUKEE STILL TRAILS 1-0
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE FIVETS.
-- FIFTH.
STEPHEN: WELCOME BACK TO
AMERICAN FAMILY FIELD WHERE
THERE'S A LITTLE MORE GREEN IN
THE STANDS THAN USUAL FOR TWO
REASONS.
THE MILWAUKEE BUCKS PLAY GAME
THREE HERE AT FICE SERVE FORUM
ON SUNDAY -- FIGHT SERVE FORUM
ON SEASONED AND ALSO A 1990'S
GIVE AWAY, THAT GREENISH LOGO TO
CELEBRATE 1990'S WEEKEND HERE.
TO HELP US CELEBRATE 1990'S
WEEKEND, WE HAVE ON THE
BROADCAST CREW THE MAN WHO RANKS
FOURTH IN THE 1990'S IN MLB AND
THAT'S DAN PLESAC.
DO YOU KNOW WHO RANKS THIRD?
DAN: PAUL OSENMACHER.
>> WELL DONE.
MICHAEL JACKSON IS ALSO IN THAT
TOP GROUP AND DOUG JONES AND
THEN DAN PLESAC.
DAN: AND I COULD TELL YOU THAT
LEFT ELBOW AND THE LEFT
SHOULDER, J.P., I'M FEELING ALL
OF THOSE APPEARANCES.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHEN: BY THE WHAT, PLESAC IS
PUTTING THAT ON HIS PITCHING
CAREER TWO DECADES.
I THINK IT'S ALL THE MILES
LOGGED ON THE GOLF COURSE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
PEDERSON.
GOOD ATTEMPT FROM FARMER.
GOOD ATTEMPT.
GOOD THROW.
BUNT OFF THE BAG.
DAN: WE WERE TALKING BEFORE THE
GAME AND WE TALKED TO CRAIG
COUNSELL AND HE RAVED AT JACE
PETERSON AT HIS STRIKE ZONE
RECOGNITION.
WHAT A TOUGH OUT THAT HE WAS.
AND HE GOT OUT OF THAT MEETING
AND WE WERE TALKING AT IT BEFORE
THE GAME, AND IT'S REALLY MADE
ME KIND OF DIVE IN AND TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS GUY AS A PLAYER.
HE'S ONE OF THOSE GUYS, YOU
KNOW, YOU KIND OF GO, OK.
GOOD PLAYER, SOLID PLAYER.
BUT WHEN YOU HEAR A MANAGER
SPEAK AS HIGHLY OF HIM AS HE
DOES, I CAN TELL YOU, I'M GOING
TO START DOING DOUBLE TAKES.
STEPHEN: DID YOU WATCH WHAT
KESTON HIURA TRIED TO DO?
A PUSH BUNT.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
COUNSELL WAS EFFUSIVE IN HIS
PRAISE.
VOTTO IN FOUL TERRITORY.
ONE DOWN.
HERE'S THE QUOTE AS BEST AS I
COULD TRANSCRIBE IT FROM CRAIG
COUNSELL ON JACE PETERSON.
ALWAYS HAD A GOOD FOUNDATION OF
BALLS AND STRIKES, GOOD ATHLETE,
HAS SNEAKY POP.
THE INGREDIENTS ARE THERE.
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF HIM HAVING
EXPERIENCE, TRIAL AND ERROR AND
GETTING TO A GOOD PLACE.
BUT THE MOST IMPRESSIVE THING
ABOUT HIM HE'S AS GOOD AS THERE
IS IN THE LEAGUE WITH BALLS AND
STRIKES.
HE'S A TOUGH A.B. FOR ANY
PITCHER.
DAN: AND THAT'S REFRESHING
BECAUSE IN A DAY AND AGE WHERE
WE'RE SEEING BATTING AVERAGES
DROP LOWER AND LOWER AND LOWER
AND SO MANY OF WHAT YOU CALL
EMPTY AT-BATS.
MAN ON SECOND, NOBODY OUT.
MAN ON THIRD.
YOU KNOW, NOT TRYING TO GET THE
BALL IN THE AIR.
FLY BALL, SAC FLY.
YOU'RE TAKING A LOOK AT NUMBER
14 RIGHT THERE.
BACK TO BASICS.
AND HE'S A GUY, STEVE, WE'RE
GOING TO START KEEPING AN EYE
ON.
>> ONCE YOU GO DEEP OFF JACOB
DEGROM.
PINA LACES ONE TO THE LEFT SIDE.
TWO ABOARD HERE IN THE FIFTH FOR
MILWAUKEE.
AND SPEAKING OF JACOB DEGROM.
LET'S PUT A BOW ON THE POLE
QUESTION IN THE LIVE CHAT AND
COMMENTARY SECTION.
AND WOW.
JACOB DEGROM WINS BY THE
SLIMMEST OF MARGINS AHEAD OF
NICK CASTELLANOS.
I ATTRIBUTE THAT TO ALL THE REDS
FANS WATCHING.
BUT HE DOES HAVE A LEGITIMATE
CASE.
BUT DEGROM WINS THE POLL.
>> THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
SURPRISE.
FERNANDO TATIS HAS HAD A MONSTER
FIRST HALF OF THE YEAR.
ANOTHER GUY THAT'S NOT ON THAT
LIST, RONALD ACUNA JR. FOR THE
BRAVES IS HAVING A POWERHOUSE
FIRST HALF BUT THAT SAYS A LOT
ABOUT NICK CASTELLANOS, A
TERRIFIC PLAYER.
STOFE
STEPHEN: AND NOW, NUMBER NINTH
SPOT ON IN THE ORDER, THE
PITCHER.
LAURER.
MILEY GOT HIM IN THE THIRD.
DAN PLESAC, DANNY GRAVES.
DANNY, I'M COMING TO YOU FIRST,
WOULD YOU, IF YOU WERE CRAIG
COUNSELL PINCH HIT FOR ERIC
LAURER HERE?
DANNY: I WOULD NOT PINCH HIT.
I'M BUNTING HIM OVER.
BUT THERE HE DOES.
PERFECT BUNT.
STEPHEN: HO, HO, HO.
DAN: I TELL YOU WHAT, JONATHAN
INDIA, WHAT A NICE PLAY.
NOT SURE WHAT BUNT PLAY WAS ON.
BUT WADE MILEY GET LATE TO THE
SCENE THERE.
HAD TO THROW A CHANGEUP TO FIRST
BASE.
BUT THIS POTENTIALLY SAVES A RUN
THIS BALL GETS DOWN THE LINE.
YOU SEE JOEY VOTTO CRASHING.
THIS IS HIS SHORT HOP ON THE
DIRT.
LAURER GETS HIS BALL DOWN.
IT'S A TOUGH PLAY FOR A LEFTY.
LOOK AT THIS SNAG BY INDIA.
WOW!
>> YOU LOOK AT THE BALL OFF THE
BAT, GUYS.
IT TOOK A FUNKY SPIN TOWARDS
THIRD.
AND THAT'S WHAT MILEY WAS TRYING
TO SAY AFTERWARDS THAT THE BALL
WAS LIKE A CUE BALL AND TOOK OFF
AND HE STILL MADE GREAT PLAY
IAN:.
STEPHEN: NICE PICK BY INDIA.
I SAID EARLIER AND I STAND BY
THE STATEMENT, HE'S JUST A FUN
BASEBALL PLAYER.
SECOND AND THIRD NOW FOR
MILWAUKEE.
LUIS URIAS, LIKE PETERSON HIT A
BOMB OFF JACOB DEGROM IN THE
PREVIOUS SERIES IN QUEENS.
DAN: I THOUGHT THAT
DOUBLE-HEADER WEDNESDAY -- I
THOUGHT GAME TWO OF THE
DOUBLE-HEADER, BREWERSED THAT
LEAD GOING INTO THE SEVENTH
INNING AND UNFORTUNATELY, JOSH
HADER WAS HIS FIRST BLOWN SAVE
OF THE YEAR, PINCH HIT HOME RUN
BREWERS LOST THAT GAME IN EXTRA
INNINGS.
THEY CAME BACK AND WON GAME TWO.
THAT SAID A LOT ABOUT THIS TEAM.
S THAT GOOD TEAM.
THERE'S A DIFFERENT HERO EVERY
NIGHT.
STEPHEN: HEAND WENT DEEP ON BOTH
ENDS OF THE DOUBLE HEADER.
AND BY THE WAY THE QUESTION I
THROUGH ABOUT THE DOUBLE-HEADER
THERE -- SKIED IN LEFT CENTER
FIELD.
CASTELLANOS CALLING OFF AQUINO
TO RETIRE THE SIDE.TTING UP THA
COME BACK.
BUT SOME TRAFFIC FOR MILEY.
SOME WORDS AS HE WALKS BACK TO
THE DUGOUT.
REDS STILL UP ONE.
STEPHEN: WELCOME BACK TO THE MLB
GAME OF THE WEEK LIVE ON
YOUTUBE.
SOMETHING NEW FOR THIS SEASON IS
THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME
WELL.
DON'T PICK IT.
-- PLAYER OF THE GAME.
WE DON'T PICK IT.
STAY TUNED FOR THE PLAYER OF THE
GAME PULLING OPTIONS A LITTLE
BIT LATER.
-- POLLING OPTIONS A LITTLE BIT
LATER.
I WONDER IF ONE OF THE POLL
QUESTIONS ON THIS 90'S WEEKEND
IN MILWAUKEE WILL BE ON THE
BACKSTREET BOYS?
98 DEGREES?
DON: I WAS HOPING WE COULD MAYBE
GET J.P., 1990'S ARE RIGHT IN
HIS WHEELHOUSE.
100% WAS "POISON" BY BELL BIVE
DEBOW.
I WONDER IF HE WAS GOING TO GRAD
SCHOOL IN HARVARD JAMMING IT AT
J.P.
STEPHEN: J.P. CAN SFWILL SPOTTED
IN A KARAOKE BAR SOMEWHERE
SINGING THAT.
DAN: HE CAN SING "POISON" IN
FOUR DIFFERENT LANGUAGES.
J.P.: I PREERBLE THAT.
BEING A GREAT LAKES NATIVE,
OBVIOUS, JUST ACROSS THE LAKE IN
MICHIGAN, BOB SEAGER IS MY JAM.
BOB SEAGER, A LITTLE BEFORE MY
TIME BUT INTRODUCED BY MY
PARENTS JOHN AND CHRIS.
SO BOB AND SEAGER -- I COULD GO
BOB SEAGER THAT COULD BE MORE
LIKE YOUR GENERATION, MY FRIEND.
HOW ABOUT THAT?
DAN: ABSOLUTELY.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, J.P., ONE
OF THE FIRST CONCERTS I SAW WAS
BOB SEAGER OUTSIDE THE CHICAGO
LAND AREA.
YEAH.
STEPHEN: HERE I GO.
I'M GOING TO TURN THE PAGE.
DAN: YOU'RE TOP SHELF, AREN'T
YOU?
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHEN: AQUINO AFTER THE
POP-OUT FROM SUAREZ WILL DIG IN.
REMEMBER THE PUNISHER?
FIRST 17 GAMES, 11 HOME RUNS WAS
THE FASTEST PLAYER IN BIG LEAGUE
HISTORY TO GET TO 11 HOME RUNS.
2020, IT WASN'T GREAT FOR HIM.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, YOU COULD SAY
THAT ABOUT A LOT OF PLAYERS.
A LOT OF ALL-STAR PLAYERS.
M.V.P. PLAYERS.
DAN: YELICH.
J.D. MARTINEZ STRUGGLED.
STEPHEN: JOSE ALTUVE.
THE LIST GOES ON, RIGHT?
SO RIGHT NOW IN THIS 2021
SAMPLE, I KNOW HE'S SLUGGING
ABOUT.600.
50 PLATE APPEARANCE THIS IS
YEAR.
BUT HE WAS A SENSATION.
TOOK THE BASEBALL WORLD BY
STORM.
HAS A 3-0 COUNT HERE.
WAS NEVER SWINGING.
I REMEMBER INTERVIEWING HIM
DURING THAT HOT STRETCH.
AND I NOTICED THAT HE ALWAYS HAS
HIS MOUTH OPEN AND A TONGUE OUT.
WE PUT UP A SIDE BY SIDE BY
MICHAEL JORDAN AS HE DOES WALK
HERE IN THE SIXTH.
AND BEFORE I FINISH MY STORY, I
WANT TO TAKE YOU TO HIS
TEAMMATE, JONATHAN INDIA ABOUT
THE PUNISHER STORY HIMSELF.
>> LOOK AT HIM.
LOOK AT HIM.
LOCK AT HIM.
-- LOOK AT HIM.
WHY DOES HE DO A FLEX ON A
SINGLE.
-- SINGLE?
HE'S FLEXING ON A SINGLE.
[LAUGHTER]
DAN: YOUTUBE PLAY OF THE GAME
RIGHT THERE.
STEPHEN: IT'S A VALID QUESTION,
JONATHAN INDIA.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
I DON'T HATE IT.
HE GREW UP LOVING MICHAEL JORDAN
HIGHLIGHTS.
BUT THEER REAL REASON HE DOES
THE MOUTH OPEN, TONGUE OUT IS IT
RELAXES HIM AT THE PLATE.
DAN: STILL WITH THE FLEX ON THE
BASE HIT ON A SINGLE?
DANNY: I WONDER IF HE DID A FLEX
ON THAT WALK RIGHT THERE?
STEPHEN: LOOK AT THE ISO CAM.
HERE'S FARMER.
LAURER'S 84TH PITCH COMING UP.
SKIED IN THE AIR.
GOT HIM ON THE HANDS.
IT IS GOING TO DRIFT OVER.
JUST IN FOUL TERRITORY.
AND ANOTHER REASON WHY CRAIG
COUNSELL DIDN'T PINCH HIT FOR
LAURER LAST INNING WAS BECAUSE
HIS BIG GUNS IN THE BULLPEN ARE
COMING OFF BACK-TO-BACKS.
THE PITCH COUNTS WERE NOT
NECESSARILY HIGH.
BUT IF LAURER IS GOING THE WAY
HE HAS ONLY GIVING UP THE ONE
RUN.
AND HE COULD HELP OUT THE PEN A
LITTLE BIT.
YOU GUYS HAVE A SEVEN-GAME LEAD
IN THE DIVISION.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE.
THAT
DAN: NO QUESTION.
TALK ABOUT BEING IN A PICKLE.
BRAD BOX BURGER LOADED THE BASES
WITH NOBODY OUT AND ENDED UP
STRIKING OUT THE SIDE.
IT WENT RIGHT THROUGH THE TEETH
OF THE METS' BATTING ORDER.
I WAS WATCHING CRAIG COUNSELL
PLAYING IT SO COOL IN DUGOUT.
BOX BURGSER ANOTHER GUY --
INTERESTING STORY THAT SAVED A
TON OF GAMES IF THE RACE.
HE GIVES THE BREWERS SOME
EXPERIENCE IN THE BACK END OF
THAT BULLPEN.
THERE'S MORE TO THIS BULLPEN
THAN JOSH I HADDER IN THE NINTH
INNING AND DEVIN WILLIAMS
SETTING THINGS UP IN THE SEVENTH
AND THE EIGHTH.
THEY'VE GOT SOME LEFT-HANDED
OPTIONS.
RIGHT-HANDED OPTIONS AND SOME
EXPERIENCE.
BRETT SUTER KIND OF A LOW 3/4
DIFFERENT LOOKS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
LOOKS IN THAT BREWERS' BULLPEN.
THEY'RE SO GOOD IN THAT SEVENTH,
EIGHTH AND NINTH INNING.
AND THAT STARTING ROTATION IN
THE FRONT THREE, IT'S SO
IMPOSING THAT I THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE REALLY DIFFICULT UNLESS
THE REDS CAN HAVE SOME FUN.
IF THEY FIND THEMSELVES EIGHT,
NINE GAMES BACK OF THE ALL-STAR
BREAK, IT'S GOING TO BE HARD TO
CATCH THIS BREWER' TEAM.
STEPHEN: MILWAUKEE LOOKS LIKE A
POSTSEASON PROBLEM FOR THE REST
OF THE NATIONAL LEAGUE.
SO IF YOU HAVE THOSE ASPIRATIONS
OF WINNING A PENNANT IN THE
N.L., YOU WANT THOSE GUICE AS
FRESH AS CAN BE.
SO IF YOU ARE JOSH HARED, OR
BRETT SUITOR, YOU'VE GOT TO TAKE
IT WHEN YOU CAN GET IT.
>> YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS A POWERFUL BULLPEN.
SO DEFINITELY, IF YOU CAN GET
THEM SOME REST, YOU NEED TO GET
IT FOR THEM SO THEY CAN HAVE
THEIR STUFF WHEN IT REALLY
COUNTS.
YOU KNOW THE OLD CLICHE IT'S NOT
HOW YOU START, IT'S HOW YOU
FINISH.
YOU NEED THOSE GUYS TO BE FRESH
COME AUGUST, SEPTEMBER AND
PLAYOFF TIME.
STEPHEN: THE BEST BULLPEN
E.R.A.S.
THE LOW NEST BASEBALL THIS YEAR.
SO MILWAUKEE AT .377.
MIGUEL SANCHEZ FIRST ACTION IN
EITHER BULLPEN ON THIS FRIDAY
NIGHT.
STARTING TO WARM-UP AS LAURER
APPROACHES 90 PITCHES HERE IN
THE SIXTH.
LAST AT-BAT WHEN HE DROVE IN
THAT RUN WAS A FASTBALL UP IN
THE ZONE.
YOU TAKE A STHROT WITH THE
BREAKING BALL.
I LIKE TO SEE HIM ALMOST DOUBLE
UP AGAIN IF HE CAN LOCATE THIS
BREAKING BALL DOWN AND AWAY, I
THE HE WOULD HAVE A PRETTY GOOD
CHANCE TO GET A SWING AND A MISS
WITH BARNHART.
FASTBALL IN.
STEPHEN: I MAY NOT BE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE TUCKER BARNHART
FAN CLUB, BUT I'M DEFINITELY A
CARD-CARRYING MEMBER.
I JUST THINK HE IS -- HE IS A
TREMENDOUS BASEBALL PLAYER.
TWO-TIME GOLD GLOVE.
HAS GOT A SECOND ONE LAST YEAR.
BUT GETTING THE CALLS FROM REDS
GAMES IN THE PAST TWO SEASONS,
GRAVY AND WATCHING HIM WORK.
HE'S TOTALLY UNDERAPPRECIATED, I
THINK.
>> HE'S SO UNDERAPPRECIATED.
NOT ONLY IS HE A GREAT GUY OFF
THE FIELD.
BUT HE HANDLES THIS PITCHING
STAFF.
WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT YADIER
MOLINA BEING ONE OF THE BEST IN
THE LEAGUE, TUCKER BARNHART
CONTROLS THIS PITCHING STAFF.
HE GETS GUYS TO THROW BREAKING
BALLS IN THE DIRT KNOWING THAT
IT'S NOT GOING TO GET BY HIM.
HE'S SUCH A DELIGHT.
STEPHEN: BARNHART LEFTED TO LEFT
RIGHT AT CHRISTIAN YELICH.NS A .
WILLY A DA MESS IS GOING TO --
ADAMES WILL START US OFF IN THE
BOTTOM OF THE SIXTH.
STEPHEN: VISIT THE CINCINNATI
REDS' OFFICIAL YOUTUBE CHANNEL
TO VISIT HIGH LIGHTS.
JUST SCRIBE TO YOUTUBE.COM/REDS
SO YOU NEVER MACE NEW VIDEO.
ALL RIGHT, DANNY GRAVES, TAKE US
THROUGH WADE MILEY'S ENING.
DANNY: WELL, WADE MILEY BEING
WADE MILEY, GOOD TEMPO.
HE'S MIXING UP HIS PITCHES
ESPECIALLY WITH THAT CHANGEUP.
HE'S BEEN THROWING THE MAJORITY
OF CUTTERS MORE THAN HIS
FASTBALL GETTING IN ON THE HANDS
AND THAT CHANGEUP DOWN AND AWAY
AND OF COURSE, FIELDING HIS
POSITION BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT
THE PITCHERS ARE GREAT ATHLETES.
DAN: WITHOUT A DOUBT.
TAKE A LOOK AT THAT LINE SCORE.
FIVE SCORELESS.
FOUR PUNCHOUTS TWO WALKS.
A NICE PLAY ON THAT BUNT.
GOT SOME HELP FROM JONATHAN
THANK INDIA.
BUT WADE MILEY HAS BEEN IN
CONTROL AS YOU TOUCHED ON.
NOT AN OVERPOWERING GUY.
MIXED IN THE CHANGEUP, THE
CURVEBALL.
SO FAR HE'S KEPT THE BREWERS
OFF-BALANCE.
STEPHEN: A DA MESS SWINGS AT THE
FIRST PITCH.
-- ADAMES SWINGS AT THE FIRST
PITCH SOFTLY.
A LEADOFF KNOCK FOR ADAMES.
DANNY: THAT'S A CHANGEUP DOWN
AND AWAY ON THE FIRST PITCH OF
THE AT-BAT.
ADAMES HITS IT IN A PERFECT
SPOT.
THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE HE'S
BEEN IN.
ONE PITCH HE CAN GET A DOUBLE
PLAY.
AND DOESN'T REALLY CAUSE TOO
MUCH DAMAGE OUT THERE GETTING
THAT LEADOFF GUY ON.
STEPHEN: OUR ODDS COURTESY OF
BET M.G.M.
SHAME ON YOU IF YOU TOOK THE
UNDER THE WAY HE'S PLAY.
NOW, CHRISTIAN YELICH.
BALL TWO GOES INTO THE GLOVE OF
BARNHART.
DAN: THE BREWERS HAVE A LOT OF
THINGS GOING FOR THEM.
THE REDS, THE CUBS AND CARDINALS
BEATING EACH OTHER UP.
CUBS PUT IT TO THE CARDINALS
THIS AFTERNOON IN WRIGLEY.
SO IF YOU'RE THE BREWERS RIGHT
NO, YOU REALLY CAN DELIVER A
KNOCKOUT PUNCH TO THE REST OF
THIS DIVISION WITH THREE GAMES
LEFT BEFORE THE ALL-STAR BREAK.
SEVEN-GAME LEAD GOING INTO
TONIGHT'S PLAY.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE TOUGH TO
CATCH UNLESS SOMETHING HAPPENS,
UNFORESEEN INJURY OR FREDDIE
PERALTA.
THEIR PITCHING IS JUST TOO GOOD
IN THE STARTING END AND BACK END
OF THAT BULLPEN.
STEPHEN: YELICH, JUST OFF THE
HANDS, BUT IT HIT THE ZONE FOR A
STRIKE.
AND NOW, SAC AND GRAVY, WE ARE
NOT IN MILWAUKEE, BUT PLESAC AND
I JUST GOT A TEXT FROM ONE OF
THE OUTSTANDING BROADCASTERS FOR
THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS AND WE
TALKED ABOUT BATTING PRACTICE
TODAY AND THE EXTRA WORK THAT
CHRISTIAN YELICH WAS TAKING.
J.P. MOROSI WILL FILL US IN IN
JUST A MOMENT AS WE SEE THE
COUNT RUN IF BY WADE MILEY.
THE 3-2.
YELICH WILL FIGHT IT OFF.
AS PART OF THE ECONOMIC HE FELL
OFF.
I DON'T THINK HE REALIZED IT.
YEP, THERE IS IT.
I'D RATHER HIM LOSE HIS ELBOW
PAD THAN HIS BAT, DAN PLESAC.
I'M NOT JOKING ABOUT THAT.
THAT HAS BEEN A MASSIVE CONCERN
FOR HIM THE PAST FEW YEARS BUT
REALLY SINCE HIS MOST RECENT
RETURN IN THE MIDDLE OF MAY,
THERE HASN'T BEEN AN ISSUE.
DAN: AND I THINK EVERYBODY IN
MILWAUKEE ARE WAITING TO SEE
THAT POWER COME BACK.
HE'S MISSED A LOT OF TIMES WITH
SOME BACK ISSUES.
OUT IN FRONT OF THAT BREAKING
BALL RIGHT THERE.
STEPHEN: HE WILL GET UNDER IT.
NOW, LET'S GO TO JON MOROSI.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE ON HIS B.P.?
J.P.: YELICH WAS ACTUALLY THE
ONE BREWER WHOM WE SAW IN THE
CAGE FOR AN EXTEND PERIOD OF
TIME.
AND AS DAN JUST MENTIONED, IT
WAS GETTING OUT IN FRONT OF THAT
BREAKING BALL A MOMENT AGO.
THAT'S WHAT HE WAS WORKING ON
HERE WITH BREWERS' HITTING
COACH.
IT WAS THAT INSIDE PITCH THAT'S
BEEN A LITTLE VEXING FOR HIM
ESPECIALLY UP AND IN AND THAT
WE'VE HEARD SO MUCH AROUND THE
GAME IN RECENT YEARS.
THE HIGH FASTBALL, HOW DOMINANT
IT WAS IN THE SPORT THAT TEASE
ONE PITCH THAT YELL I, AT LEAST
TODAY, WAS WORKING ON.
STEPHEN: THANK YOU, J.P.
ONE BY ONE REDS PLAYERS WOULD
COME OUT OF THEIR CUP WILL HOUSE
TO WATCH YELLY DO SOME WORK.
CASTELLANOS SETTLED NEXT TO THE
CAGE TO WATCH AND OBSERVE THAT
AS THE AUDIENCE GREW, YELICH'S
B.P. PERFORMANCE ELEVATED MORE.
DAN: THE BREWERS ARE SEVEN GAMES
IN FRONT.
AND THEY'VE YET TO HAVE THEIR
BEST PLAYERS GOING.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF YELICH GETS
ROLLING.
THEY MIGHT GO AHEAD AND RUN AWAY
WITH THIS THING.
STEPHEN: GO AHEAD, GRAVY.
DANNY: THAT'S SCARY TO SEE IF
YELICH STARTS GETTING HOT AGAIN.
IT'S UNREAL HOW GOOD HE IS AND
HOW EASY HE STARTS HITTING THE
BALL AND DRIVING THE BALL.
DRIVING RUNNERS IN.
SEEING HIM A LOT IN THIS
DIVISION.
MAN, THOSE NUMBERS ARE
RIDICULOUS.
JUST IMAGINE HOW GOOD THIS TEAM
IS WHEN HE'S RIGHT.
STEPHEN: I THINK THE ONLY THING
MISSING IS THE SLUG.
RIGHT NOW, SLUGGING PERCENTAGE
IS THE LOWEST IT'S BEEN IN THIS
CAREER, BUT HIS ON-BASE
PERCENTAGE IS STILL AMONG THE
LEADERS IN MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
ABOUT 400.
HE'S IN THE TOP FIVE.
AND HE'S STILL HITTING THE BALL
RELATIVELY HARD.
SO HE'S GOT THE HARD HIT RATE TO
GO WITH THE WALK RATE.
BUT IT DOES SEEM LIKE IT'S A
MATTER OF TIME FOR ALL THINGS TO
LINEUP FOR YELICH.
DAN: HE'S A STAR PLAYER.
WE'RE GETTING TO THE ALL-STAR
BREAK AND IT'S HARD NOT TO
IGNORE.
24 RUNS BATTED IN.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE MILWAUKEE
WOULD BE.
SO THEY ACQUIRED HIM IN THE
LATER PART OF MAY.
IT'S NOT THE YELICH SHOW
ANYMORE, WHICH IS A GOOD THING
FOR MILWAUKEE.
THEY'RE WINNING DESPITE HIM NOT
BEING
STEPHEN: AFTER ADAMES WLEEDS THE
LEADOFF SINGLE, THAT SENDS US
INTO THE SENT.
-- SEVENTH.
STEPHEN: I'M STEPHEN NELSON
SITTING NEXT TO DAN PLESAC.
YOU HAVE DANNY GRAVES ON THE
TELECAST.
JOHN PAUL MOROSI REPORTING FROM
-- JON PAUL MOROSI REPORTING
FROM MILWAUKEE.
MLB ORIGINAL IS LIVE ON YOUTUBE
WITH NEW EPISODES EVERY SINGLE
WEEKFUL YOU CAN SEE YOUR
FAVORITE PLAYERS AND LEARN MORE
ABOUT THE GAME YOU LOVE MOST ON
YOUTUBE.COM.
HI.
WE SEE YOU.
IN THE OUTFIELD AND FAN FIELD IN
MILWAUKEE, WISCONSIN.
GAME TWO OF A FOUR-GAME SERIES
BETWEEN THE FIRST PLACE BREWERS
AND THE SECOND PLACE REDS.
SEVEN GAMES SEPARATE THEM IN THE
N.L. CENTRAL STANDINGS  ONE RUN
SEPARATES THEM TONIGHT AS WE SAY
HELLO TO MIGUEL SANCHEZ.
DAN: THIS WILL BE HIS EIGHTH
GAME OF THE SEASON.
YOU LOOK AT OPPONENTS .120.
STRIKE THROWER.
ONLY THREE HITS ALLOWED.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT STRIKEOUT
TO WALK RATIO, SEVEN STRIKEOUT
ANSWERED ONE WALK.
BUT KUDOS TO ERIC LAURER WHO IS
REALLY GOOD, SIX INNINGS OF
ONE-RUN BASEBALL.
HE WALKED FOUR, PUNCHED OUT
THREE.
89 PITCHES IF YOU'RE CRAIG
COUNSELL YOU WOULD HAVE SIGNED
UP FOR SIX INNINGS OF ONE-RUN
BASEBALL OF IT'S TIME FOR THAT
BREWERS' OFFENSE TO GET GOING.
WADE MILEY HAS HANDCUFFED THE
BREW CREW FROM THE BEGINNING.
STEPHEN: AND WADE MILEY IS
LEADING OFF IN THE BATTER'S BOX
FOR CINCINNATI.
DANNY: AND PEOPLE ARE WONDERING
WHY WADE MILEY IS HITTING
LEADING 1-0.
AND TO ME, IT'S BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY, ONE IS PITCH COUNT IS
ONLY AT 75.
BUT THE BULLPEN FOR THE REDS
THAT IS BEEN STRUGGLING SO YOU
WANT MILEY TO GO AS DEEP AS HE
CAN.
STEPHEN: OH!
WADE MILEY!
ROPED TO RIGHT FIELD, HUSTLING
TO SECOND BASE.
AND THE STARTER HAS A LEADOFF
DOUBLE.
THE THROW BOUNCES AWAY.
MILEY RUNNING TO THIRD!
HE SLIDES IN SAFELY!
DAN: NICHOLAS CASTELLANOS IS
SAYING, YOU KNOW WHAT, YOU TWO
GUYS MIGHT BE RIGHT.
HEADS UP PLAY.
STEPHEN: GET ON THE TANK.
GET ON THE TANK.
DAN: GET HIM SOME OXYGEN.
THEY ALL WANT TO TAKE A LAUGH.
WAY TO GO, WADE.
[LAUGHTER]
GET YOUR HEATER RIGHT HERE.
MIDDLE UP TOO, AND HE JUST GOES
AHEAD AND SMASHES THIS THING
DOWN IN THE CORNER LIKE SOME OF
THE REDS' SPEED STERS --
-- SPEEDSTERS.
DANNY GRAVES SAYS, HEY, I'M
GOING TO CONTINUE ON TO THIRD!
STEPHEN: WOW.
DANNY: HE LOOKED REAL HITTERISH
RIGHT THERE.
WHEN HE'S RUNNING THE BASES HE
KNEW WHAT HE WAS DOING.
STEPHEN: REAL HITTERISH, LESS
RUNNERISH.
FIRST BASE HIT FOR MILEY SINCE
2013.
HOW ABOUT IT?
AND IN SCORING POSITION FOR
JONATHAN INDIA WHO IS SCORCHING.
OOH.
GOOD PITCH FROM SANCHEZ.
DAN: HERE'S ANOTHER LOOK AT WADE
RIGHT HERE OF HE GETS TO FIRST
BASE.
AND HE'S THINKING EXTRA BASES,
RIGHT?
GETS TO SECOND BASE.
DOES PICK UP THE THIRD BASE
COACH.
SEES THE BALL DEFLEGGET FROM
ADAMES AND HE'S OFF TO THE
RACES.
-- BALL DEFLECT FROM ADAMES AND
HE'S OFF TO THE RACES.
DANNY: THAT WAS AN ATLETIC
SLIDE.
STEPHEN: THE GAIT WAS FINE,
WADE.
DON'T LISTEN TO MOMENT I'M JUST
A TV CLOWN.
HE'S 90 FEET AWAY.
DANNY: HE'S STILL TRYING TO
CATCH HIS BREATH.
DAN: IF YOU'RE DAVID BELL, I WAS
THINKING, I LOVE THE ENTHUSIASM
THERE AT THIRD BASE.
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHEN: SHOUTS TO EVERY YOUTH
COACH WHO WAS SAYING THERE'S NO
OXYGEN DOWN THERE.
NO, NO, NO HANDS ON YOUR HEAD.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
IT'S ALL OVER THE PLACE.
INDIA IS 2-3.
HE'S BEHIND IN THE COUNT.
1-2.
FORMER FIFTH OVERALL PICK.
BALL TWO.
DAN: PROBABLY HIS BEST SECONDARY
PITCH IS HIS CHANGEUP IF YOU'RE
INDIAN, A BETS ARE OFF WHEN YOU
GET TO TWO STRIKES.
BREWERS WILL ARE TRYING TO CUT
THIS LEADOFF.
GARCIA, REALLY STRONG THROWER
OUT IN RIGHT FIELD.
STEPHEN: SANCHEZ JUST INTO THE
GAME FOR LAURER.
GREETED RUDELY BY MILEY.
NOW THE 2-2 TO INDIA.
FOULED BACK.
HERE'S MILEY'S ARIEFL TO SECOND
BASE.
Dan: THAT'S THE END OF THE RACE,
HE'S LOOKING FOR SOME OXYGEN.
HANDS ON HIS KNEES.
WE'VE ALL BEEN THERE, HAVEN'T
WE?
Danny: I'M TIRED JUST WATCHING
HIM CONTINUING TO RUN.
MAKES ME TIRED.
Stephen: IN THE COMMENTS
SECTION, HE HULKED SMASHED --
HULK SMASHED THAT BASEBALL.
Dan: THERE'S THE STRAIGHT
CHANGUP.
HE WAS IN SWING MODE THERE AND
HE TAKES ADVANTAGE OF IT.
THAT CHANGEUP DOWN AND IN.
ALMOST REACTS LIKE A SCREWBALL.
THERE'S THE LOOK AT IT.
CIRCLE CHANGEUP.
LOCATES IN IT A GREAT SPOT.
>> THAT'S 96-MILE-PER-HOURS.
USUALLY YOU DON'T SEE
RIGHTY-ON-RIGHTY.
Dan: THIS IS THE FIRST TIME HE'S
BEEN UNDER .200.
HIS BATTING AVERAGE AT .299.
HE'S BEEN IN A PROLONGED SLUMP.
MAYBE THIS WILL GET HIM TO GET
BACK ONTO THE BASEBALL.
Stephen: THIS IS AN
89-MILE-PER-HOUR OFFERING TO
START THE A.B.
Dan: YOU DON'T AS A GENERAL RULE
LIKE TO START OFF WITH A FIRST
PITCH CHANGEUP.
AS A GENERAL RULE YOU'LL HAVE
OLDER PITCHING COACHES SAY
YOU'RE NOT CHANGING OFF OF
ANYTHING.
YOU HAVEN'T GAUGED THE FASTBALL
YET.
BUT HE ELECTED TO GO WITH THE
CHANGEUP ON THE FIRST PITCH.
Stephen: DAVID BELL CALLS JESSE
A NATURAL HITTER.
CHOPPED IT DOWEL.
0-2.
IN THE MIDST OF A LITTLE SLUMP
HERE.
BUT PERHAPS WITH A RIGHT-HANDER
COMING UP TO RELIVE THE LEFTY
LAUER, IT'LL TURN THINGS AROUND.
18 OF HIS 19 DINGERS AGAINST
RIGHT-HANDED PITCHERS.
Dan: THAT DOES MAKE IT TOUGH
WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE HISTORY WITH
THE GUY, FACING HIM FOR THE
FIRST TIME, RUNNER ON THIRD.
TRYING TO GET SOMETHING UP IN
THE AIR THREES FOR A SACRIFICE
FLY.
Stephen: GETS AWAY FROM SANCHEZ,
ELEVATING ON THE HEATER.
Dan: HARD TO DO THAT FASTBALL
THAT'S ALMOST A NONCOMPETITIVE
PITCH.
AT NO WOINT WAS JESSE WINKER
GOING TO OFFER THAT FOR A
STRIKE.
YOU HATE TO SELL OUT AND SIT ON
A PITCH WHEN A GUY THROWS 95 BUT
YOU HAVE TO THINK A CHANGEUP
WOULD BE COMING FROM SANCHEZ.
Danny: 100%.
AFTER CHANGING EYE LEVEL P WITH
THAT FASTBALL PROBABLY BET THE
HOUSE THE CHANGEUP IS COMING,
RIGHT?
Stephen: SANCHEZ HAS THE SIGN
FROM PENA, READIES FOR THE 1-2
WITH MILEY ON THIRD.
BOUNCES IN FRONT.
TELLS MILEY TO HOLD.
Dan: HE THROWS A HARD CHANGEUP.
ANYWHERE FROM 88 TO
90-MILE-PER-HOURS.
IT'S A CIRCLE CHANGEUP.
MUCH LIKE DEVIN WILLIAMS WITH
THROWS A HARD CHANGEUP ALSO.
THE KEY TO THAT IS, YOU HAVE TO
HAVE ENOUGH GIDDYUP ON THEIR
FASTBALL AND HE DOES.
WE'VE SEEN THE FASTBALL ALREADY
96-MILE-PER-HOURS.
BUT THAT JUST -- THAT'S HIS
GO-TO PITCH, DON'T BE SURPRISED
IF HE DOESN'T COME RIGHT BACK
WITH IT AGAIN.
Stephen: WINKER, NINE HOME RUNS
AGAINST THE BREWERS.
GOT A PIECE OF IT.
Dan: THAT'S WHAT MAKES IT SO
TOUGH, TO SIT BACK ON A CHANGUP.
THAT HEATER WAS
96-MILE-PER-HOURS.
YOU ALMOST HAVE TO GO UP THERE.
OUR COLLEAGUE HERE AND FORMER
CINCINNATI RED SEAN CASEY ALWAYS
SAID YOU HAVE TO HIT OFF THE
FASTBALL, GO UP THERE, LOOK FOR
A FASTBALL.
AND ADJUST OFF THAT YOU CAN'T GO
UP LOOKING FOR A CHANGEUP,
PARTICULARLY WHEN A GUY THROWS
AS HARD AS SANCHEZ DOES.
Danny: HITTING WAS EASY FOR THE
MAYOR TOO.
HE WOULD JUST ROLL OUT OF BED
AND SEND IT OVER TO LEFT-FIELD
LINE FOR A DOUBLE.
Stephen: OUR FRIEND SEAN CASEY.
SANCHEZ MISSES AWAY.
FILL HER UP.
RESPECT FOR WINKER, WHAT WE'RE
SEEING FROM SANCHEZ.
Dan: IT IS BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
ONE EYE ON THE ON-DECK, YOU HAVE
CASTELLANOS NOAH ON THE
CASTELLANO ON THE ON DECK.
RIGHT NOW HE'S STRUGGLE, FIRST
TIME HE'S BEEN BELOW .300 IN A
WHILE.
Stephen: CASTELLANOS LURKING IN
THE ON-DECK CIRCLE.
HE AND WINKER ON PACE TO BECOME
THE FIRST REDS OUTFIELD DUO TO
BOTH HIT .300 IN 44 YEARS.
LAST HAPPENED IN 1977.
CAN YOU NAME THE TWO OUTFIELDERS
IN 1977?
POP TRIVIA QUIZ.
Dan: I CAN NAME THE TWO
OUTFIELDERS.
ONLY BECAUSE I READ IT EARLIER.
I'M ALL ABOUT HONESTY HERE.
GEORGE FOSTER AND KEN GRIFF
GRIFFEY.
I DIDN'T MEAN TO SPOIL IT FOR
YOU.
Stephen: I APPRECIATE THE
INTEGRITY AND HONESTY.
YOU COULD BE A GREAT GOLFER.
Dan: I COULD HAVE SOUNDED REALLY
SMART IF I JUST THREW THE NAMES
OUT.
Stephen: NO ONE WOULD HAVE
KNOWN.
THIS IS A NICE BATTLE WE'RE
WATCHING WITH WINKER AN SANCHEZ.
WHAT DO YOU OFFER HERE?
Danny: 3-2 CHANGEUP.
THAT'S HIS BESTOFF SPEED PITCH.
TRYING TO GO FOR A STREUT RIGHT
NOW.
Dan: IF YOU WALK HIM YOU'VE GOT
A RIGHTY UP NEXT.
Dan: THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
WE'VE SEEN WINKER CAUGHT, I
DON'T WANT TO SAY CAUGHT, IN
THAT IN-BETWEEN AREA.
HE DOESN'T LOOK AS COMFORTABLE
AT THE PLATE, DANNY, AS HE DID
TWO AND A HALF OR THREE WEEKS
AGO.
Danny: IN THE EVEN CLOSE.
THAT'S THE DEFENSIVE SWING RIGHT
NOW.
I KNOW IT'S 97-MILE-PER-HOURS
COMING -- COMING IN ON HIS HANDS
A LITTLE BIT.
HE DOESN'T LOOK COMFORTABLE.
EVEN THE BALLS HE'S TAKING, NOT
SWINGING AT, DOESN'T LOOK
COMFORTABLE.
Stephen: GOT A PIECE OF IT.
IF YOU'RE WIPGER, THAT'S A GOOD
JOB BEING ABLE TO FIGHT A GOOD
PITCH OFF AFTER GETTING A
FASTBALL THAT WENT IN.
THAT WAS A GOOD CHANGEUP THAT
HAD SOME DOWNWARD MOVEMENT.
DOWN AND AWAY.
WINKER DOES A GOOD JOB GETTING A
PIECE OF THAT HE MIGHT BE ABLE
TO GET UP IN THE AIR WITH
ANOTHER PITCH.
Stephen: WADE MILEY ON THIRD
BASE.
GAVE US THE SECOND HARDEST HIT
BALL BY ANY BATTER IN THE GAME.
104.8 OFF THE BAT OF MILEY.
REACHED THIRD.
SECOND RUN OF THE REDS.
WINKER DOWN THE LINE INTO RIGHT
FIELD.
MILEY WILL TROT HOME.
WINKER HAS EXTRA DAYSES.
THE REDS HAVE A 2-0 LEAD.
Danny: I THOUGHT THE KEY TO THAT
AT-BAT WAS THE OFFSPEED PITCH.
BOUGHT HIM ANOTHER PITCH.
Stephen: DID MILEY JUST SAY
ABOUT TIME?
Dan: I THINK.
SO WADE MILEY HAS BEEN THE STAR
OF THE AFTERNOON.
THE NIGHT SO FAR.
THERE'S ANOTHER CHANGEUP.
THIS ONE A LITTLE BIT UP IN THE
ZONE.
WINKER HITS A GOOD PASS ON THIS
ONE.
THAT'S A BIG INSURANCE RUN RIGHT
NOW.
PARTICULARLY THE WAY THAT WIDE
MAILY IS THROWING IT.
YOU SEE HIM APPRECIATES IT RIGHT
THERE.
Stephen: THE RIDERS.
THAT'S THE SIGN.
TALKED TO WINKER ABOUT THAT.
Danny: THAT COULD BE WHAT TURNS
THE NEXT FEW GAMES AROUND FOR
HIM.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE SLUMP HE'S
BEEN IN, HAVING AN AT-BAT,
THAT'S AS PROFESSIONAL AS IT
GETS.
FIGHTING OFF NASTY PITCHES.
ABLE TO GET THAT DOUBLE TO DRIVE
IN MILEY.
Stephen: ALSTAR JESSE WINKER AND
NOW ALL-STAR CASTELLANOS.
CINCINNATI IN THE TOP OF THE
SEVENTH.
AN IMPORTANT MATCHUP FOR THE
CINCINNATI REDS.
TRYING TO KEEP THE GAP BETWEEN
THEM AND THE BREWERSING MORABLE
HEADING INTO THE SECOND HALF OF
THE SEASON.
Dan: YOU DON'T NECESSARILY WANT
TO LOOK AHEAD, IT'S TOUGH TO DO
IN BASEBALL.
BUT YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
PITCHERS COMING UP TOMORROW AND
SUNDAY.
PE RAL TA AND WOODRUFF GOING
SATURDAY AND SUNDAY.
THEY LOST A TOUGH ONE LAST
NIGHT.
5-3.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT GAME TO
TRY TO PULL OUT.
Stephen: CASTELLANOS.
Dan: THEY'RE SEVEN GAMES BEHIND
THE BLUE CREW.
YOU HATE TO FALL THAT FAR BACK.
Stephen: I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE, MOST OF THEM ARE FANS.
THEY'RE PUTTING A LOT OF
IMPORTANCE, A LOT OF EYEBALLS,
ON THIS SEVEN-GAME STRETCH,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE TRADE
DEADLINE LOOMING.
FOLKS FEEL IF THIS SERIES, IT'S
CALLED A SEVEN-GAME SERIES, GETS
AWAY FROM CINCINNATI, THEN MAYBE
THEY'LL BE SELLERS LIKE THE
CUBS.
BUT THERE'S STILL A FULL SECOND
HALF OF BASEBALL TO BE PLAYED.
Dan: IT'S ALMOST KIND OF LIKE A
PANIC MOMENT RIGHT NOW THE NEXT
COUPLE OF WEEKS IN JULY, MOVING
UP TO THE TRADE DEADLINE.
EVERYBODY JUST FEELS LIKE, IT'S
ABOUT THIS SERIES.
THERE'S A LOT OF TIME LEFT.
COME BACK AFTER THE BREAK AND
MAKE UP SOME GROUND IF YOU LOSE
ANY GROUND.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GET TOO FAR
BEHIND THESE GUYS ESPECIALLY
AFTER THEY GET SOME REST AT THE
ALL-STAR BREAK.
Stephen: DANNY GRAVES, DAN, AND
STEPHEN HERE.
CASTELLANOS.
VOTTO GETTING LOOSE IN THE
ON-DECK CIRCLE.
CASTELLANOS TO THIRD.
NICE PICK FROM URIAS.
TWO DOWN.
Dan: NICE PLAY BY URIAS.
A SCOOP AND STRONG THROW ACROSS
THE DIAMOND TO GET CASTELLANOS.
Danny: COUNCIL SAID BEFORE THE
GAME, FOUR SHORTSTOPS ON THE
INFIELD, RIGHT?
THAT'S A GLOVE OF A SHORTSTOP
OVER THERE MAKING IT LOOK EASY.
Stephen: WHEN COLTEN WONG COMES
BACK FROM INJURY, THAT'S HOW
CONFIDENT HE IS IN THE INFIELD.
THEY MADE STRIDES AFTER MOVING
FROM FIRST BASE TO SECOND.
THE INTENTIONAL PASS GIVEN TO
VOTTO.
TO GET TO EUGENIO SUAREZ.
Dan: SUAREZ SCORED THE REDS'
FIRST RUN.
WALKED, WAS DRIVEN IN BY A
BULLET FROM BARNHART.
I EXPECT A BETTER SECOND HALF
FROM EUGENIO.
THE BATTING AVERAGE IS DOWN.
BUT I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
A MUCH IMPROVED SUAREZ
POSTALL-STAR BREAK.
Stephen: BOTH OF THESE LINEUPS
HAVE X FACTORS.
Dan: THROW YELICH INTO THE MIX.
THE YELICH WE'VE SEEN SO FOR A
THE FIRST # 0-PLUS GAMES IS NOT
THE YELICH THEY'RE ACCUSTOMED TO
SEEING.
Stephen: SANCHEZ GETS IN TO
SUAREZ.
YOU SEE HIS BATTING AMPLE AT
.176.
THE HEST AVERAGE IN A SINGLE
SEASON, THIS IS A FRANCHISE
THAT'S BEEN AROUND A LONG TIME.
GRANTED, THE GAME HAS CHANGED.
BATTING AVERAGE ISN'T AS VALUED,
SEEMINGLY, BY THE GAME AS IT
ONCE WAS.
IT'S .106 IF YOU'RE NOT HITTING.
Dan: I THINK HE TRIED TO BLOCK
THAT ONE WITH THE RIGHT HAND.
LOOKED LIKE IT MIGHT HAVE
DEFLECKED OFF THAT HAND.
YOU CAN SEE HE HAS TAPE ON HIS
INDEX FINGER THERE.
THIS IS ANOTHER CHANGEUP THAT
SPIKED INTO THE GROUND.
TRIES TO GET OVER AND COVER IT.
FORTUNATELY, DOESN'T HIT THE
HAND.
BUT HE KIND OF WENT AFTER THAT
ONE TOO WITH AN OPEN HAND.
MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
COMES NATURAL TO TRY TO KEEP THE
BALL IN FRONT.
Stephen: A REFLEK, JUST TRYING
TO KEEP IT IN FRONT OF YOU BY
ANY MEANS NECESSARY.
STRIKE THREE.
SANCHEZ LIVES A PAIR ON SECOND
AND THIRD BUT THAT'S ONLY AFTER
JESSE WINKER PICKED UP HIS 50TH
RIB EYE OF THE SEASON -- RIBBY
OF THE SEASON TO WADE
MILEY.
IT'S NOW 2-0, CINCINNATI.
Stephen: IT'S NOW A TWO-RUN
BALLGAME.
Dan: ROLL OUT THE BARREL.
HEARD THAT SONG MANY TIMES FROM
1986 THROUGH 1992, PLAYING IN
BEERLAND.
Stephen: CHASE PETERSON.
LEADOFF FOR MILWAUKEE.
START OFF THIS FRAME ON A
POSITIVE NOTE TO SPARK A
COMEBACK.
STILL FACING WADE MILEY.
THE SCORER OF THAT SECOND RUN OF
THE GAME.
Dan: THAT WAS A TOUGH AT-BAT
FROM JESSE WINKER TOO.
THERE'S A REASON HE'S IN THE
ALL-STAR GAME.
Stephen: WHAT WE HAVE HERE IS A
COUPLE OF LOUISIANA KIDS FACING
OFF.
AND PETERSON HITS IT HARD.
BOUNCES OUT OF THE REACH OF
AQUINO.
HE'S GOING TO HUSTLE OVER TO
SECOND BASE.
SLIDING IN.
BUT HE'S OUT.
JESSE WINKER IN LEFT FIELD.
TO JONATHAN INA APPLYING THE
TAG.
Dan: WE SAW WITH THE BAT IN THE
TOP HALF OF THE SECOND INNING
AND A HEADS UP PLAY BY WINKER
HERE, BACKING UP TO PLAY.
A TERRIFIC PLAY HERE.
THROWS A STRIKE TO SECOND BASE.
IT MAY BE THE FIRST OF MANY
ALL-STAR GAMES THAT COME, YOU
SEE JONATHAN INDIA LOVES IT,
THROWS A STRIKE.
PETERSON IS OUT EASILY AT SECOND
BASE.
HEADS UP WITH THE STICK IN THE
TOP HALF.
HEADS UP WITH THE GLOVE AND THE
ARM IN THE BOTTOM HALF OF THE
SEVENTH HERE.
JESSE WINKER TO THE RESCUE FOR
THE REDS.
Stephen: SAW MILEY.
ATTABOY, WINKER.
IT DROPS.
CASTELLANOS.
HE PLAYS IT TO THROW TO SECOND.
NOT GOING TO GET HIM.
SO INSTEAD OF BACK-TO-BACK
DOUBLES AND A 2-1 GAME, THE
GREAT BACKUP FROM WINKER AND
LEFT -- IN LEFT THROWING OUT
PETERSON KEEPS MILWAUKEE OFF THE
BOARD.
Dan: THERE'S NOT MUCH YOU CAN DO
IF YOU'RE CASTELLANOS.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE SOFT SERBS
JUST INSIDE THE LINE.
UNFORTUNATELY WITH THAT
INSIDE-OUT SWING, IT HAS SO MUCH
ANGLE, IT HITS AN CURVES TOWARD
THAT RIGHT FIELD.
Dan: HE HAD A HIT IN HIS LAST
AT-BAT.
HAD A BIG HOME RUN IN THE SERIES
AGAINST THE METS EARLIER IN THE
WEEK.
SOME ACTION IN THE REDS'
BULLPEN.
Stephen: HENRY THE RIGHT-HANDER
GETTING READY.
PENA TO THE LEFT SIDE.
GETS PENA.
OUTSTANDING DEFENSIVE WORK IN
THE SEVENTH INNING OF THE
CINCINNATI REDS.
>> WHAT A GREAT PLAY BY --
Dan: WHAT A GREAT PLAY BY FARMER
TO PLANT HIS FEET.
THAT'S NOT AN EASY ONE, THAT IS
IN BETWEEN HOPS.
DOES A GREAT JOB, FARMER,
GETTING HIS FOOTING.
JOEY VOTTO DOES A MARVELOUS JOB
AT FIRST BASE.
THIS IS A TOUGH THROW.
IT'S ONE OF THOSE WHERE YOU'RE
NOT SURE IF YOU WANT TO GO OUT
AND GET IT, WIDE MILEY LOVES IT.
>> AND THAT'S ONE OF THOSE PLAYS
BY KYLE FARMER, HE KNEW WHO WAS
RUNNING THE BASES.
HE KNEW IT WAS PENA, THE
CATCHER, THAT HE HAD TIME TO SET
HIS FEET THERE AND MAKE A GOOD,
STRONG THROW.
JOEY VOTTO HAS BEEN MAKING THOSE
PICKS HIS WHOLE CAREER, THOSE
IN-BETWEEN NASTY HOPS LIKE THAT.
Stephen: PINCHING HITTER FOR
MILWAUKEE, PAB ROW REYES.
IN THE PITCHER'S SPOT.
NEAR THE BOTTOM OF THE ORDER.
SENSING URGENCY IN THE LATE
INNINGS HERE.
85TH PITCH.
THIS IS DOWN AND IN.
IN THE COMMENTS SECTION, DEFENSE
WITH AN EXCLAMATION POINT.
WE'VE SEEN SOME GREAT DISPLAYS
THE LAST FEW FOR THE REDS.
NOT OUT OF THIS INNING.
3-0 TORAY YES, SIR.
Dan: A LOT OF THAT HAS TO DO
WITH THE TEMPO THAT WIDE MILEY
HAS OUT THERE ON THE MOUND.
I KNOW IT SOUNDS KIND OF PERIOD
WEIRD BUT WHEN YOU WORK QUICK
YOUR DEFENDERS ARE READY TO
PLAY.
Stephen: THAT'S A VETERAN MOVE.
SPINS A LITTLE BREAKING BALL IN
THERE JUST IN CASE HE'S SWINGING
ON THE 3-0 PITCH.
REYES PULLED THE HANDS IN LIFTED
TO LEFT FIELD.
EASY PLAY FOR WINKER.
Dan: PITCH 10G 1.
3-0 BREAKING BALL FOR THE
STRIKE.
INNING.
DOESN'T NEED ANY HELP.
STILL 2-0, CINCY.
WE'RE ON TO THE EIGHTH INNING.
Stephen: MLB AND T-MOBILE
BRINGING AN ALL NEW DERBY
EXPERIENCE TO FANS.
THIS AUGUST.
ED REALITY APP PROVIDES
UNPRECEDENTED 3-D VIEWS FOR THE
HOME RUN DERBY IN DENVER,
COLORADO.
DOWNLOAD IT TODAY AT MLB.COM/AR.
IN THE COMMENT SECTION, WE SEE
DODGER FILMS, WHAT AN AT-BAT.
Danny: THIS IS A PATIENT AT-BAT.
BEHIND IN THE COUNT.
HE MADE SANCHEZ THROW A LOT OF
PITCHES.
RUNS HIS COUNT TO THREE BALLS
TWO STRIKES AND FOULED OFF SOME
REALLY NASTY PITCHES.
BUT THERE'S SEVERAL REASONS WHY
JESSE WINKER IS HEADED TO DENVER
FOR THE ALL-STAR GAME.
STAYS ON HIS CHANGEUP HERE AND
HITS A BALL, GREAT THROW IN
LEFT-FIELD LINE IN THE BOTTOM OF
THE SEVENTH.
THAT AT-BAT RIGHT THERE GETS
THAT BATTING AVERAGE BACK UP
OVER .300.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A TERRIFIC
YOUNG PLAYER.
Stephen: GIVE US YOUR
PERSPECTIVE?
>> HE DIDN'T LOOK COMFORTABLE
SWINGING AT THE FASTBALLS.
MAYBE HE WAS JUST WAITING TO GET
A CHANGEUP HE COWL HIT.
AFTER THE AT-BAT THAT COULD BE
AN AT-BAT THAT CHAIPS THE RS OF
THE HALF FOR HIM AND CONTINUES
TO GET HIM BACK ON THE HOT
STREAK FOR THE REDS.
Stephen: NEW PITCHER FOR THE
BREWERS, DAN PLESAC.
STRICKLAND.
Dan: GUY WITH A BIG ARM.
HE HAD A ROCKY POSTSEASON.
GAVE UP SIX HOME RUNS IN HIS
INITIAL VOYAGE INTO THE
POSTSEASON.
THE GIANTS STILL WON EVERYTHING
THAT YEAR.
BUT HARD TELE, BIG HARD SLIDER.
THERE'S A GOOD LOOK AT IT.
96.
KIND OF AN OLD COUNTRY HARDBALL
FOR MR. STRICKLAND.
HE IS WHAT HE IS.
HE'S A FASTBALL SLIDER GUY.
GOING TO PUMP SOME HEATERS IN
THERE.
Stephen: 10.1 SCORELESS INNINGS
SO STAR.
STARING AT AN 0-1 COUNT HERE IN
THE TOP OF THE EIGHTH.
REDS UP 2-0.
Dan: THAT'S A TERRIFIC PITCH.
9 #-MILE-PER-HOURS WITH A LITTLE
CUTTING ACTION ON IT NO.
A LOT YOU CAN DOE DO WITH THAT
PITCH, YOU ALMOST HAVE TO TAKE
IT.
IF HE CONTINUES TO MAKE THOSE
KIND OF PITCHES HE'S GOING TO
RUN THROUGH A LOT OF LINEUPS.
HE'S THROWN THE BALL REALLY WELL
SINCE PUTTING ON THE BREWER UNI.
Stephen: BASE HIT, FLEXED ON
HIM.
WALK.
STRIKES OUT HERE IN THE EIGHTH.
Dan: FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL UP IN
THE ZONE.
A TOUGH PITCH TO HIT.
LOOKS SO INVITING BUT I THINK
DANNY, WHAT MAKES IT SO TOUGH IS
THE HIGH STRIKE IS CALLED FOR A
STRIKE.
NO LONGER THAT CHEST HIGH
FASTBALL.
IT'S KIND OF FLIP A COIN IF IT'S
GOING TO BE COULD OR NOT.
A LOT OF PITCHERS ARE MAKING A
LIVING NOW PITCHING UP IN THE
ZONE.
Stephen: I WANT TO HEAR FROM
J.P. ABOUT KYLE FARMER.
J.P.: HE'S ONE OF ONLY EIGHT
PLAYERS TO START THREES FIVE
GAMES IN THE SAME SEASON AT
CATCHER, FIRST, SECOND, AND
THIRD.
THAT ATHLETICISM WAS ON
BRILLIANT DISPLAY IN THE LAST
HALF INNING.
THE ONLY OTHER RED TO DO SO WAS
HIENY PIKES BACK IN 1902.
Stephen: I HAD HIS CARD.
JUST KIDDING.
THANK YOU, J.P.
SERIOUSLY WORK FARMER, HE
DESERVES A TON OF CREDIT FOR HOW
HE HAS TAKEN THAT ATHLETICISM TO
MULTIPLE POSITIONS.
AND YOU KNOW, EVEN DAVID BELL
WILL SAY HE DIDN'T REALLY GIVE
HIM A CHANCE INITIALLY.
FARMER TALKED TO HIM MULTIPLE
TIMES.
AND HE'S MADE THE PLAYS TO PROVE
THAT HE CAN MAKE ALL THE PLAYS.
INCLUDING A TERRIFIC ONE IN THE
LAST INNING TO HELP OUT WADE
MILEY.
HE DID NOT GO THERE.
NOW HE'S IN AN UNFAVORABLE COUNT
2-1.
THIS IS THE FIRST GAME I'VE
CALLED IN THIS 2021 SEASON,
GRANTED, WE'RE DOING IT OFF THE
MONITOR, BUT IT'S GREAT TO HEAR
THE ACTUAL AMBIENCE AND SOUNDS
FROM A BALLPARK, NOT FROM A
SPEAKER IN THE BALLPARK.
FOLKS ARE ENJOYING THE RETURNS,
BALLPARKS ALL AROUND THE LEAGUE,
SAFELY OF COURSE.
Dan: IF YOU'VE NEVER HAD A
CHANCE TO GO TO THAT BALLPARK IN
MILWAUKEE, YOU SHOULD.
AMERICAN FAMILY FIELD.
RETRACTABLE ROOF.
GREAT CONCESSION STAND AS GOOD
AS ANY PLACE IN THE BIG LEAGUES.
NOT A BAD SEAT IN THE HOUSE.
IT'S A WONDERFUL PLACE TO WATCH
A BALLGAME.
Stephen: ESPECIALLY THIS YEAR
THE WAY THE CREW HAS BEEN GOING.
SEVEN GAMES CLEAR.
UP THE REDS IN THE CENTRAL.
RESULT PENDING HERE TONIGHT.
2-2 RIGHT DOWN THE CHUTE.
BACK-TO-BACK STRIKEOUT HERE'S IN
THE EIGHTH FOR HUNTER STRIK LAN.
Dan: WE'VE SEEN SO MUCH WITH
BULLPENS BEING VOLATILE, GUYS
MOVING FROM ONE PLACE TO THE
NEXT AND NOT HAVING IT.
THE BREWERS MIGHT HAVE HIT A
HOME RUN WITH HUNTER STRICKLAND.
HE LOOK AS CONFIDENT AS WE'VE
SEEN HIM IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS.
FASTBALL HAS SOME LIFE, A COUPLE
OF GOOD BREAKING BALLS IN THAT
SEQUENCE TO FARMER.
ADD HIM TO A LIST, A GROWING
LIST OF A LOT OF STRONG ARMS
THEY HAVE OUT THERE IN THAT
BULLPEN.
I THINK THE LAST THING YOU WANT
TO DO IS GET INTO A FIGHT WITH A
BULLPEN WITH THIS BREWERS TEAM.
THEY CAN COME AT YOU,
LEFT-HANDED, RIGHT-HANDED, YOU
WANT TO STAY AWAY FROM HEYEDER
IN THE NINTH.
Stephen: THOSE TWO STRIKES --
STRIKEOUTS GIVE THEM ONE IN THE
NIGHT.
STRIKE ONE TO BARNHART.
TUCKER BARNHART GETTING THE
START TONIGHT FOR DAVID BELL'S
CLUB EVEN THOUGH IT WAS AGAINST
A LEFTY STARTER, ERIC LAUER,
BECAUSE HE'S THAT MAN'S CATCHER.
WIDE MILEY WHO IS STANDING IN
THE ON-DECK CIRCLE.
HE ROPED A DOUBLE AND GOT TO
THIRD LAST TIME UP, WHY NOT TRY
HIM AGAIN.
Dan: AND STILL GOT THE HIGHEST
EXIT VELOCITY OF THE GAME SO FAR
OF ANYBODY.
Stephen: LOOKING AT THE
COMMENTARY SECTION.
THE BULLPEN IS NOT MOVING.
AIN'T MOVING.
THE REDS ASK, WHAT DO YOU GUYS
THINK?
WILL WE SEE MILEY BACK OUT FOR
THE EIGHTH INING?
THE BREWERS RESPOND, WE WOULDN'T
BE UPSET IF YOU TOOK HIM OUT.
0-1 TO BARNHART.
FOUL.
Dan: ONE THING THAT'S REFRESHING
WHEN YOU WATCH STRICKLAND, HE'S
AT TIMES HAD AN INABILITY, HAD A
DIFFICULT TIME GETTING THE
BREAKING BALL OTHER FOR A STRIKE
BUT WE SEE HE'S ABLE TO GET BACK
TO A 1-1 COUNT.
A GOOD BREAKING BALCH DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE A GREAT ONE.
HE THROWS SO HARD SO HARD TO
COVER BOTH.
HE'S SHOWN SOME LIFE WITH THAT
FASTBALL UP IN THE ZONE.
COMMANDING THE BREAKING BALL
WHICH IS A PLUS TO GO ALONG WITH
THE BIG HEATER.
HE'S THROWING THE BALL GREAT.
Stephen: THIS IS DOWN 2-2.
BARNHART IN THE FINAL YEAR OF A
FOUR-YEAR CONTRACT.
LAST CLUB OPTION FOR NEXT
SEASON.
I'VE SEEN HIS NAME BEING THROWN
AROUND, IF IN BOLD, AND IN
STARS, IF THE REDS DECIDE TO
MOVE PIECES OUT AT THE DEADLINE,
I PERSONALLY LOVE BARNHART IN A
REDS UNIFORM, I'M NOT JA --
ADVOCATING FOR THAT.
BUT WOULD BE A BIG PICKUP FOR
ANYBODY IN NEED OF A BACKSTOP.
THE 2-2 FROM STRICKLAND.
SWUNG ON AND MISSED.
HUNTER STRICKLAND STRIKES OUT
THE SIDE IN THE EIGHTH INNING..
STILL DOWN 2-0.
Stephen: WADE MILEY IS BACK OUT
THERE FOR THE EIGHTH INNING FOR
THE REDS.
SORRY, BREWERS.
BREWERS FANS.
HE'S NOT COMING OUT.
# 8 PITCHES SO FAR.
E.R.A. HAS BEEN LOWERED TO 2.83
ON THE SEASON.
Dan: COMING UP, URIAS, ADAMES
AND YELICH.
HE'S BEEN UNPREDICTABLE, THROWN
STRIKES, MADE A COUPLE OF NICE
PLAYS DEFENSIVELY.
THE REDS TOO HAVE MADE STELLAR
PLAYS BEHIND HIM.
ADD THAT UP TO 7/8 OF SHUT UTAH
BASEBALL.
Stephen: URIAS APPARENTLY GOT A
PIECE OF THAT.
STRIKE ONE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN REVIEW
THAT, RIGHT?
DANNY, AS YOU'VE WATCHED WADE
MILEY THROW INTO THE EIGHTH
INNING, WHAT HAS IMPRESSED YOU
MOST ABOUT HIS OUTING?
Danny: THE THING ABOUT MILEY, HE
JUST GETS THE BALL AND GETS BACK
UP THERE AND HE COMMANDS THE
STRIKE ZONE.
YOU KNOW, HE HASN'T REALLY HAD
ANY STRESSFUL INNINGS TONIGHT
EITHER.
# 9 PITCHES NOW.
INTO THE EIGHTH INNING.
HE'S CONTROLLED THIS LINEUP.
ANY TIME HE'S HAD GUYS ON BASE
HE'S BEEN ABLE TO GET OUT OF THE
MINOR JAMS.
BUT DOING IT WITH CHANGEUPS AND
CUTTERS BASICALLY AND MIXING IN
A FEW BREAKING BALLS.
Stephen: AND SOME FROZEN ROPES.
Danny: GREAT DEFENSE HELPS.
Stephen: I'M SAYING HIS OWN
FROZEN ROPES WITH HIS DOUBLE.
HE HAD THE DEFENSE -- QUUR
RIGHT.
HAS BEEN OUTSTANDING.
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING AT?
LOOK AT THE GAME.
BETTER STOP IT.
UMPIRE THE GAME.
Dan: DON'T SEE THIS CALL VERY
OFTEN THE LOW STRIKE WHEN THE
BALL IS DOWN BELOW THE KNEES.
STIP URIAS DEFINITELY GOT A
PIECE OF BARNHART.
Dan: THE BACKSWING, I THINK.
Stephen: POPS OUT, HOPFULLY
BARNHART IS OK.
BOOS RAINING DOWN HERE.
BARNHART SAYS HE'S GOOD.
GOOD SIGN FOR CINCINNATI.
Dan: TUCKER IS NOT COMING OUT OF
THE --
Danny: TUCKER IS NOT COMING OUT
OF THIS GAME.
NOTHING IS GOING TO PHASE HIM.
Stephen: GOOD POINT.
IF ANYBODY HAS GOTTEN TO WADE
MILEY TONIGHT, IT'S BEEN THIS
MAN.
WILLY ADAM DERVETION S.
WILLY ADAMES.
Dan: INTERESTING WATCHING THIS
FOURTH GO-AROUND.
SO MANY ARE AFRAID TO LET A
STARTING PITCHER GO A THIRD TIME
THROUGH THE ORDER.
HE'S NOT AFRAID, HE'S PITCHING
INSIDE MORE THAN HE DID.
EVERYTHING CUTTING IN ON THE
FIRST TWO HITTERS.
BOTH THESE PITCHES TO ADAMES,
BALLS CUT.
INNING.
Stephen: DOUBLE IN THE FIRST.
SINGLED IN THE SIXTH.
2-3.
WILLY ADAMESEST.
ADAMES.
ONE OF THE HOTTEST HITTERS ALIVE
RIGHT NOW.
THE 2-1 FROM MILEY.
COMES INSIDE.
MISSES 3-1 NOW.
ADAMES Y -- ADAMES IS LOCKED.
IN HE IS WORKING QUICKLY.
HE CAN STEP OUT OF HIS STANCE.
TAKES BALL FOUR.
A ONE-OUT WALK BRINGS THE TYING
RUN TO THE PLATE HERE AT BOTTOM
OF THE EIGHTH.
Dan: THAT WAS A GOOD AT-BAT.
HE DIDN'T OFFER THE #-1 PITCH.
FIRST THREE PITCHES IN THAT
SEQUENCE WERE ALL IN, IN, IN.
WIDE MILEY THROUGH A NICE
CHANGEUP DOWN AND AWAY.
ADAMES WASN'T TAKING THE BAIT AT
ALL.
Danny: THOSE CUTTERS WEREN'T BAD
PITCHES, HE WANTED NOTHING TO DO
WITH IT.
HE'S SO LOCKED IN.
Stephen: SAW THE PITCHING COACH
ON THE FLOOR.
HE'S GOT LEFT-ON-LEFT HERE.
MILEY APPROACHING THE CENTURY
MARK IN PITCHES.
Dan: I THINK THIS MIGHT BE THE
LAST ONE HE'LL SEE.
J.P.: IF HE GETS A GROUND BALL
DOUBLE PLAY DO YOU LET HIM HIT
AND GO OUT FOR THE NINTH?
Dan: ILL THINK ABOUT IT.
Y.P.: ME TOO.
Stephen: WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT YELICH AND THE POWER,
WANTING TO COME BACK.
NO BETTER TIME THAN NOW.
MILEY, RUNS IN, YELICH HAS TO
DANCE OUT OF THE WAY.
Dan: IN A SPOT LIKE THIS, A
VETERAN PITCHER LIKE MILEY, I
DON'T THINK THE COUNT WILL SCARE
HIM.
HE'S KEPT THE BALL FOR THE MOST
PART AWAY FROM YELICH.
HE WAS GETTING THOSE CALLS THE
FIRST FOUR OR FIVE INNINGS.
THERE WERE SEVERAL PITCHES THAT
WERE NEAR THE TOP OF THE STRIKE
ZONE THAT SEEMED TO GO WIDE
MILEY'S WAY.
THERE'S A GREAT TAKE BY YELICH.
THAT BALL, A COUPLE OF BALLS OFF
THE PLATE INSIDE.
Stephen: THE 3-1 TO YELICH.
Dan: THAT'S A PITCHER'S PITCH.
3-1 BREAKING BALL.
YOU'RE THINKING YELICH IS
SELLING OUT FOR A HEATER.
PUT A LITTLE CUT ON THAT ONE.
Danny: IF HE DOES MAKE CONTACT
HE WON'T HIT IT WITH ANY KIND OF
AUTHORITY.
Stephen: YELICH REPRESENTS THE
TYING RUN.
THE 3-2 PITCH.
SLAPPED TO THE LEFT SIDE.
WHAT A RANGE TO SECOND.
THEY CANNOT TURN THE DOUBLE PLAY
BUT STILL A GREAT PLAY FROM
EUGENIO SUAREZ.
WOW.
Dan: SIT INTERFERENCE?
Stephen: BASE RUNNER
INTERFERENCE.
ADAMES PLEADING HIS CASE.
THE REDS CELEBRATE COUNSEL COMES
OUT AND WANTS TO HAVE A WORD.
GOT TO HAVE ANOTHER LOOK AT THAT
WE'RE IN OUR STUDIOS IN NEW
JERSEY.
GOING TO STAY HERE TO SHOW IT TO
YOU.
Dan: WHAT A PLAY BY SUAREZ.
THAT BALL LOOKED LIKE IT HAD
DOUBLE WRITTEN ALL OVER IT GOING
DOWN THE LINE.
I DIDN'T THINK HE HAD A CHANCE
TO GET ANY OF THE GUYS OUT AT
EITHER BASE.
TAKE A LOOK.
MAYBE CHECK OUT THE SLIDE GOING
INTO SECOND BASE.
IF IT WAS A LATE SLIDE OR HE
TRIED TO REACH AROUND AND MAYBE
TRIED TO -- INHIBIT HIBT THE
THREE THROE TO FIRST BASE.
Stephen: LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE
HEADING TOWARD THE HEADSET.
Dan: LOOK AT SUAREZ OFFBALANCE,
KIND OF A JUMP THROWLE.
Stephen: NO.
TERRIFIC RANGE BEING DISPLAYED
BY SUAREZ TO FARMER.
Dan: I GUESS THE ONLY THING,
STEPHEN, IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE
REALLY TECHNICAL WAS MAYBE THE
ROLL INTO, AFTER SLIDING INTO
SECOND BASE ADAMES WENT INTO A
LITTLE ROLL RIGHT THERE INTO
FARMER.
Stephen: YOU'RE SAYING IF HE
HOLDS THE BAG AS A RUNNER, IT'S
A DIFFERENT STORY.
THE BREWERS DUGOUT REACTING.
Dan: IT STANDS.
Danny: NOW, GUYS THE QUESTION
IS, DOES MILEY GET TO HIT.
THERE'S OUR DOUBLE PLAY.
Stephen: I THINK THEY'RE
PROBABLY SAY, WADE, HELL OF A
NIGHT, GREAT JOB, BROTHER.
BUT THAT'S A TOUGH CALL.
A GREAT QUESTION.
ONE MORE LOOK AT THE ADAMES
SLIDE.
IF HE HOLDS THE BAG BETTER, IT'S
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T.
HE SLIDES THROUGH.
IT WAS NOT MALICIOUS OR INTENDED
TO INTERFERE.
BECAUSE HE TUMBLES OVER THE BAG.
Danny: NOT INTENTIONAL ON HIS
PART BUT I UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
UMPIRES ARE TRYING TO DO AND
IT'S A JUDGMENT CALL ON THEIR
PART.
IT'S TO PROTECT THE MIDDLE
INFIELDERS.
A-- ADAMES SHOULD UNDERSTAND
THAT, BEING A MIDDLE INFIELDER
HIMSELF.
Stephen: HE OTHER FACTOR THAT'S
NOT SITTING WELL WITH ME IF I'M
A BREWER FAN, I DON'T THINK
FARMER GETS YELICH ANYWAY.
IT'S LIKE A CATCHABLE PASS.
Dan: IT'S A TECHNICALITY, IT'S
SIMILAR BUT THE STEAL OF SECOND
BASE AND THE GUY -- YOU KNOW.
WITHOUT QUESTION BEATS THE TAG
BUT THE FOOT COMES OFF.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
HOLD A TAG ON AND THE GUY COMES
JUST A FRACTION OFF THE BAG.
THERE'S NO WAY THEY'RE TURNING A
DOUBLE PLAY HERE.
YELICH IS CLEAR.
Stephen: THE THROW IS HALFWAY TO
VOTTO AND HE'S ALREADY TOUCHED
FIRST BASE.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
REDS FANS ARE CHANNELING THEIR
INNER EUGENIO SUAREZ.
HE'S OUT.
WE MOVE ON.
THE BOO BIRDS CAN HANG OUT AS
LONG AS THEY WANT AT THE FIELD,
THEY'RE NOT CHANGING IT.
LOOK AT THE COMEP TEAR.
I SAW THE INTERFERENCE, WASN'T
INTENTIONAL NEW YORK CHANCE OF
GETTING YELICH ANYWAY.
CINCINNATI REDS SAY WE'LL TAKE
IT, ON TO THE NINTH.
AND GOOGLE CLOUD IS HELPING TO
POWER STAT CAST WITH MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF DATA POINTS TO REVEAL
NEW INSIGHTS TAKING YOU DEEPER
INTO THE GAME THAN EVER BEFORE.
GOOGLE CLOUD IS THE OFFICIAL
CLOUD TECHNOLOGY OF MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL.
LOOK WHO IS COMING UP.
WADE MILEY.
YOU WERE RIGHT, GRAVY.
Danny: 104.5-MILE-PER-HOURS EXIT
VOTE VE LOSTY.
REMEMBER THAT.
Stephen: FACING A NEW PITCHER.
BUT THEY'RE SAYING, THIS IS YOUR
BALLGAME TO FINISH.
Dan: 99-MILE-PER-HOUR FASTBALL
THERE.
WADE MILEY IS TURNING IT LOOSE,
LETTING IT EAT.
Danny: WHY NOT.
SWING HARD IN CASE YOU HIT IT,
RIGHT?
Stephen: BEHIND 0-2 IN A HURRY.
Dan: IN ALL SERIOUSNESS I LIKE
THIS MOVE.
BECAUSE OF THE STRUGGLES FOR THE
BULLPEN FOR THE REDS AS OF LATE.
MILEY IS PITCHING A PRETTY DARN
GOOD BASEBALL GAME RIGHT NOW
KEEPING THESE GUYS OFF BALANCE.
Stephen: GOT A CHANCE TO SWING
THE BAT.
Dan: HE'S SAYING I KNOW YOU'RE
SWINGING, HERE'S A LITTLE EXTRA.
ANOTHER BIG ARM OUT OF THE
BREWERS' BULLPEN.
Stephen: IT'S NOT JUST THE BIG
BOY, THE POPULAR NAMES AT THE
BACK END.
Dan: THERE'S A LOT OF TALL ENUP
AND DOWN THAT MILWAUKEE, NO ONLY
ROTATION BUT ALSO THE BULLPEN.
I THINK THAT'S ONE EDGE THEY
HAVE RIGHT NOW.
BUT LISTEN, WITH THE CINCINNATI
REDS -- WHEN THE CINCINNATI REDS
GET GRAY BACK IN THAT ROTATION,
WHERE IS THAT ONE?
Stephen: INDIA, GOOD WORK TO
AVOID THAT AS BEST HE COULD.
LIMIT THE DAMAGE TO HIM.
GOT HIM ON THE SHOULDER.
LEADOFF MAN IN THE ORDER.
ONE-OUT WALK HERE IN THE TOP OF
THE NINTH.
CINCINNATI TRYING TO PAD ITS
LEAD.
CURRENTLY 2-0.
NO STRANGER TO THIS.
JESSE WINKER WILL COME BACK UP.
HIS LAST TIME UP IN THE SEVENTH
A BIG R.B.I. DOUBLE.
58 ON THE YEAR FOR HIM.
Dan: YOU TOUCHED ON IT, A BIG
SEVENTH INNING.
DROVE IN THE SECOND RUN.
THEN WINKER MADE A TERRIFIC PLAY
BACKING UP A SOFT FLY BALL IN
THE GAP IN LEFT CENTER FIELD.
BREWERSES LOOKED LIKE THEY'D
START WITH A LEADOFF DOUBLE HIT.
NO PART OF THAT STRONG THROW TO
SECOND BASE.
AVERAGE BACK OVER .300 AT .301.
HEADING TO HIS FIRST ALL-STAR
GAME THIS TUESDAY IN DENVER.
YOU THINK ABOUT IT, THE REDS,
2/3'S OF THE OUTFIELD IN WINKER
AND CASTELLANOS, GOING TO BE
PATROLLING THE BIG OUTFIELD IN
DENVER.
Danny: HE'S GOT A DIFFERENT LOOK
IN HIS EYES AFTER THAT LAST
AT-BAT.
Stephen: TO THE RIGHT SIDE.
THE BREWERS TURN TWO.
THEY AVOID FALLING BEHIND
FURTHER.
IT'LL BE 2-0 CINCINNATI TO THE
BOTTOM OF
GO.
GARCIA, TAYLOR AN PETERSON
AGAINST WADE MILEY.
Stephen: WE'RE BACK FOR THE
BOTTOM OF THE NINTH IN
MILWAUKEE.
BREWERS DOWN BY TWO.
REDS UP IN LARGE PART TO THAT
MAN.
WADE MILEY.
HE STARTED THE GAME.
DAVID BELL GIVING HIM A CHANCE
TO FINISH IT.
GRAVY, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
Danny: I LOVE THIS.
I LOVE THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR HIM
TO GO BACK OUT.
HE'S THE WORK HORSE ON THIS
STAFF.
HE'S BEEN ABLE TO KEEP THIS
BREWERS OFFENSE AT BAY.
CHANGING SPEEDS AND YOU KNOW,
MIXING UP HIS PITCHES.
IT'S BEEN AWESOME TO WATCH RIGHT
NOW.
Stephen: MILEY'S 104TH PITCH
LACED BY GARCIA.
A LEADOFF DOUBLE FOR THE
MILWAUKEE BREWERS.
Dan: IF YOU'RE DAVID BELL YOU
HAVE A DILEMMA HERE.
YOU'VE GOT A START FOR THE WADE
MILEY THAT'S PITCHED SO WELL,
YOUR BULLPEN HAS STRUGGLED, YOU
CERTAINLY WOULD HATE TO LEAVE
HIM OUT THERE TO LOSE A GAME
HE'S PITCHED SO WELL BUT DO YOU
HAVE A BETTER OPTION IN THE
BULLPEN?
Danny: THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
YOU DON'T WANT TO GIVE HIM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LOSE THE GAME.
Stephen: YOU SEE BELL COME OUT
OF THE DUGOUT.
MILEY'S REACTIONS, HE WANTED TO
FINISH IT, HE REALLY DID.
104 PITCHES.
ONLY TIME HE HAD MORE PITCHES IN
A GAME WAS LAST TIME HE HAD A
COMPLETE GAME.
HIS NO-HITTER ON THE 7TH OF MAY
AGAINST CLEVELAND.
TIP OF THE CAP TO WIDE MILEY.
A.K.A. THE HULK.
AN OUTSTANDING PERFORMANCE FOR
HIM.
EIGHT SHUTOUT INNINGS.
THE REDS GOING TO THE BULLPEN. S
COMEBACK.
Stephen: BREWERS FANS, IF YOU
WANT MORE EXCLUSIVE COP TENT,
VISIT THE BREWERS' EWETUBE PAGE.
IT'S THE BEST PLAY TO -- PLACE
TO GO BEHIND THE SCENES WITH THE
MILWAUKEE BREWERS.
SUBSCRIBE TO THE CHANNEL SO YOU
NEVER MISS A VIDEO.
GO TO EWETUBE.COM/BREWERS -- GO
TO YOUTUBE.COM/BREWERS.
HEATH HEMBREE.
HAD TWO SAVES ENTERING 2021 WITH
THE CINCINNATI BULLPEN WHICH
IS -- WHICH HAS STRUGGLED THIS
SEASON.
ALSO HAS NOT BEEN HEALTHY.
WHAT HAS HEMBREE DONE?
Danny: HE'S THE GUY THEY'VE
CALLED ON LATELY TO BE THE
CLOSER.
I KNOW THEY'VE BEEN GOING CLOSE
BIER COMMITTEE THIS SEASON BUT
THREE OF HIS LAST FOUR
APPEARANCE HE IS RECORDED A
SAVE.
THIS IS HIS 30TH APPEARANCE ON
THE SEASON.
HE'S A STRIKEOUT GUY, GOT A
FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL AND SLIDER.
47 STRIKEOUTS IN JUST 28 INNINGS
PITCHED ON THE SEASON.
Dan: I THINK ONE OF THE KEYS
TOO, HE'S RETHIRD FIRST
BATTER -- RETIRED THE FIRST
BATTER 23 OF HIS 29 APPEARANCES.
ONE OF THE THINGUS NEED TO DO IS
THROW STRIKES OUT OF THE
BULLPEN.
THEY'VE GOT ANOTHER LEFT-HANDED
BAT THEY ACQUIRED FROM THE BLUE
JAYS.
Stephen: CINCINNATI HAS A
HANDFUL OF RELEAVERS ON THE
INJURED LIST.
HOPEFULLY THEY GET ONE BACK IN
THE NEXT WEEK OR SO.
TYING RUN AT THE PLATE.
TELLEZ FOULS AWAY STRIKE ONE.
Dan: DANNY, YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO
BE AGGRESSIVE, NOT PAINT
YOURSELF INTO A CORNER AND GET
INTO FASTBALL COUNTS,
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU LEAN ON
THE FASTBALL.
A GOOD FIRST PITCH BY HEMBREE.
I THINK THE KEY TO HIM IS
GETTING AHEAD STRIKE ONE.
Danny: COMING IN AS A
RIGHT-HANDED RELEAVER, FACING A
LEFT-HANDED PINCH HITTER,
THEY'LL JUMP ON THE FIRST ONE
THEY SEE.
BUT THAT'S A PERFECT LOCATION.
Stephen: RIGHT DOWN THE CHUTE
FOR STRIKE TWO.
Dan: WHAT HAPPENS A LOT OF
TIMES, YOU KNOW AS WELL AS I,
YOU SEE GARRETT GETTING UP, HAD
A LITTLE BIT OF A TOUGH OUTING
IN KANSAS THE OTHER NIGHT.
SAL VA TORE PEREZ WITH A BALL
OFF THE WALL, A TOUGH GAME FOR
THE REDS TO LOSE.
IT'S ALL ABOUT THROWING STRIKES
THE BULLPEN CAN DO THAT.
Stephen: YOU HEAR THE CROWD
CHANTING "ROWDY" FOR PEREZ.
EMBRY -- HEMBREE GOES TO HOME
PLATE AND MISSES OUTSIDE.
TELLEZ JUST CAME OVER, TRADE FOR
TREVOR RICHARDS.
CAME TO MILWAUKEE WITH ONE OF
THE MEN YOU SAW THAT.
ADAMES.
WHAT A WAY TO INTRODUCE YOURSELF
TO YOUR NEW HOME FANS.
BIG KNOCK IN THE NINTH IF YOU'RE
TELLEZ.
FIGHTS OFF THE 1-2.
WHO IS LEADING THE CHANTS?
OF COURSE IT'S WILLY ADAMES.
Dan: HE SAID ON A COUPLE OF
OCCASIONS HOW MUCH FUN HE'S HAD
IN MILWAUKEE.
PLAYING IN THAT BALLPARK IN THAT
BIG SERIES AGAINST THE CUBS.
IT'S A LEAVELY BALLPARK,
PARTICULARLY WHEN THEY'RE IN
FIRST PLACE BY SEVEN GAMES.
Stephen: WIDE MILEY WANTED TO
HAVE A COMPLETE GAME.
JUST REMOVED AFTER THE LEADOFF
DOUBLE.
THE 1-2.
BOUNCES IN THE DIRT.
2-2.
ROWDY TELLEZ A PRODUCT OF A PRO
BALLPLAYER PIPE LIEP IN OAK
GROVE HIGH SCHOOL IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
A NUMBER OF CURRENT BIG
LEAGUERS, DYLAN CARLSON, HIS
FATHER WAS A KOCH.
J.D. DAVIS.
NICK MADRIGAL OF THE WHITE SOX.
BUCK MARTINEZ.
FOR THE BLUE JAYS.
RIGHT NOW OUR FOCUS IS ON ONE
ALUM, HIS NAME IS ROWDY.
THE 2-2.
SWUNG ON AND MISSED.
HEMBREE.
STRIKES OUT TELLEZ.
Dan: THAT'S WHAT VELOCITY WILL
DO FOR YOU.
THAT PITCH WAS INTENDED TO BE ON
THE INNER-OF THE PLATE.
IT WAS 9 #-MILE-PER-HOURS.
YOU CAN SEE WHERE BARNHART IS
SETTING UP INSIDE.
THIS BALL HAS TREMENDOUS SAIL.
FOUR-SEAM FASTBALL, 97 UP.
NOT MUCH THAT ROWDY COULD DO
WITH THAT ONE.
BIG OUT FOR THE REDS.
Danny: THAT'S THE FASTBALL UP IN
THE ZONE, GUYS THINK THEY CAN
GET ON TOP OF IT BUT CAN'T CATCH
UP IT TO -- UP TO IT.
MUST BE NICE THROWING 9 #,
MISSING THE SPOT BY FOUR FEET
AND GETTING A SWING AND MISS.
THAT'S ONE THING I CAN SAY NEVER
HAPPENED.
Stephen: CHASE PETERSON.
TALKED ABOUT HIM A LOT TONIGHT.
INFIELD SINGLE.
IN THE FIFTH.
ANOTHER SINGLE IN THE SEVENTH
TRIED TO STRETCH INTO A
TWO-BAGGER BUT WAS THROWN OUT.
GREAT THROW.
GREAT PLAY.
JESSE WINKER BACKING UP
VIZCAINO.
Dan: THAT'S BACK-TO-BACK
TERRIFIC SLIDERS FROM HEMBREE.
NOTHING BUT FASTBALLS AS HE
BLOWS UP TELLEZ FOR THE FIRST
OUT OF THE INNING.
THIS IS A GOOD BACK DOOR
BREAKING BALL.
JUST CATCHES A LITTLE BIT OF THE
OUTSIDE CORNER.
SLIDER FOR A CALLED STRIKE.
BACKS IT UP WITH ANOTHER ONE.
TWO REALLY GOOD BREAKERS.
Danny: AND NEITHER ONE OF THOSE
ARE HITTABLE.
THEY DON'T APPEAR TO BE STRIKES
AND JUST CATCH THE CORNER.
IT OPENS UP THE PLATE FOR HIM TO
THROW A FASTBALL IN OR FASTBALL
UP OR EVEN SOMETHING DOWN IN THE
DIRT.
Stephen: WITH THE HELP OF A
CALL, A FEW INCHES OFF THE
PLATE.
Dan: I THINK THIS ONE YOU'LL SEE
CRAIG COUNSEL, HE MIGHT GET THE
GAIN ON THIS ONE.
COUPLE OF BALLS ON THE OUTSIDE
CORNER.
IF YOU'RE HEATH HEMBREE, THE WAY
THIS BULLPEN HAS STRUGGLED, IT'S
CLEARLY OFF THE CORNER.
98-MILE-PER-HOURS.
Stephen: HEMBREE AND THE REDS
WILL TAKE IT TWO.
AWAY.
THIS IS A MAN IN HET HEMBREE WHO
DID NOT HAVE A LOT OF CLOSING
EXPERIENCE COMING INTO THE
SEASON.
WE'RE TALKING TO THE MAN WHO HAS
THE FRANCHISE RECORD, CINCINNATI
HISTORY, FOR SAVES WITH 182.
WHAT WOULD YOU TELL HIM HERE
WITH TWO OUTS, TYING RUN AT THE
PLATE, AND A SLUGGER IN OMAR FAR
VAIZ.
Danny: ATTACK.
YOU'VE GOT TO ATTACK JUST LIKE
THEY DID WITH A MAN ON SECOND
AND NOBODY OUT.
THEY BROUGHT HIM IN BECAUSE HE'S
GOOD WITH RUNNERS ON BASE,
STRANDED NINE OF THE 13.
HEMBREE HAS NO PROBLEM PITCHING
IN THESE SITUATIONS.
IT'S ABOUT GETTING AHEAD EARLY.
Stephen: HE DOES HERE.
NARVAEZ SWINGS THROUGH STRIKE
ONE.
Danny: YOU KNOW WHAT TOO, IF HE
GETS A SITUATION HERE 0-2 THEY
NEED TO GO OFF THE PLATE GEND
AND GET THAT THREE OR FOUR
INCHES OFF THE PLATE FOR ANOTHER
CALLED THIRD STRIKE.
WHY NOT?
Stephen: NARVAEZ REALLY GOOD
AGAINST FASTBALLS.
95-MILE-PER-HOURS.
SKYED IN THE AIR.
BARNHART GIVES IT A LOOK.
DEFINITELY OUT OF PLAY.
TOP TWO O.P.S.'S AMONG CATCHERS
THIS YEAR, NUMBER ONE, BUSTER
POSEY.
NUMBER TWO, THIS GUY.
Dan: IF YOU'RE DAVID BELL YOU
HAVE TO LIKE WHAT YOU'RE SEEING
COMING OUT OF THE RIGHT ARM OF
HEATH HEMBREE.
FASTBALL HAS A LOT OF LIFE.
THROWN SOME GOOD BREAKING BALLS
DOWN INTO THE STRIKE ZONE.
GIVE THIS BULLPEN A BIG SHOT IN
THE ARM.
Stephen: HEMBREE AND THE REDS
ONE STRIKE AWAY.
TIME CALLED.
EIGHT FULL FOR WADE MILEY.
STARRED THE EVENING WITH A
LEADOFF DOUBLE, PROMPTED DAVID
BELL TO GO TO HEMBREE.
THE 0-2.
STRIKE THREE.
REDS WIN.
MILEY WITH A SENSATIONAL START.
AND HEMBREE VAMS THE -- SLAMS
THE DOOR IN THE BOTTOM OF THE
NINTH WITH THE TYING RUN AT THE
PLATE.
CINCINNATI BACK WITHIN SIX GAMES
OF THE N.L. CENTRAL LEAD.
Dan: THIS WAS A BIG GAME FOR THE
REDS.
THEY'RE GOING TO FACE FREDDIE PE
RAL TA ON SATURDAY AND WOODRUFF
IN THE FINALE BEFORE THE
ALL-STAR BREAK.
THIS PITCHING MATCHUP, WIDE
MILEY WAS REALLY FAVORABLE.
BOY, WAS HE TERRIFIC TONIGHT.
EIGHT-PLUS SCORELESS INNINGS.
SOME GREAT BULLPEN HELP FROM
HEATH HELP BREE THAT GUY RIGHT
THERE, JESSE WINKER, PLAYED A
BIG PART WITH HIS BAT AND HIS
GLOVE.
Danny: THIS WAS LIKE A MUST-WIN
GOING INTO THE ALL-STAR BREAK.
BUT WHAT A PERFORMANCE BY WIDE
MILEY.
Stephen: HE HAS SOME CHALLENGERS
FOR THE YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE
GAME.
THE POLL IS UP, VOTE QUICKLY.
I THINK I KNOW WHICH WAY THE
POLL IS GOING TO GO.
I'M ACTUALLY GOING TO VOTE
MYSELF.
YOU SEE THE CELEBRATION FOR
CINCINNATI.
HOW ABOUT JONATHAN INDIA.
MIC'D UP.
>> REDS WINKER BABY, REDS WIN.
>> THAT'S WHAT I SAID, JONATHAN.
Stephen: THE REDS DO WIN IT.
AGAIN WE TALKED ABOUT HOW
PIVOTAL THE SERIES IS FOR BOTH
TEAMS, REALLY, BUT ESPECIALLY
FOR CINCINNATI BEING THE ONES
CHASING THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS IN
THE FINAL.
NOT FINAL FOR US YET.
WE HAVE THE MLB GAME OF THE WEEK
LEAVE ON YOUTUBE POSTGAME SHOW
COMING YOUR WAY.
Stephen: LET'S GET THINGS
ROLLING INTO THE WEEKEND.
THE GAME OF THE WEEK POSTGAME
SHOW ON YOUTUBE PRESENTED BY
CHIME.
BEAUTIFUL EVENING IN MILWAUKEE,
WISCONSIN.
GAME OF THE WEEK AND A FUN GAME
BETWEEN THE CINCINNATI REDS AND
THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS.
A DAZZLING OUTING AND
PERFORMANCE BY ONE WADE MILEY.
WHO HAS PUT ON A HEADSET AND IS
KIND ENOUGH TO JOIN US.
WADE, CAN YOU HEAR US OK?
WADE: YES, SIR.
Stephen: YOU'VE GOT DANNY
GRAVES, DAN PLESAC AND STEPHEN
WITH YOU.
HAVE YOU CAUGHT YOUR BREATH FROM
YOUR DOUBLE YET.
WADE: THAT'S A TRIPLE.
I CALL THAT A TRIPLE.
YEAH, I CAUGHT MY BREATH.
I WAS GOOD.
RAN OUT OF GAS LATE BIT THERE IN
THE NINTH.
I RECOVERED OK.
Stephen: WHAT ARE YOU MOST
PLEASED WITH, THE EIGHT OR THE
KNOCK?
WADE: THE DOUBLE FOR SURE.
COOLEST THING WHEN A PITCHER
GETS A HIT.
THAT WAS AWESOME.
GENO TOLD ME TO HIT A DOUBLE AND
I RAN INTO ONE.
Danny: I THOUGHT WE JUST DECIDED
IT WAS A TRIPLE, WADE, NOT A
DOUBLE.
WADE: YOU'RE RIGHT.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
Danny: I KNOW LAST TIME I TALKED
TO YOU, I ASKED YOU ABOUT THE
TATTOO.
THE HULK TATTOO.
I WANT TO KNOW IF YOU GOT A REAL
ONE.
YOU SAID YOU WEREN'T GOING TO,
MAYBE YOU CHANGED YOUR MIND?
WADE: I'M SCARED TO DEATH OF
NEEDLES MAN.
NOTHING THERE.
Dan: WADE, IT'S DAN PLESAC SACK.
I THOUGHT YOU SHOWED EVERY PART
OF YOUR GAME.
HOW ABOUT THE PLAY ON THE
SWINGING BUNT AT THE THIRD BASE
LINE.
WADE: I WANTED TO GO TO THIRD SO
BAD, THE BALL HOOKED ON ME.
I WAS JUST HOPING I GOT AN OUT
AT FIST.
INDIA MADE A GREAT PLAY, ABLE TO
GET IT OUT THERE AND SHORTEN THE
INNING.
Dan: I WAS WATCH, WENT INTO THE
SEVENTH AND EIGHTH INNING, YOU
SEEMED TO BE REALLY CONSCIOUS OF
TRYING TO CROWD THE RIGHT-HANDED
HITTERS.
I THOUGHT YOU DID A MARVELOUS
JOB OF MOVING THE BALL AND BEING
UNPREDICTABLE.
I THOUGHT GOING IN WAS THE KEY
TO THE RIGHTIES.
WADE: NO DOUBT.
I WAS TRYING TO GET IT UP AND IN
TO THEM.
THEY KNOW IT'S COMING.
A LOT OF TIMES THEY WANT TO TRY
TO GET BIG.
IT OPENS UP THE CHANGEUP DOWN
AND WAY A AWAY.
I'VE GOT TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
HELPED ME OUT BACK THERE PUTTING
THE RIGHT FINGERS DOWN.
THE DEFENSE WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
GREAT DEFENSIVE PERFORMANCE ALL
AROUND.
SCORED ENOUGH RUNS TO WIN.
IT WAS A GREAT BALLGAME.
Dan: DID YOU HAVE TO --
Danny: DID YOU HAVE TO DO ANY
CONVINCING FOR BELL TO LET YOU
GO BACK OUT?
WADE: NO.
I THOUGHT I WAS AT 90 PITCHES.
I LOOKED UP IN THE EIGHTH, I WAS
AT # 7.
I WENT IN THERE AND SAID, I GOT
THE NINTH.
HE DIDN'T SAY NOTHING ELSE.
Stephen: WANT TO SHOW THAT
HARDWARE YOU GOT IN YOUTUBE
PLAYER OF THE GAME.
WADE: IT'S ABOUT 45 POUNDS, THIS
THING IS HEAVY.
Stephen: SERIOUS BUSINESS ON THE
GAME OF THE WEEK PRESENTED BY
CHIME.
ALSO A BIG WIN FOR THE
CINCINNATI REDS.
WADE: HUGE WIN.
Stephen: YOU WERE CHASING THE
BREWERS.
NOW THE LEAD CUT TO SIX GAMES
FOR MILWAUKEE.
HAVE YOU BEEN TALKING IN THE
CLUBHOUSE ABOUT THIS PIVOTAL
STRETCH, SEVEN GAMES IN A ROW
AGAINST THEM?
OR ARE YOU DOWN PLAYING IT?
WADE: WE KNOW WHERE WE'RE AT.
WE KNOW IN ORDER TO JUST GO OUT
AND PLAY GOOD BASEBALL, WE KNOW
WHO IS IN FRONT OF US.
WHAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE TO TRACK
THEM DOWN.
GOT A GOOD OPPORTUNITY RIGHT
HERE TO PLI SOME GOOD BASEBALL
AND CATCH UP SOME GAMES.
Stephen: ON YOUR DOUBLE, EXCUSE
ME, NAY, TRIPLE, YOU HIT THE
BALL 104.8-MILE-PER-HOURS OFF
THE BAT, IT WAS THE HARDEST HIT
BALL BY A CINCINNATI RED
TONIGHT.
YOU CAN GO BRAG ABOUT IT TO YOUR
TEAMMATES NOW.
WADE: I WILL DEFINITELY LET THEM
KNOW THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
Stephen: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WADE: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
Stephen: THERE HE GO, WADE
MILEY.
NO TATTOO.
I'M WITH YOU.
I'M NOT GETTING NEAR A TATTOO
NEEDLE.
YOUTUBE PLAYER OF THE GAME, WADE
MILEY.
WAS THERE ANY DOUBT?
Dan: NO.
HE WAS TERRIFIC.
EIGHT-PLUS INNINGS, LOWERED HIS
E.R.A. TO 2 . 80.
THERE'S THE FINE PLAY HE DID
IT -- HE DID IT WITH HIS BAT,
WITH HIS LEGS AND WITH THE LEFT
ARM.
LOOK AT HIM MOTOR RIGHT HERE.
Stephen: GIVE ME A HORSE RACING
CALL, DAN.
Dan: DOWN THE STRETCH THEY COME.
GIVE WADE SOME OXYGEN.
Stephen: FLIES IN AND SCORED A
CRUCIAL INSURANCE RUN.
WADE MILEY, LAND SLIED VICTOR OF
THE PLAYER OF THE GAME POLL.
THANKS TO EVERYONE WHO TUNED IN
AND VOTED.
90% SAYING WADE MILEY.
HE WAS THE PROHIBIT I FAVORITE
AND CAME THROUGH.
JESSE WINKER, BIG INCOME, HUGE
DEFENSIVE PLAY TO PICK UP WADE
MILEY.
TUCKER BARNHART BEHIND THE DISH.
WE'LL TAKE AE ON THE GAME OF THE
WEEK AND COME BACK TO SHOW YOU
SOME HIGHLIGHTS FROM MILWAUKEE.
Stephen: LOUD AT AMFAM FIELD IN
WISCONSIN.
WELCOME BACK TO THE POSTGAME
SHOW.
THINGS ARE ALL QUIET NOW AFTER
THE REDS' 2-0 SHUTOUT VICTORY.
IN CASE YOU MISSED ANY HIGHLIGHT
WE GOT YOU.
GOOD OLD-FASHIONED PITCHERS DUEL
SO FAR.
FIRST THREE IN, NOTHING DOING.
ONE HIT APIECE.
THE 0-2 PITCH OVER TO ADAMESEST
AT SHORT.
0-1 TO KYLE FARMER.
SWING AND A POP-UP.
SHALLOW LEFT CENTER OUT.
INFIELD FLY CALLED FOR AT THE
LAST MOMENT BY JOHN LITKA.
ADAMES MADE THE CATCH ANYWAY.
>> TUCKER PARN HART.
HIT A GROUND BALL OFF THE THIRD
BASEMAN.
TWO ON, TWO OUT.
>> SENDS IT INTO LEFT FIELD.
TUCKER BARNHART.
GOING TO START THE SCORING.
BRINGING HOME SUAREZ.
THROW BECOME TO THIRD.
1-0 CINCINNATI AFTER FOUR.
Stephen: JONATHAN INDIA, BASE
HIT HIS FIRST TIME UP.
JONATHAN INDIA IS A FUN BASEBALL
PLAYER.
I LOVE HOW HE'S TURNED IT ON
HERE FOR THE CINCINNATI REDS AND
HE GETS ON BASE ONCE AGAIN HERE
WITH A ONE-OUT SINGLE.
ONE-OUT WALK HERE IN THE FIFTH.
A RUN FOR THE SCORING POSITION
FOR THE REDS.
A CHANCE TO ADD TO THEIR 1-0
LEAD.
CASTELLANOS, A CHANCE TO DO SOME
DAMAGE HERE.
SENT INTO CENTER FIELD.
TAYLOR.
GOING TO COME IN AND THERE'S OUT
NUMBER TWO.
NOW TWO OUTS FOR JOEY VOTTO.
2-2.
SWUNG ON AND MISSED.
CELEBRATES IT GOING TO CLAP FOR
HIMSELF.
>> PETERSON BOUNCED OUT HIS
FIRST TIME UP TWO.
STRIKES AND COMING BACK.
SWINGING A ONE-HOPPER HIT TO
SHORT.
OFF BALANCE THROW.
GOING TO BE LATE FOR PETERSON.
AND HE'S GOT AN INFIELD BASE
HIT.
>> DEEP OFF JACOB DEGROM.
PENIA.
LACES ONE TO THE LEFT SIDE.
NOW NUMBER NINE SPOT IN THE
ORDER.
>> I WOULD NOT PIMPLEG HIT.
I'M BUNTING HIM OVER.
I KNOW BUNTS ARE THE SAME BUT
THERE IT IS, PERFECT BUNT.
Stephen: ON THAN INDIA, WHAT A
TERRIFIC PLAY.
A NICE PLAY BY WIDE MILEY.
NOT SURE WHAT BUNT PLAY WAS ON
BUT WIDE MILEY, LATE IF GETTING
OVER THERE.
CHANGEUP TO FIRST BASE.
COUPLE OF PLAYS AROUND SECOND
BASE.
BUT THIS POTENTIALLY SAVES A
RUN.
>> SECOND AND THIRD NOW FOR
MILWAUKEE.
SKYED INTO RIGHT CENTER FIELD.
CASTELLANOS.
RETIRED THE SIDE.
ONE RUN SEPARATES THEM TONIGHT
AS WE SAY HELLO TO MIGUEL
SANCHEZ.
WIDE MILEY LEADING OFF.
>> YOU WANT MILEY TO GO AS DEEP
AS HE CAN.
LEADOFF DOUBLE THROASM BOUNCES
AWAY.
MILEY TO THIRD.
SLIDES IN SAFELY.
>> HEADS UP PLAY.
>> GET IN THE TANK.
>> GET HIM SOME OXYGEN.
>> LOOK AT THE REDS PLAYERS.
WAY TO GO WADE.
Stephen: SCORING POSITION FOR
JONATHAN INDIA.
SANCHEZ BOUNCES BACK.
A BIG STRIKEOUT OFF JONATHAN
INDIA.
90 FEET AWAY, WINKER AFTER A BAT
ONLY THE 11TH PITCH ROPES IT
DOWN THE LINE INTO RIGHT FIELD.
MILEY WILL TROT HOME.
THE REDS HAVE A #-0 LEAD.
BACK TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
SEVENTH.
TWO-RUN BALLGAME.
>> PETERSON STILL FACING WADE
MILEY.
PETERSON HITS IT HARD.
BOUNCES OUT OF THE REACH OF
AKINO.
SLIDING IN HE'S OUT.
JESSE WINKER IN LEFT FIELD.
TOON THAN INDIA.
APPLYING THE TAG.
PENA.
TO THE LEFT SIDE.
RANGING TO HIS RIGHT, THROWS TO
HIS LEFT.
PENA.
OUTSTANDING DEFENSIVE WORK IN
THE SEVENTH INNING FROM THE
CINCINNATI REDS.
REYES PULLED A HAND SON SON.
LOOKED TO LEFT FIELD.
EASY PLAY FOR WINKER.
GETS WADE MILEY OUT OF THE
SEVENTH INNING.
>> THEN WE PICK THINGS UP IN THE
BOTTOM OF THE EIGHTH INNING.
THIS WAS A BIG MIAMI, A BIG
CALL.
YELICH.
GROUNDED TO THIRD.
SUAREZ WITH A GREAT PLAY TO
SECOND.
YELICH IS SAFE AT FIRST RIGHT?
WELL, NO.
THE CREW RULES THAT ADAMES'
SLIDE INTO SECOND WAS
INTERFERENCE ON THE THROW FROM
FARMER.
BOTH ARE OUT, END OF THE INNING.
WADE MILEY COMES BACK OUT FOR
THE BOTTOM OF THE NINTH.
ALREADY OVER 100 PITCHES.
FIRST PITCH THROWN AND THE IN--
IN THE INNING.
GARCIA GREETS HIM WITH A DOUBLE.
THEN SAYS FAREWELL TO WADE
MILEY.
KNOCKS HIM OUT OF THE GAME.
FORCES DAVID BELL TO GO TO A
BULLPEN THAT HAS HAD ITS FAIR
SHARE OF STRUGGLES IN 2021.
HEATH HEM BREE.
FIFTH IN LINE.
MAYBE YOU COULD SAY FOR CLOSING
DUTIES.
COMES OUT OF THE GATE AND HOLDS
THE LINE.
TO PLEAT THE SHUTOUT VICTORY FOR
THE REDS.
JESSE WINKER AND TUCKER BARNHART
BOTH FINISH 1-4 WITH AN R.B.I.
DOUBLE.
WE NOW SEND IT OUT TO OUR MAN ON
THE GROUND AT AMFAM FIELD IN
MILWAUKEE.
J.P.
J.P.: FIFTH IN, THE KEY AT-BAT
FOR WINKER AGAINST SANCHEZ OF
THE MILWAUKEE BREWERS, THE REDS
AT THAT POINT IN TIME LEADING
JUST 1-0 AND 11 -- AN # 1-PITCH
AT-BAT FOR WINTER WHO STRUGGLED
IN THE LAST COUPLESLE OF
WEEKED -- WEEKS HAVE BEEN WELL
DOCUMENTED.
HE GRINDS HIS WAY THROUGH.
I LOVE THE 10TH PITCH OF THE
AT-BAT, A CHANGEUP DOWN.
HE GETS JUST ENOUGH WOOD ON IT
TO STAY ALIVE.
HE COMES BACK.
THE 11TH PITCH OF THE AT-BAT HE
DELIVERS TO SCORE WADE MILEY WHO
AS WE HAVE DISCUSSED WAS THE
OFFENSIVE AND PITCHING STAR OF
THIS REDS 2-0 VICTORY TONIGHT
AND AFTER HE GAME WAS OVER I
SPOKE ON THE TEELD WITH JESSE
WINKER ABOUT HIS EMOTIONS IN
THAT AT-BAT, SPECIFICALLY AFTER
THE 10TH PITCH.
JESSE: HE PITCHED UNBELIEVABLE.
I JUST TRIED TO PUT THE BARREL
ON THE BALL, HIT A LINE DRIVE
DOWN TO THE CORNER.
IT WAS -- JUST GOT ENOUGH OF
THAT 10TH ONE, THE 11TH ONE, IT
WORKED OUT.
IT WAS ONE OF THOSE THINGS THAT
I WAS PUMPED, GOT OVER.
WHO WAS PLAYING FIRST AT THE
TIME?
I WAS PUMPED ABOUT THAT.
J.P.: I'M NOT A GREAT LIP READER
BUT I THINK YOU SAID THE WORDS
"ABOUT TIME" AFTER THAT WHAT DID
IT MEAN FOR YOUR TEAM?
JESSE: IT'S A LONG SEASON.
GOING TO GO THROUGH UPS AND
DOWNS.
GOT GREAT GUYS HERE, I GET TO
COME TO WORK EVERY DAY AND ENJOY
IT.
SOME DAYS YOU'LL GET HEATS AND
SOME DAYS YOU WON'T.
DID I SAY THAT HONESTLY I WAS
JUST HAPPY TO DRIVE WADE IN.
I WANTED TO GET THAT JOB DONE
RIGHT THERE.
I WAS HAPPY I DID IT.
J.P.: SPEAKING OF WADE, MORE
IMPRESSIVE, THE HITTING OR HE
PITCHING?
JESSE: I DON'T KNOW.
HE'S WADE THE BLADE.
HE CAN DO IT ALL.
HE'S BEEN AMAZING TO PLAY BEHIND
HE'S HILARIOUS TO WATCH HIT.
HE CAN HIT.
I JUST WANT EVERYBODY TO KNOW.
HE KEEPS TELLING ME WHEN WE'RE
BACK IN CINCINNATI HE'S GOING TO
HIT A BALL INTO THE ALLEGHENY
RIVER, BUT IT'S THE OHIO RIVER.
HE CARRIED US AGAIN TONIGHT.
J.P.: IF YOU HAD TO GIVE THE
ALL-STAR PITCHER, ONE OF THE
GUYS THAT REPLACE THE PITCHERS
THE WEEKEND, WHO WOULD IT BE?
JESSE: WADE MILEY.
HE'S AN ABSOLUTE GAMER.
I THINK EVERYBODY IN THE WHOLE
MLB LOVES HIM, NOT JUST US HERE.
I THINK IT'S EVERYBODY.
HE'S HAD A GREAT IMPACT ON US
HERE.
GREAT IMPACT EVERYWHERE.
HAPPY WE'VE GOT HIM.
I WOULDN'T WANT TO FACE HIM.
J.P.: YOUR FIRST ALL-STAR
APPEARANCE COMING UP, WHAT DO
YOU WANT TO SAY TO YOUR FAMILY
IN BUFFALO AND FAMILY IN ORLANDO
THAT HAVE HELPED YOU GET TO THIS
POINT?
JESSE: THANK YOU.
IF IT WASN'T FOR THEM I WOULDN'T
BE STANDING HERE TALKING TO YOU.
IT'S GOING TO BE A VERY SURREAL
MOMENT.
I -- IT'S BEEN CHANNELING NOT TO
THINK ABOUT IT.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE.
BUT IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS
THAT I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO.
WE'VE GOT TWO MORE BIG GAMES
HERE.
THEN I'LL SEE THEM ALL IN
DENVER, EVERYONE IS GETTING ON
THEIR OWN FLIGHT TO GET OUT
THERE I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO EVERYBODY.
EVERYONE THAT'S HAD A POSITIVE
IMPACT, THEY KNOW.
THEY KNOW.
YEAH, I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE
EVERYBODY.
IT'S PRETTY COOL, I'M NOT GOING
TO LIE.
J.P.: ENJOY ALL THERE IS TO
ENJOY ABOUT THE ALL-STAR GAME.
JESSE: APPRECIATE IT.
J.P.: JESSE WINKER, 27-YEAR-OLD
GRADUATE OF OLYMPIA HIGH SCHOOL
IN FLORIDA.
YOU CAN SEE HOW EMOTIONAL HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT HIS FAMILY BACK
HOME IN BUFFALO AND IN FLORIDA.
WE TALKED ABOUT IT DURING THE
GAME.
HE WAS GREAT LAST YEAR TOO HIS
O.P.S. LAST SEASON UP ABOVE 900.
THIS IS NOT A RECENT REVELATION.
HE'S BEEN A GOOD MAJOR LEAGUE
HITTER FOR A WHILE.
WINKER, I THINK YOU CAN SEE
WANTS TO GET THROUGH THESE TWO
GAMES AND SEE HIS FAMILY IN
DENVER ON TUESDAY.
JUST WHAT A GREAT CELEBRATION
IT'S GOING TO BE FOR HIM.
FOR THE REDS.
FOR OUR NATIONAL PASTIME.
FOR EVERYONE WHO IS WATCHING.
REALLY SPECIAL DAY COMING UP ON
TUESDAY AT THE MAJOR LEAGUE
BASEBALL ALL-STAR GAME.
TUCKER BARNHART WHAT A GREAT
GAME HE HAD.
DRIVING IN THE REDS' FIRST RUN.
AND IN SPEAKING TODAY WITH THE
REDS' G.M., NICK PRAISED THE
WORK TUCKER HAS DONE WITH
STEVENSON, THE FELLOW CATCHERS
ON THE REDS' ROSTER.
A YOUNG CATCHER HE'S HELPING TO
MENTOR AND BRING ALONG THAT SAYS
A LOT ABOUT SOMEONE AS A
TEAMMATE TO LOOK AT SOMEONE
PLAYING THE SAME POSITION AN
JUST POUR YOUR ENERGY AND EFFORT
INTO MAKING HIM AS GOOD AS HE
CAN BE.
AND REALLY JUST LOOK AT A
COLLECTIVE GROUP OF PLAYERS AT
THAT POSITION.
TUCKER BARNHART, A RESPECTED
PLAYER IN THAT REDS CLUBHOUSE.
REDS CLUBHOUSE NOW, THEY'VE
CLOSED THE GAP WITH THE BRAWRS
TO SIX GAMES IN THE NL CENTRAL.
FIVE IN THE LOSS COLUMN.
IF THE PADRES LOSE TONIGHT
THEY'LL BE THREE GAMES BACK IN
THE LOSS COLUMN FOR THE WILD
CARD WHICH IS WHY AS NICK KRAAL
SAID TO ME TODAY, THEY REMAIN
BUYERS HERE THREE WEEKS BEFORE
THE MLB TRADE DEADLINE.
Stephen: THEY SHOULD BE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
REPORTS LEAVE FROM MILWAUKEE.
PLEASE DRIVE HOME SAFELY.
WE LOVE J.P. SO MUCH AND WE ALSO
LOVE JESSE WINKER.
A GREAT REPRESENTATIVE OF NOT
JUST THE REDS BUT THE GAME OF
BASEBALL.
LAST TWO SEASONS HE'S HURT
MILWAUKEE.
BUT THE WHOLE THING WITH JESSE
WINKER IS HEALTH AND
OPPORTUNITY.
HE'S FINAL BY BEEN GIVEN BOTH
THE LAST TWO YEARS.
HE'S MADE A BIG ADJUSTMENT TO
HIS SWING.
HE'S STANDING UP MORE UPRIGHT.
IT'S PAYING DIVIDENDS.
AND WE SEE THAT DISPLAYED AS HE
WAS NAMED AN ALL-STAR STARTER.
DANNY GRAVES, HE AND TUCK R
BARNHART, 1-# TONIGHT WITH AN
R.B.I. DOUBLE.
THEY ARE TWO TIKI COGS IN A
TEAM, AND I AGREE THEY SHOULDN'T
BE LOOKING TO MOVE PIECES OUT.
Danny: THAT FAN BASE IN
CINCINNATI, THEY LOVE THE REDS.
YOU'VE GOT TO BE BUYERS.
GET ANY EXTRA PIECES YOU CAN TO
SOLIDIFY THE TEAM TO GET TO THE
PLAYOFFS AGAIN.
THEY WERE SO CLOSE LAST YEAR IN
THE FIRST ROUND AGAINST THE
BRAVES AND ENDED UP LOSING OUT.
BUT THIS TEAM, IT'S SUCH A FUN
TEAM TO WATCH TOO THERE'S SO
MANY GUYS.
YOU KNOW, THE -- WATCHING JESSE
WINKER TALK IN THAT -- THAT
LITTLE CONVERSATION WITH JOHN
PAUL MOROSI ALMOST MADE ME TEAR
UP.
HE'S SO GENUINE.
SO HAPPY TO BE A PART OF THE
YAWL STAR GAME.
SO HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO SEE HIS
FAMILY SOON.
JUST A TREMENDOUS GUY.
MOST OF THOSE GUYS IN THE
CLUBHOUSE ARE JUST LIKE THAT
VERY GENUINE.
REAL QUICK ABOUT TUCKER
BARNHART, I KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT
IT DURING THE SHOW OR DURING THE
GAME HE WASN'T SUPPOSED TO PLAY
TODAY.
HE WASN'T SUPPOSED TO PLAY
AGAINST A LEFTY.
WIDE MILEY AND HIM ARE BATTERY A
MATES.
HE CATCHES MILEY EVERY TIME.
HE GETS AN OPPORTUNITY, GETS THE
R.B.I., THEN THEY END UP WINNING
#-0.
IT WAS A FUN GAME TO WATCH.
WADE MILEY CUE KUDOS TO YOU MAN.
Stephen: WADE THE BLADE.
IF ANYONE HEARS JESSE WINKER
REFERENCE THE RIDERS, HE CAME ON
"I.T." WITH MILLAR AND I, THEY
SAILED WHEN THEY GO ON THE ROAD,
THERE'S A GROUP THAT THEY GET
THOSE PORTABLE SCOOTERS THAT YOU
CAN PICK UP AND RIDE AND DROP
OFF WHEREVER, THEY CALL
THEMSELVESES THE RIDERS.
WADE MILEY ROAD HARD -- RODE
HARD TONIGHT.
Dan: REALLY THIS WAS A BIG GAME
FOR THE REDS.
THEY WERE SEVEN GAMES GOING OUT
BEHIND THE BREW CREW HEADING
INTO PLAY TONIGHT.
THIS WAS A MUST-WIN.
PE RAL TA AND WOODRUFF COMING UP
SATURDAY AND SUNDAY A LOT OF
CUTTERS HE FEEL MOVED THE BALL
IN ON THE RIGHT-HANDERS.
I THINK THAT'S THE KEY BEING
SUCCESSFUL STARTING LPPEDDED
WHEN YOU'RE FACING A HE WASE
LINEUP LIKE THE BREWERS HAVE OF
THE RIGHTIES.
HE MADE THEM AWARE OF THE BALL.
USED THE CHANGEUP AWAY.
A LITTLE HELP FROM HIS FRIENDS.
WINKER HERE ON A TERRIFIC THROW
TO SECOND BASE TO GET PETERSON
OUT.
WADE MILEY TASMS COMBINATION OF
A LOT OF THINGS.
FARLER HERE, A TERRIFIC THROW
AND A GREAT SCOOP BY JOEY VOTTO.
A WELL PITCHED GAME, A WELL BASE
RUNNING GAME.
VERY GOOD DEFENSE.
YOU ADD IT ALL UP AND THE REDS
DID A LOT OF THINGS.
THEY WERE ADD -- AIDED HERE BY
THIS DOUBLE PLAY CALL TO GET OUT
OF THE SEVENTH INNING.
ANYWAY ADD UP, WADE MILEY WAS
TERRIFIC.
AND HEATH HEMBREE WAS EXPLOSIVE
IN THE NINTH.
Stephen: HE'S GOT A 3-1 RECORD,
A 2.20E.R.A. AND PURGED 44
TICKETS, WALKED JUST 15.
AND THE REDS HAVE WONINE GAMES.
2-0 THE FINAL TONIGHT FOR
CINCINNATI.
WHEN WE COME BACK AFTER THIS,
WE'LL TIE THINGS UP AND SEND YOU
ON TO YOUR SATURDAY.
>> WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
LUCY?
NICE TO MEET YOU BE GOOD OK.
>> IT'S ALL GOOD.
I WAS GOING TO APOLOGIZE
YESTERDAY.
>> I KNOW IT'S THE HEAT OF THE
BATTLE.
BELIEVE ME.
>> BETTER TODAY.
LET'S GO.
>> GROUND BALL, LET'S GO, BABY.
>> HE AIN'T FOOLING NOBODY.
I KNOW.
TOLD ME YESTERDAY.
TAKE IT EASY.
I GOT YOU.
>> YOU KNOW, BRO.
>> WHOA!
>> HOW YOU DOING, BABY?
>> I'M GOOD, I'M GOOD.
>> HOW YOU DOING?
YOU MIC'D UP TOO?
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO SAY?
>> HE'S MIC'D UP.
>> WHY IS HE DOING THE FLEX ON A
SINGLE?
FLEXING ON A SINGLE.
>> AWAY FROM EVERYBODY TODAY.
I DON'T WANT NOBODY CLOSE TO ME
TODAY.
>> LET'S GO, BUCKS.